hey everyone welcome to this docker fill
course video by simply learn
in this full course we will learn
everything about docker in detail we
will begin this full course video with
what docker is then we will look into
the services and components of docker in
detail next we will see what docker
container is and what are the basic
commands of a docker container then we
will focus on docker swarm and docker
compose after that we will discuss
everything about docker networking then
we will see how to install docker on
ubuntu and windows 10. next we will talk
about 12 crucial docker interview
questions and answers for beginners and
experienced candidates finally we will
conclude this video by discussing the
differences between the two famous tools
which are
docker and kubernetes
by the end of this video i can assure
you that all your docker career related
queries will have been answered for this
training with me i have our experienced
docker expert massive and akel
together we will take you through the
various topics of docker so let's start
with an exciting video on the
configuration management tool before we
begin make sure to subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit that bell icon
to never miss an update from simply
learn hello this is matthew from simply
learn and today we're going to cover
what is docker and why it should be of
value to you as somebody who works in
devops
so let's take a little scenario of a
developer and a tester before you had
the world of docker a developer would
actually build their code and then they
send it to the tester but then the code
wouldn't work on their system the code
doesn't work on the other system due to
the differences in computer environments
so what could be the solution to this
well you could go ahead and create a
virtual machine to be the same of the
solution in both areas we think docker
is an even better solution so let's kind
of break out what the main big
differences are between docker and
virtual machines as you can see between
the left and the right hand side both
look to be very similar what you'll see
however is that on the docker side what
you'll see as a big difference is that
the guest os for each container has been
eliminated docker is inherently more
lightweight but provides the same
functionality as a virtual machine so
let's step through some of the pros and
cons of a virtual machine versus docker
so first of all a virtual machine
occupies a lot more memory space on the
host machine in contrast docker occupies
significantly less memory space the boot
up time between both is very different
docker just boots up faster the
performance of the docker environment is
actually better and more consistent than
the virtual machine docker is also very
easy to set up and very easy to scale
the efficiencies therefore a much higher
with a docker environment versus a
virtual machine environment and you'll
find it is easier to port docker across
multiple platforms than a virtual
machine finally the space allocation
between docker and a virtual machine is
significant when you don't have to
include the guest os you're eliminating
a significant amount of space and the
docker environment is just inherently
smaller so after docker as a developer
you can build out your solution and send
it to a tester as long as we're all
running in the docker environment
everything will work just great so let's
step through what we're going to cover
in this presentation we're going to look
at the devops tools and where docker
fits within that space we'll examine
what docker actually is and how docker
works and then finally we'll step
through the different components of the
docker environment so what is devops
devops is a collaboration between the
development team the operation team
allowing you to continuously deliver
solutions and applications and services
that both delight and improve the
efficiency of your customers if you look
at the venn diagram that we have here on
the left hand side we have development
on the right hand side we have operation
and then there's a crossover in the
middle and that's where the devops team
sits if we look at the areas of
integration between both groups
developers are really interested in
planning code building and testing and
operations want to be able to
efficiently deploy operate a monitor
when you can have both groups
interacting with each other on these
seven key end elements then you can have
the efficiencies of an excellent devops
team so planning in codebase we use
tools like jit and geara for building we
use gradle and maven testing we use
selenium the integration between dev and
ops is through tools such as jenkins and
then the deployment operation is done
with tools such as docker and chef
finally nagios is used to monitor the
entire environment so let's step deeper
into what docker actually is so docker
is a tool which is used to automate the
deployment of applications in a
lightweight container so the application
can work efficiently in different
environments now it's important to note
the container is actually a software
package that consists of all the
dependencies required to run the
application so multiple containers can
run on the same hardware the containers
are maintained in isolated environments
they're highly productive and they're
quick and easy to configure so let's
take an example of what docker is by
using a house that may be rented for
someone using airbnb so in the house
there are three rooms and only one
cupboard and kitchen and the problem we
have is that none of the guests are
really ready to share the cupboard and
kitchen because every individual has a
different preference when it comes to
how the cupboard should be stocked and
how the kitchen should be used this is
very similar to how we run software
applications today each of the
applications could end up using
different frameworks so you may have a
framework such as rails perfect and
flask and you may want to have them
running for different applications for
different situations this is where
docker will help you run the
applications with the suitable
frameworks so let's go back to our
airbnb example so we have three rooms
and a kitchen and cupboard how do we
resolve this issue well we put a kitchen
and cupboard in each room we can do the
same thing for computers docker provides
the suitable frameworks for each
different application and since every
application has a framework with a
suitable version this space can also
then be utilized for putting in software
and applications that are long and since
every application has its own framework
and suitable version the area that we
had previously stored for a framework
can be used for something else now we
can create a new application in this
instance a fourth application that uses
its own resources you know what with
these kinds of abilities to be able to
free up space on the computer it's no
wonder docker is the right choice so
let's take a closer look to how docker
actually works so when we look at docker
and we call something docker we're
actually referring to the base engine
which actually is installed on the host
machine that has all the different
components that run your docker
environment
if we look at the image on the left hand
side of the screen you'll see the
information about the infrastructure and
it's using this rest api as that
communication channel the docker server
then would check out the requests and
the interaction necessary for it to be
the docker daemon which runs on the
server itself will then check out the
interaction and the necessary operating
system pieces needed to be able to run
the container okay so that's just an
overview of the docker engine which is
probably where you're going to spend
most of your time but there are some
other components that form the
infrastructure for docker let's dig into
those a little bit deeper as well so
what we're going to do now is break out
the four main components that comprise
of the docker environment the four
components are as follows the docker
client and server which we've already
done a deeper dive on docker images
docker containers and the docker
registry so if we look at the structure
that we have here on the left hand side
you see the relationship between the
docker client and the docker server and
then we have the rest api in between now
if we start digging into that rest api
particularly the relationship with the
docker daemon on the server we actually
have our other elements that form the
different components of the docker
ecosystem so the docker client is
accessed from your terminal window so if
you are using windows this can be
powershell on mac it's going to be your
terminal window and it allows you to run
the docker daemon and the registry
service when you have your terminal
window open so you can actually use your
terminal window to create instructions
on how to build and run your docker
images and containers if we look at the
images part of our registry here we
actually see that the image is really
just a template with the instructions
used for creating the containers which
you use within docker the docker image
is built using a file called the docker
file and then once you've created that
docker file you'll store that image in
the docker hub or registry and that
allows other people to be able to access
the same structure of a docker
environment that you've created the
syntax of creating the image is fairly
simple it's something that you'll be
able to get your arms around very
quickly and essentially what you're
doing is you're creating the option of a
new container you're identifying what
the image will look like what are the
commands that are needed and the
arguments for within those commands and
once you've done that you have a
definition for what your image will look
like so if we look here at what the
container itself looks like is that the
container is a standalone executable
package which includes applications and
their dependencies it's the instructions
for what your environment will look like
so you can be consistent in how that
environment is shared between multiple
developers testing units and other
people within your devops team now the
thing that's great about working with
docker is that it's so lightweight that
you can actually run multiple docker
containers in the same infrastructure
and share the same operating system this
is its strength it allows you to be able
to create those multiple environments
that you need for multiple projects that
you're working on interestingly though
within each container that container
creates an isolated area for the
applications to run so while you can run
multiple containers in an infrastructure
each of those containers are completely
isolated they're protected so that you
can actually control how your solutions
work there now as a team you may start
off with one or two developers on your
team but when a project starts becoming
more important and you start adding in
more people to your team you may have 15
people that are offshore you may have 10
people that are local you may have 15
consultants that are working on your
project you have a need for each of
those developers or each person on your
team to have access to that docker image
and to get access to that image we use
the docker registry which is an open
source server-side servers for hosting
and distributing the images that you
have defined you can also use docker
itself as its own default registry and
docker hub now something it has to be
very mind though is that for publicly
shared images you may want to have your
own private images in which case you
would do that through your own registry
so once again public repositories can be
used to host the docker images which can
be accessed by anyone and i really
encourage you to go out to docker and
see the other docking images that have
been created because there may be tools
there that you can use to speed up your
own development environments now you
will also get to a point where you start
creating environments that are very
specific to the solutions that you are
building and when you get to that point
you'll likely want to create a private
repository so you're not sharing that
knowledge with the world in general now
the way in which you connect with the
docker registry is through simple pull
and push commands that you run through
terminal window to be able to get the
latest information so if you want to be
able to build your own container what
you'll start doing is using the pull
commands to actually pull the image from
the docker repository and the command
line for that is fairly simple in
terminal window you would write docker
pull and then you put in the image name
and any tags associated with that image
and use the command pools so in your
terminal window you would actually use a
simple line of command once you've
actually connected to your docker
environment and that command will be
docker pull with the image name and any
associated tags around that image what
that will then do is pull the image from
the docker repository
whether that's a public repository or a
private one now in reverse if you want
to be able to update the docker image
with a new information you do a push
command where you take the script that
you've written about the docker
container that you defined and push it
to the repository and as you can imagine
the commands for that are also fairly
simple in terminal window you would
write docker push the image name any
associated tags and then that would then
push that image to the docker repository
again either a public or a private
repository so if we recap the docker
file creates a docker image that's using
the build commands a docker image then
contains all the information necessary
for you to be able to execute the
project using the docker image any user
can run the code in order to create a
docker container and once a docker image
is built it's uploaded to a registry or
to a docker hub where it can be shared
across your entire team and from the
docker hub users can get access to the
docker image and build their own new
containers hello and welcome to
simplyline in this session we're going
to cover what kubernetes is and why you
would want to be using it within your
devops team but before we get started
remember to hit the like button if you
like this video and the subscribe button
if you want to get notified about more
of these videos as they come out and as
always if you have any comments about
the content that we're covering or
questions that you have on the subject
please post them in the comments below
so let's get started we're going to
break up this presentation into four key
areas we're going to talk about life
before kubernetes which some of you are
probably experiencing right now what is
kubernetes the benefits that kubernetes
brings to you particularly if you are
using containers in a devops environment
and then finally we're going to break
down the architecture and working
infrastructure for kubernetes so you
understand what's happening and why the
actions are happening the way that they
are so let's jump into our first section
of life before kubernetes so the way
that you have done work in the past
where you may be doing work right now is
really building out and deploying
solutions into two distinct areas one is
a traditional deployment where you're
pushing out code to physical servers in
a data center and you're managing the
operating system and the code that's
actually running on each of those
servers another environment that you may
potentially be using is to buying code
out to virtual machines so let's go
through and look at the two different
types of deployment that you may be
experiencing when you have applications
running on multiple machines you run
into the potential risk that the setup
and configuration of each of those
machines isn't going to be consistent
and your code isn't going to work
effectively and there may be issues with
uptime and errors within the
infrastructure of your entire
environment there's going to be problems
with resource allocation and you're
going to have area issues where
applications may be running effectively
and not not effectively and not load
balance um effectively across the
environment the problem that you have
with this kind of infrastructure is that
it gets very expensive uh you can only
install one piece of software one
service on one piece of hardware so your
hardware is being massively under
utilized this is where virtual machines
have become really popular with a
virtual machine you're able to have
better resource utilization and
scalability at much less cost and this
allows you to be able to run multiple
virtual machines on a single piece of
hardware the problem is is that vms or
for virtual machines are not perfect
either some of the challenges you run
with vms is that the actual hardware and
software need needed to manage the vm
environment can be expensive there are
security risks with virtual with vms
there are security risks with vms there
have been data breaches recorded about
solutions that run in virtualized
environments you also run into an issue
of availability and this is largely
because you can only have a finite
number of virtual machines running on a
piece of hardware and this results in
limitations and restrictions in the
types of environment you want to be
running and then finally setting up and
managing a virtualized environment is
time consuming it can take a lot of time
and it can also get very expensive so
how about kubernetes well kubernetes is
a tool that allows you to manage
containerized deployment of solutions
and inherently kubernetes is a tool that
is really a next level maturity of
deployment so if you can think of your
maturity curve as deploying code in
directly to hardware in a data center
and then deploying your solutions to
virtual machines the next evolution of
that deployment is to use containers and
kubernetes so let's kind of go through
and look at the differences between a
virtual machine and kubernetes we've got
a few here that we want to highlight and
you'll get an understanding of what the
differences are between the two so first
of all with virtual machines there is
inherently security risks and what
you'll find as we get dig through the
architecture later in the presentation
is that kubernetes is inherently secure
um and this is largely because of the
legacy code the legacy of kubernetes and
where it came from we'll talk about that
in just a moment but kubernetes is
inherently secure virtual machines are
not easily portable now with that said
they they are technically portable
they're just not very easily portable
whereas with kubernetes it's working
with docker container solutions it is
extremely portable that means that you
can actually spin up and spin down and
manage your infrastructure exactly the
way that you want it to be managed and
scale it on the demands of the customers
as they're coming in to use the solution
from a time consuming point of view
kubernetes is much less time consuming
than with a
virtual machine a few other areas that
we want to kind of highlight from
differences virtual machines use much
less isolation when building out the
encapsulated environment than kubernetes
does uh for instance with a virtual
machine you have to run hypervisor on
top of the os and hardware and then
inside of the virtual machine you also
have to have the operating system as
well whereas in contrast on a kubernetes
environment because it's leveraging a
darker container and or container-like
technologies it only has to have the os
and the hardware and then inside of each
container it doesn't need to have that
additional os layer it's able to inherit
what it needs to be able to run the
application this makes the whole
solution much more flexible and allows
you to run many more containers on a
piece of hardware than versus running
virtual machines on a single piece of
hardware so as we highlighted here vms
are not as portable as kubernetes and
kubernetes is portable directly related
to the use of containerization and
because kubernetes is built on top of
containers it is much less time
consuming because you can actually
script and automatically allocate
resource to nodes within your kubernetes
environment because it allows the
infrastructure to run much more
effectively and much more efficiently so
this is why if we look at our evolution
of the land of time before kubernetes
why we are running into a solution where
kubernetes had to come about because the
demand for having more highly scalable
solutions that are more efficient was
just really a natural evolution of this
software deployment model that started
with pushing out code to physical
hardware and then pushing code out to
virtual machines and then needing to
have a solution much more sophisticated
kubernetes would have come about at some
point in time i'm just really glad it
came back when it did so
what is kubernetes let's let's dig into
the history of kubernetes and how it
came about so in essence kubernetes is
an open source platform that is allows
you to manage and deploy and maintain
groups of containers and the container
is something like docker and if you're
developing code you're probably already
using docker today consider kubernetes
as the tool that manages multiple docker
environments together now
we talk a lot about docker and as a
container solution with kubernetes the
reality is is that kubernetes can
actually use other container tools out
there but docker just simply is the most
popular container out there both these
tools are open source that's why they're
so popular and they just allow you to be
able to have flexibility in being able
to scale up your solutions and they were
designed for the post-digital world that
we live and exist in today so a little
bit of background a little bit of trivia
around kubernetes so kubernetes was
originally a successor to a project at
google and the original project was
googleborg googleborg it does exactly
what kubernetes and does today but
kubernetes was rewritten from the ground
up and then released as an open source
project in 2014 so that people outside
of google could take advantage of the
power of kubernetes containerization
management tools and today it is managed
by the cloud native computing foundation
and there are many many companies that
support and manage kubernetes so for
instance if you're signing up for
microsoft azure aws google cloud all of
them will leverage kubernetes and it's
just because
so let's kind of step through some of
the key benefits that you'd experience
from kubernetes and so we have nine key
benefits and the first is highly
portrayed similarly beyond open source
code and this means that you can
actually go ahead and contribute to this
code project if you want to through
github the ability to scale up the
solution is incredible um what's the the
history of kubernetes being part of a
google project for managing the google
network and infrastructure
kind of really sets the groundwork for
having a solution that is highly
scalable the
out of the high scalability also comes
the need for high availability and this
is the desire to be able to have a
highly efficient and highly energized
environment that also you can really
rely on so if you're building out a
kubernetes management
environment you know that it's going to
be available for the solutions that
you're maintaining and it's really
designed for deployment so you can
script out the environment and actually
have it as part of your devops model so
you can scale up and meet the demands of
your customer then what you'll find is
that the um load balancing is extremely
efficient and it allows you to
distribute the load efficiently across
your entire network so your network
remains stable and then also the tool
allows you to manage the orchestration
of your storage so you can have local
storage such as an ssd on the hardware
that the kubernetes is
maintaining or if the kubernetes
environment is pulling storage from a
public cloud such as azure or aws you
can actually go ahead and make that
available to your entire system and you
can inherit the security that goes back
and forth between the cloud environments
and one of things you'll find consistent
with kubernetes is that it is designed
for a cloud-first uh environment um
kubernetes as well is that it's it's
really a self-healing environment so if
something happens or something fails
kubernetes will detect that failure and
then either restart the process kill the
process or replace it and then because
of that you also have automated rollouts
and rollbacks in case uh you need to be
able to manage the state of the
environment and then finally uh you have
automatic bin packaging so you can
actually specify the compute power
that's being used from cpu and ram for
each container so let's dig into the
final area which is the actual
kubernetes architecture i'm going to
cover this at a high level there's
actually another video that you can
that simply learn has developed which
digs deeper into the kubernetes
architecture and so the kubernetes
architecture is a clustered-based
architecture and it's really about two
key areas you have the kubernetes master
which actually controls um and all of
the activities within your entire
kubernetes infrastructure and then you
have nodes um that actually are running
on linux machines um outs that are
controlled by the master so let's kind
of go through some of these um areas so
if we look at the kubernetes master uh
to begin with um then we'll start with
uh etc is this is a tool that allows for
the configuration of information and the
management of nodes within your cluster
and one of the key features that you'll
find with all of the tools that are
managed within either a the master
environment or within a node is that
they are all accessible via the api
server um and what's interesting about
the api server is that it's a restful
based infrastructure which means that
you can actually secure each connection
with ssl and other
security models to ensure that your
entire infrastructure and the
communication going back and forth
across your infrastructure is tightly
secured scheduler goes ahead and
actually as you'd expect it actually um
manages the schedule of activities
within the actual cluster and then you
have the control and the controller is a
daemon server that actually manages and
pushes out the instructions to all of
your nodes so uh the other tools really
are the
the infrastructure and the and you can
consider them the administration side um
of the master whereas controller is the
management actually pushes out all of
the controls via the api server so let's
actually dig into
one of the actual nodes themselves and
there are three key areas of the nodes
one is the docker environment which
actually helps and manage and maintain
the container that's actually inside
of the node and then you have the
kubelet which is responsible for
information that goes back and forth and
it's going to do most of the
conversation with the api server on the
actual health of that node and then you
have the actual kubernetes proxy which
actually runs the services actually
inside of the node so as you see all of
these infrastructures are extremely
lightweight and designed to be very
efficient and very available for your
infrastructure and so here's a quick
recap of the different tools that are
available and it really breaks down into
two key areas you have your kubernetes
master and the kubernetes node the
kubernetes master has the instructions
of what's going to happen within your
kubernetes infrastructure and then it's
going to push out those in structure to
an indefinite number of nodes that will
allow you to be able to scale up and
scale down your solution in a dynamic
way welcome to all our viewers i'm
anjali from simply learn and today i'll
be taking you through the installation
process for docker so before we begin
let me give you an intro to docker so
what is docker docker is a tool which is
used to automate the deployment of
applications in lightweight containers
so when i say containers i mean a
software package that consists of all
the dependencies required to run the
particular application and when you
deploy containers you're basically
providing the capability for the
application to run in any kind of
environment so dockers have multiple
features some of which are that multiple
containers can run on the same hardware
it has very high productivity when
compared to virtual machines it
maintains isolated applications and has
a very quick and easy configuration
process so now let's begin with the demo
we'll be installing docker on an ubuntu
system so this is my system i'll just
opened the terminal so the first thing
you can start with is removing any
docker installation that you probably
already have present in your system if
you want to start from scratch so this
is the command to do so sudo apt get
remove
docker
docker engine docker dot io enter your
password
and docker is removed so now we'll start
from scratch and we'll install docker
once again
before that i'll just clear my screen
okay so before i install docker let me
just ensure that all the softwares on my
system currently is in its latest state
so sudo apt get update
great so that's done next thing we'll
actually install our docker
so type in sudo apt
get
install
docker
now as you can see here there's an error
that's occurred
so sometimes it's possible that due to
the environment of the machine that
you're working in this particular
command does not work in which case
there is always another command that you
can start with
just type docker install
and that by itself will give you the
commands you can use to install docker
so as it says here sudo apt install
docker dot io is a command that we will
need to execute to install docker
and after that we'll execute the suros
snap install docker so sudo apt install
docker dot io first
and this will install your docker
after that's done we will have
sudo snap install docker so snap install
docker installs a newly created snap
package
there are basically some other
dependencies for docker that you'll have
to install
of course since this is the installation
process for the entire docker io
it will take some time
great so our docker is installed the
next thing we do as i mentioned earlier
is that we need to install all the
dependency packages so the command for
that is
sudo snap install docker
enter your password
so with that we have completed the
installation process for docker but
we'll perform a few more stages where we
will test if the installation has been
done right
so before we move on with the testing
for docker let's once again just check
the version that we have installed
so for that the command is docker
version
and as you can see docker version
17.12.1 ce has been installed
next thing we do is we pull
an image from the docker hub
so docker run
hello
world
now hello world is a docker image which
is present on the docker hub docker hub
is basically a repository that you can
find online so with this command the
docker image hello world has been pulled
onto your system
so let's see if it's actually present on
your system now
the command to check this
is sudo docker images
and as you can see here hello world
repository
this is present on our system currently
so the image has been successfully
pulled onto the system
and this means that our docker is
working
now we'll try out another command
sudo docker ps minus a
this displays all the containers that
you have pulled so far so as you can see
here there are three hello world images
displayed and all of them are in exited
state so i did this demo previously to
which is why the two hello worlds which
is created two minutes ago is also
displayed here and the first hello world
which has been created a minute ago is
the one we just did for this demo now as
you have probably noticed that all the
hello world images over here all these
containers are in the exited state so
when you give the option for docker ps
minus a where minus a stands for all it
displays all the containers whether they
are in exited or running state if you
want to see only those containers which
are in their running state you can
simply execute sudo docker ps
sudo
docker
yes
and as you can see no container is
visible here because none of them are in
running state and with that we come to
an end of our docker installation
welcome everyone to our one another demo
on which we are going to see that how
exactly we can do the installation of
docker on the windows platform
specifically on windows 10. now docker
is something which is available for most
of the operating systems different
different platforms so it supports both
the unix and the windows platform as
such so
linux through various commands we can do
the installation but in the case of
windows you have to download the exe
file and a particular installer from the
docker hub websites you can simply
google it and you will get a kind of a
link from where you will be able to
download the package so let's go to the
chrome and try to search on for the
windows string uh particular installer
you will get a link from docker hub you
download it you get the stable version
you get the edge version whichever
version you want you wish to download
you can download it so let's go back to
the chrome so here you have the docker
desktop for windows so you can go for
this table or you can go for the edge
right so you also have the comparison
that what is the difference between
these two versions right
so um
the particular edge version is something
which is getting releases every month
and uh the um stable version is getting
the releases every quarter so they are
not doing much of the changes to the
stable version as compared to the edge
there so you just have to double click
on the installer and that will help you
to do the installation of the process so
let's get started so you just click on
the get instable version so when you do
that the particular installer is going
to install now it's going to take like
around 300 mb there so that's the kind
of installed which is available so uh
once the installer is downloaded so what
you can do is that you can actually go
ahead and you can uh proceed with the
doing the double click on this installer
when you double click on that you have
to proceed with some of the steps like
you know from the gui itself you are
going to proceed with these steps so
we'll wait for 10 to 20 seconds more and
then the installer will be done and then
we can do the double click and the
installation will proceed
so another thing is that uh there is a
huge difference between the installer
like for example in case of unix the
installer is a little bit less but in
case of windows it's a gui is also
involved and there are a lot of binaries
which is available there so that's the
reason why you know the huge size is
there now it's available for free that's
for sure and it also requires the
windows 10 professional or enterprise
64-bit there so um if you are working on
some previous version of operating
systems like windows 7 and all you have
the older version called docker toolbox
so they used to call it as like docker
toolbox earlier but now they are calling
it as a docker desktop with the new
docker windows 10 support as such here
so another couple of seconds and then
the installer will be done and then we
will be able to proceed with the
installation
so let's see that how much progress is
there to the download so we'll click on
the downloads and here still we have
some particular installations or some
download going on so we'll wait for some
time and once the installation is done
then we'll go back and we'll proceed
with installation
so couple of seconds
so it's almost done so i'll just click
on this one you can go to the directory
to the downloads and you can double
click on that also but if you want to do
the installation you can click on this
one also and it will ask for the
approval yes or no you have to provide
now once that is done so um a desktop a
kind of a gui component will open there
so it will start proceeding with
installation so it's asking whether you
want to add a desktop the shortcut to
desktop so you can say okay i'm going to
click on ok so it will unpack the files
all the files which is required for
docker to successfully install that is
getting unpacked over here so it will
take some time to do the installation
because it's doing a lot of work here so
you can just wait for till the execution
of the installer to be completed and
once the installer is done you can open
your command line and start working on
the docker
so taking some time to extract the
files now it's asking us to you know do
the close and do the restart so once
that is done you will be able to proceed
further and you can just you know run
the command line and any docker command
if you can run so that will give you the
response whether the docker is installed
or not so you can see here that docker
is you know something which is installed
so you can run like docker version you
will be able to get a version of the
client when you do the restart of the
machine then at that moment of time the
docker server will also be started and
then this particular error message will
go off right now the docker daemon is
not up and running because the
installation requires a restart and when
you close on this one and go for the
restart the machine will be restarted
here so this is the way that how exactly
we can go for a docker installation and
we can go on that part welcome everyone
to this topic on docker tutorial for the
beginners here now in this one we are
going to talk about the various
components for example what is the
devops here why the devops is important
what is docker the advantages of docker
installation of docker architecture of
docker components of docker game
so these are the different things which
we are going to talk about over here now
let's start with what exactly is in
devops all about here now devops is
nothing but a collaboration between the
development and the operations teams
over here which enables continuous
delivery of the applications and
services to the end user so it's a
combination or collaboration between the
two teams development and operations
which helps us to go for a further
implementation of various processes like
continuous integration continuous
deployment continuous delivery all these
things are possible with this
collaboration over here now why exactly
docker is important for us as such
in a city far away from this one so
a developer decided to develop a tons of
software on a single vm now he can put
up applications he is having a big
server and he wants to host the the
multiple application on a single machine
but for him these virtual machine got a
crash because definitely if you are
putting up more uh different different
applications as such on the on a single
vm uh it's not able to take up that much
kind of load over there so in order to
avoid this situation how exactly he can
do the various options or what he can
implement to have this uh issue resolved
so ultimately docker is something which
is the solution of him so if he really
wants to host multiple applications
on a single virtual machine or you want
to have different different applications
then docker is the ultimate solution for
him to do that and by doing so
uh there will be no issues as such when
we talk about that the errors or the
virtual machines cannot be crashed and
but there will be no impact on the
virtual machine as such so why exactly
docker is important so let's talk about
the comparison between the docker and
virtual machine there are very few
reasons why exactly
the docker is being chosen open a
virtual machine because virtual machine
is a full-fledged component which can
take up any kind of load but some of the
reasons are still that in which case we
will be preferring the docker instead of
the virtual machine here the very first
one is the memory users so docker is
having a very less memory users because
there is no concept of guest operating
system whereas on the other hand the
virtual machines are going to take a
huge amount of ram uh resources in order
to keep that particular operating system
up and running second one performance
because uh if definitely if you have
less
utilization and the users is less the
performance will be better but for some
reason if you are taking up more
resources and you will not be able to
deliver that amount of performance as
such over there and then again we have
portability so portability is also quite
easy when we talk about the virtual
machines in case of docker it's quite
portable as compared to the virtual
machine and then the last time is that
the boot up time so virtual machine boot
time is probably in minutes but uh in
case of docker it's in seconds so if we
summarize it on this one so the memory
utilization the boot up time the
performance everything is better in case
of docker as compared to the virtual
machines
right for a classic example let's say
that what about the memory user 9gb of
memory uh you know is something if you
can see that one f2 and f3 is there so
green and red color represents the
occupied memory and the wasted memory
now
there is a particular uh utilization of
let's say that um you know a server
which is available there and uh you know
3 gb of
ram is something which is wasted and 4gb
of ram is something which is being
occupied there so app2 is using like 2gb
and then you can see that the specific
2gb of ram is occupied and 3gb is
occupied and the wasted one is 1gb so
vm can see over there that you know 9 gb
of ram is used and the remaining 6 gb of
uh unused ram cannot be reused here
because if for example i allocate like 4
gb of ram to the virtual machine it's
there itself it it gets locked on so
it's not like okay uh i'm using only 4
gb ram out of this
9 gb of ram then the next
5 gb of ram will be totally wasted so
you cannot reuse it for any purpose
so this is a problem with the virtual
machine that if you allocate some memory
to the uh specific virtual machine if
you are not using that much uh resources
or that much memory the remaining memory
will be simply wasted because this is
hardcorely allocated to virtual machine
and you cannot utilize this unused
memory as such over there so this is the
limitation from the memory perspective
but in case of docker definitely if you
know out of the 9gb of ram if we are
using uh only 3gb of ram
so whatever the unused memory is there
so we can actually use it to for the new
containers so it's not dedicatedly
allocated to the virtual machines if you
are using uh
out of 9gb gb if you're using 1gb 2gb
3gb or 4gb whatever the remaining
memory is available that you can simply
use it for the other containers also
this ensures that you always go for an
optimal utilization of your resources
and unnecessarily there is no wastage of
the different different resources or the
different components over here in this
one so that's the reason why the docker
containers are quite uh efficient in
terms of memory when we compare it with
the virtual machine next one is a
performance now um in a virtual machine
we know that you know on the
infrastructure on the physical
infrastructure on top of that you put up
a kind of operating system a base
operating system is there and then on
top of that you have the hypervisor and
this hypervisor then is used to create
the virtual machines which is having a
kind of guest operating system inside it
now the issue over here is that you have
two operating systems over here so the
guest operating system is also going to
take some particular resources and uh
for example a memory or a space a
processor so in every terms in every
source terms it is going to
[Music]
go ahead and say that okay i'm going to
use the uh particular some of the
resources now problem is
that if you're hosting a very small
application you will end up in having a
more consumption because of this guest
operating system will take more more of
the resources and then you are just
using some small very small resources
for your application in an uh real world
so docker container on the other hand
does not have a concept of the guest
operating system and that's where
what happens that the docker engine is
more than sufficient to handle the
docker containers and inside the docker
containers there is the application
which is being hosted over there now
with this one definitely the performance
is quite better as compared to any
virtual machine because of the terms
that there is no unnecessarily wasted of
the resources because in the previous
case virtual machines a full-fledged
guest operating system is up and running
you need some resources to be allocated
to that but in case of containers you
don't need to have that particular
functionality implemented then
portability so um you know having a
portability or moving an application
which works on a system a does not means
that it will work on the system b also
this is a similar problem which we face
that you know the usually the
application works perfectly fine in a
lower environment and when it goes to
the production environment it sometimes
fails and uh it does not comes up
properly so this isn't portability issue
which we have when we talk about the
virtual machines but when in case of
containers when we got a container up
and running in a lower environment and
once the container is prepared you don't
have to do the changes on modification
to that depending on the environment the
same container can be deployed in
production environment and it's very
easy so whatever container prepared in
the lower environment in a dev
environment the same will work in
production environment without any
issues because it contains all the
dependencies and executables everything
inside it so you don't have to do any
kind of modifications or changes to
these containers as such over here and
the last one is the boot up time so
the boot up time of the virtual machines
is in minutes and whereas the boot up
time of uh the
docker containers is in
seconds or probably in milliseconds so
these are the reason why we consider the
virtual machine as an uh resources
based uh environment but on the other
hand docker is something which is quite
light and fast as compared to virtual
machines so let's see that what exactly
is in docker all about here so in this
one you can see uh we have the physical
infrastructure on which we have
the host operating system now we don't
have the hypervisor and the guest
operating system instead of that we have
the docker engine which is taking care
of managing the docker containers and
inside these docker containers you have
the applications and all the required
binaries and the libraries here so there
is no concept of the gift operating
system these docker engine is the uh
person or is the process which is taking
care of all the requests which is going
on and if this docker engine is up and
running then all the containers will
also be accessible and will be available
now docker is nothing but a os level
virtualization
software platform that enables
developers and id administrators to
create deploy and run applications in a
docker container with all its
dependencies so docker is a very
important tool nowadays if you want to
look forward to the host your
application because of its portability
uh benefit that you don't require much
of the changes uh depending on the
platform or depending on the environment
so whatever the developers are able to
build up the same thing will go till the
production environment now let's talk
about what exactly is in docker
container here now docker container is a
lightweight software package
that includes all the dependencies
whether it's a base operating system
some framework some libraries it's it's
something which is a part of this one so
that if you will be uh if you want to
host your application you will be able
to do that so it's a complete package so
both the source code and the
dependencies is what you put up inside
the docker containers
now
within these docker containers you can
have multiple applications there
multiple programming languages multiple
frameworks can be hosted there in fact
the databases also can be hosted within
these docker containers you can host
them as such over there now one of the
different advantages of docker let's
talk about that now the first one is the
rapid deployment so rapid deployment is
the very first advantages which we are
getting over here second
quick and easy configuration
better efficiency
portability
scalability and security over here now
there are different ways in which we can
understand the uh benefits or we can
have the understanding about the docker
here
so uh these are some couple of uh
benefits now let's take up uh take them
one by one the for the first one is the
deployment part so uh it's it supports
the rapid deployment now
just like a web application for instance
i want to deploy to website so there are
some couple of steps which
needs to be done across different
different environments like for example
if i have five environments i have to do
the deployment the same steps in all the
five environments at the different
period of time now when we talk about
docker containers we don't have to run
those steps multiple times because once
those steps are executed in one docker
container the same docker container goes
till the production environment so you
don't have to actually do a rebuild of
the docker containers and you can simply
say that okay i have got the docker
container here so you can just run one
or two couple of commands and that will
help you to host your docker containers
so you don't have to redo or rework on
any kind of the deployment work into the
production environment or into the
higher environments and then we goes for
the quick and easy configurations so the
configurations of docker containers is
quite easy you can have your own custom
docker images built out the docker files
so these processes can be integrated
within the jenkins also so cicd is quite
possible with the help of docker if you
want to really do that and
then we have better efficiency yes they
have a better efficiency and
resources management as compared to the
virtual machines portability uh we have
already thought about that that it's
easy to move from one environment from
one system to another in fact it's easy
from the developer also so from one
machine from one developer to another
developer it's very easy to move these
uh different docker containers then we
have scalability
scalability is also possible with this
docker containers just like multiple
virtual machines you can also create
multiple containers and you can share
the traffic out of that so but that
scalability and all is possible with the
orchestration tools uh then security is
there so
you can have your best practices of the
security implemented because um it's
just a kind of a virtualization just
like a virtual machine so you have all
the uh different uh possibilities which
is available which you can explore when
you talk when you want to make these
stock containers secure right so these
were some of the benefits which was
there for the docker here now let's talk
about the installation of docker here
now installation of docker is pretty
common and uh whatever platform you want
it's available over there so it's
available for ubuntu windows
it's available for mac operating system
so for ubuntu you have to run the
commands on the ubuntu part operating
system to download it and for windows
it's actually having a
particular exe file so you can go for
the installation of exe file and then we
have the mac operating system so for mac
operating system you have the dmg files
and when you do the dmg file so it will
uh help you to install the
component over there so mac you can also
use the home view wants to do the
installation of that particular
component now next one is the
architecture of docker
now the architecture of docker is pretty
straightforward there are key components
which is available there in the
architecture of docker here the very
first one is the as the client facing is
the docker client now docker client or
you can say that docker cli is available
there now this is the component it's a
command line interface which takes up
the request from the end user like for
example i'm running the command so
it will take all the requests from me as
an end user and it will send those uh
particular uh things or the requirements
to the docker daemon to the server using
the rest api interface so this docker
daemon is something which keeps on
running on the server and it's a
background process it gets deployed as
in service there in case this docker
demon is not available or it's not up
and running you will not get the proper
response from the docker command line
here so in order to get all your
activity or your
procedures implemented you need to have
the docker server or docker daemon up
and running in fact this docker cli can
be configured to connect to any other
servers or any other different server
docker daemon also so it's a
connectivity which is happening over the
rest api interface where all the
requests are processed are sent to the
docker demon and whatever response is
coming back that is given back to the
end user so what are the different
components of docker here let's talk
about that so docker client consists of
the cli company uh like we have already
discussed so that is something which is
uh going to take up all the requests
from the end user then um it's using the
rest api interface which is there to
have the connectivity with the docker
daemon so docker daemon is uh something
uh which is always up and running so if
you run couple of commands like docker
pull push and also that activity you are
actually sending the request to the
docker demon and docker daemon is
actually doing all the work so it's not
a docker client which is doing it just
taking its kind of interface which will
take the things up and send it back or
send it forward to the docker day right
so it's a background process which keeps
on running on the server on the
operating system and uh it's it's the
same process across all the
infrastructure all the different
platforms whether you use mac operating
system you use windows or you use linux
everywhere this is the basic
functionality and it keeps on listening
to the rest api interface so uh whatever
the request new request comes in it
immediately process it and whatever the
response whether you are stopping a
container whether you you're running a
container according to that the action
will be taken and the response will be
sent back to the rest api to the docker
client so a docker is a process or it's
a command line which is used to start
the docker daemon
when you run the command like service
docker status on the server you will be
able to see the command which is getting
executed in the back end so there you
can see that uh docker is the process or
is the command line which is used to
initialize the docker daemon and of
course there is a kind of configurations
which you have to pass it on as a
parameters so even if you run psiphony
of command you will be able to know that
what process is running from the docker
perspective and the third component is a
a particular docker registry so we have
a ready-made uh cloud service which is
available known as the docker hub so you
can actually store the docker images on
these docker registry so there are a lot
of ready-made uh docker images which is
available there but of course you can
have your own docker image also over
there or you want you can have your own
custom uh registry docker registries
also for example in jfrog you can have
your private hosted registries also so
all these are different repositories you
can use with your docker containers so
docker containers is having the
flexibility that whichever registries or
repositories you want to connect or you
want to establish the connectivity you
can always do that now let's talk about
the docker image over here
in detail
now a docker image is nothing but a
template of instructions
it's having a couple of instructions in
which you will be using these
instructions to create a final dock
container so docker image is nothing but
uh for example i want to have a tomcat
apache docker image so what are the
instructions i have to do so the very
first thing is that i have to pick up a
base operating system then on top of
that i will be installing the jdk or
some prerequisite packages and then on
top of that we will be configuring on to
the tonkit apache there so these are the
steps these are the different
instructions step by step procedure
which we are implementing so that at the
end of the
activity we will be able to have a
docker container ready which we can
deploy to host tomcat apache so it's a
template which is having all the uh
particular instructions in order to
build a docker image you require a file
called dockerfile which is uh of course
having all these different uh
instructions embedded in that so when
you run the dockerfile it acts like a
build tool so whatever the instructions
you are putting up over there all those
instructions are getting uh processed
and you are able to get a end result
then these docker images are actually
comprised of multiple layers so multiple
layers are available there so step by
step so you will be first of all having
a base layer from which the image starts
on top of that another layer for example
you did the installation of jdk so
another layer will be there and then you
did the configuration
of the term kit apache and then another
layer will be there so it's a
multi-layered in
component which is available and these
layers are in incremental order so
definitely the oldest one will be known
as the base layer and then on top of
that all the latest changes will be done
in the latest layers there so this is an
example now here you can see that uh
there are four instructions and these
four instructions are also known as the
four layer docker image so whatever the
final docker image you will get in there
you will be able to see four layers of
uh the uh docker image here now the very
first is ubuntu so ubuntu 18.04 we are
pulling up and then we are pulling like
uh the file over here and uh then we are
running the make utility
and uh once that is done then we are
running that file dot uh python file
over here in this one so these are four
instructions which is available right so
uh which will definitely help us to do
that how exactly we can make or we can
perform the different activities right
from the base so in this case the base
layer will be like uh the one two one so
one two one will be the base image and
the moment the final cmd attribute or
cmd
attributions are processed and executed
after that you will be able to get a
final full-fledged docker image over
there so this will be a full uh complete
docker image or docker container which
you will get once the whole build
process is completed
now in this case you have
you can see that the previous docker
file which we processed so the base
layer is ubuntu 18.04 we are not
building that actually it's
automatically so it's by default getting
downloaded as in full base layer after
that only we have like layer 1 layer 2
layer 3 added up because those
modifications we are doing it after the
because from does not means that you are
doing any kind of layer modifications
it's just like you are importing some
base operating system or base image so
the modification or adding up the layers
is only done after the base layer there
so whenever a user creates a container a
new uh layer is something which is
stopped on top of the image these layers
are known as the
containers layers so one to one the very
first instruction does not comprises it
is it's not a kind of container layer we
can call it as an base image layer there
so every container has a separate read
write container layer and any
modification in a container is reflected
upon the container layers only so layer
one may be having some different of uh
instructions later maybe having
different instructions so like that is a
step-by-step processor
in case
you know whenever a container is deleted
the top layer also gets deleted over
there in that one so if i delete some
particular containers and that is
something which is gone so it was
supposed having like three layers so the
top layer will be simply deleted because
the container is also deleted for that
particular part now docker uses a copy
and write strategy with both docker
images and docker containers so
whenever we uh perform any activity or
whenever copy on
write strategies and strategy to share
and copy files for better efficiency so
it's something which is being used to
increase the overall performance of the
docker containers it also makes docker
efficient by reducing the uses of disk
space because whenever uh required okay
whenever is needed only at that moment
of time it's actually performing the
copy and uh it definitely reduces the
overall disk utilization and this is
very important also because when you
have so many docker containers up and
running so you have to worry or you have
to make the utilization of a disk or
your disk users or resources also
minimum so that is also you need to make
sure that it does not exceed a
particular value
so once the utilization is also less
then definitely the overall performance
will also be better and improved over
here in this case
so uh let's talk about some of the facts
here so the base layers are something
which is purely read-only format so you
cannot do the modifications union file
system saves the memory uh you know by
avoiding the duplications of the files
uh the layers can be combined in a union
file system to create a single image so
all these mail layers are combined and
got a final product or called a you know
you can call it as docker image or
docker containers
and this allows a file system to appear
as a write table uh which is known as
copy on right so copy and write strategy
is being used so to do the changes or to
do the perform the modifications to this
union file system while creating the
different different layers
so
now let's talk about the docker testing
very important component because even if
you prepare the docker image locally and
you don't have the collaborative tool or
you don't have the uh tool where you can
share these images definitely it's not
easy for you to port these docker images
from one system to another so docker
registry is very important for the
portability feature of docker so docker
registry is a service to host and
distribute docker images among users so
uh it can be built up by one user and
multiple users can use it for example
i'm using a jenkins one so
jenkins uh image is prepared only once
but it's being used by different people
as such docker registry uh again it's a
repository is a collection of docker
images so in a repository you will be
having like different different uh
docker images as such
so in registry a user can distinguish
between the docker images with their tag
names so
for example jenkins is an a kind of a
single image there might be different
type of images there let's say that okay
let's talk about uh jenkins uh jdk8 so
there will be image called jenkins the
name of the image will be same but the
tags will be different so one tag could
be like jdk8 one tag would be like jk9
and one tag would be dedicated so the
difference between all these three
docker images is that that jdk81 is
prepared on gdk8 it's running on jdk8
and if you want to use jtk9 in that case
you have to pull down the the docker
image of jenkins with the jdk 9
installed so depending on the frameworks
or depending on the runtimes so with
these tags different tags are processed
so you can have the distinguished
between the
docker images and whichever docker image
you feel you want to use you can
implement according to your requirement
and uh docker
by default is having its own uh
cloud-based registry called as docker
hub which gets automatically connected
when the moment you do the docker
installation but in case you are working
into your private infrastructure so in
that case uh you may use the
repositories uh docker repositories on
the uh specific jfrog artifactory or the
private repositories also can be hosted
but docker hub is something which is
having a public and private repositories
both so you can create either the public
and private repositories you can use uh
push and pull activities to interact
with these docker images you want to
download a docker image so you can run
pull if you want to push your docker
image to the docker registry in that
case you can run the push activity so in
both the cases you are doing the
interaction with the docker hub so when
you run some build process or when you
run the containers there may be some
docker containers which is getting
pulled down from the
specific registry from the docker hub
and uh if that specific image and tag is
available definitely pull command will
be successful but in case of push
command you are pushing your custom
docker images uh you cannot push the
ready-made docker images which is
available you can
publish your own docker image only to
the docker hub and then you can further
on do the poll and push activity
accordingly to those repositories so
whatever the ready-made and third-party
images which is available you can only
do the pull activities to them you
cannot do the push activities push
command scenario will only come when you
are looking when you are interacting
with your custom docker image next one
is the docker container now docker
container is an executable package of an
application and its dependencies
together so when we prepare a docker
container we actually combine both the
dependencies and the
application source code inside it so the
docker container don't have to look for
the dependencies on the host machine on
the server so this is one of the benefit
where we see that the portability is
very easy because whatever i'm building
up on one system everything is inside
the docker container so i don't really
need to do any further activity on other
machines so whatever works on one system
can be easily worked on in the system
so it's very lightweight also so it can
be easily deployed and executed on you
know on their particular uh servers
because it does not take that much
utilization like a virtual machine so if
you are looking forward for having your
application hosted into your local
system you can easily do it within the
docker container so the utilization is
very less as compared to the virtual
machine so you don't have to worry about
your operating host operating system and
the qualifications
so docker containers can run in totally
isolation just like a virtual machine so
there is no interaction or there is no
interference so they share the os called
uh kernel but uh the thing is they don't
have the interface as such over there so
it works totally in isolation uh two
different containers will not have any
interaction unless and until we do we
set up that the containers to have the
interactions
now there is uh data volumes where which
can be shared and uh be used among the
multiple containers so um you have the
uh capability over here that you know if
the there is some on
used uh space that can be easily shared
across the multiple containers here so
uh it is uh built using the docker
images so
using the docker images the docker
containers are built up and docker run
is a specific command which is used to
build a docker container so if you got a
docker image let's say that i have
prepared a docker image a custom docker
image using the docker file now if i
need to create a docker container out of
a docker image i have to run a docker
run command so docker run command is
nothing but it initializes or creates an
instance of a docker image now next
component is the docker compose
now typically when we work with the the
docker containers so we have to run like
if i want to run like five six
containers i have to initialize like
five six times or i have to run docker
and commands five six times there so um
and if you want to create a relationship
between the containers then definitely
that is something which you need to
manage using the docker commands but
sometimes it's not an easy task for you
to run those commands manually or
remember those commands so docker
compose is a utility over here using
which you can actually run multiple
containers with a single service
you just got off a kind of a single file
you just run it and all the containers
definitions and relationships everything
is inside this docker file here so you
want to run two containers that's
totally fine instead of running two
commands now you just have to run one
file and that will do take care of that
now
you may be having more than two
containers five six seven whatever
number of containers you have that can
be easily deployed without any uh manual
activity or without any maintainers onto
the server
so
these containers totally run in
isolation but yes you can establish the
interaction that how they want to
interact with each other and that
interaction you can put up in these
docker compose files so docker compose
file is something which is written in
the vml format and in this you define
that okay i need two containers and this
in this image should be there these are
the parameters which you need to run and
if you want to have the interaction or
the linkage between the images that also
you can establish within this yml files
or this in within this docker compose
file here right so let's say for example
i want to have an application which
requires apache web server and mysql
database now uh i can create a docker
compose file which can run both
containers and uh without you know you
don't require to restart or start them
separately or initialize them separately
so i will be having a final docker
compose file which is having like uh
you know containers like apache
containers and my school containers both
inside a single docker compose file here
so that's the benefit you're going to
get because now you don't have to run
them separately separate apache and
separate via mysql so you can get it
done with the help of a single docker
compose file here now what exactly is
the docker swamp now docker swamp is a
inbuilt or it's a default
uh oxygen tool which is being provided
by the docker itself it's a service uh
for containers which allows the id
administrators and the developers to
create and manage a cluster of smart
nodes so um in a typical world when you
do the installation of docker there is a
limitation that you some of the features
like high ability multiple uh instances
or scalability all these things are not
possible as it is with the core docker
now on top of that you require the
organization tools like docker swamp
where you have a swam of node machines
uh five six known machines are there on
which you can have your highly available
application infrastructure implemented
now this one means that if i want to run
my uh applications five containers six
containers and seven containers for that
purpose we are using the docker spam so
each node of docker swam is having a
docker daemon which is uh used to for
performing the interaction so there will
be a master node which is available so
uh it will be interacting with all the
known machine on the all the client
machines and these interaction will be
in such a way that it will let them know
okay i want to deploy the
container or onto the note 3 so it will
perform that activity and the container
will be up and running on the note 3
there so a swamp consists of two type of
nodes one is the manager node and button
is a worker node so manager is the
master node which you can refer
and the worker node is the one which is
actually doing most of the work so uh
the manager node is not something which
is expected to host uh anything apart
from the main component but yes
you can always configure
if you feel that you want to only deploy
the container on the worker node so that
also you can
do during the deployment of the
containers so manager will will keep on
connecting to the different worker nodes
there and whenever new request comes in
so it will basically try to connect and
see that okay i just want to go ahead
and deploy a container so it will do the
deployment of the container on the
worker node so the main work will be
done by the worker nodes and manager is
just doing the management of all these
resources the worker nodes will be
definitely receiving the request from
the manager and
it will be proceeding and performing
those activities and uh
if for some reason worker node is not
active on online so the master node will
not be able to deploy the containers on
that server so right now let's talk
about a demo in which we have to create
a docker image using a docker file on
the open220 so uh you want to use a base
operating system as an ubuntu 20 there
and using that we will we are going to
create a custom docker image
so let's connect to our virtual machine
and see that how we can do that okay so
as part of this demo here we are going
to prepare a docker image and uh in that
we are going to use a base image of
ubuntu so uh let's take an operating
system of ubuntu 220 20 is the latest
version of the ubuntu operating system
so i have got a server so let's see so
first of all we have to install the
docker.io package which will install the
docker package and then we can
enable the
service we can make sure that the docker
service is up and running because if the
service itself is down then we will not
be able to perform any activity and then
our sample if you run docker run hello
hyphen volt so that is going to pull a
docker image from the docker hub and a
particular activity will be done to you
so once that is done so we can say that
okay the container is up and running and
everything is got uh you know over there
up and running and then you can also try
some of the ubuntu docker image also if
you feel that you want to try you can do
that but the main uh demo which we need
to do over here is that we need to
prepare a custom docker image and in
this one we will be having like we will
be using an ubuntu firebase operating
system on top of that we will be
installing php and genix all these
different components so we are going to
have a php based website hosted onto the
apache web server as an nginx and then
we will be able to access that
application so the very first thing
which we need to do is that we need to
create a folder uh let's say that i just
created a particular folder called
enginex hyphen image and then i create a
docker file over there so docker file uh
content we are going to take from this
one so let's go to the server and see
that how we can go ahead with the
activity
now uh what we can do is that uh what uh
we have got a server over here
now in this server what i'm going to do
is that i'm going to proceed with the
installation of docker first now when i
do the docker installation first so what
will happen that i will be able to have
my docker installation completed and
then further on i can take the further
steps of having the accessibility of uh
going through the understanding that
what is this uh particular platform or
how to prepare different different kind
of containers so
i have got a particular container over
here so what i can really do is that i
can simply say that okay i have got a
server so this is a one-two server so
i'm going to run the command called app
update first now this will do the update
locally so all the links and everything
will be updated now the whole idea about
doing the updates is that so that i will
be able to ha establish the fact that
i'm trying to connect i'm trying to uh
connect with the ubuntu url so that at
any moment of time i should be able to
fetch on the latest packages now once
that is done so i'm going to run the
command called apt install docker dot io
now the moment i do this what will
happen that it will try to download some
packages it will ask for the
confirmation you can give your
confirmation and i can say yes the
moment you give the confirmations the
download of the packages will proceed
over here step by step it will download
the packages and the installation will
go on now once the installation is done
so what you can do is that you can see
that docker is uh deployed into your
system or not you can run docker version
command or you can also use this service
command to check to make sure to ensure
that the docker service is always up and
running if the service is not up and
running you have to make sure you have
to enable it you have to start that
service so these are some couple of
steps which you need to do in order to
make sure that your connectivity or your
environment is ready for with the docker
installation and once the docker
installation is done then only you will
be able to proceed further with the
further activities like preparing the
containers preparing the images and all
that stuff but if you don't have the
docker installed prior to that then
definitely it's going to be a problem so
just make sure that before even doing
any kind of activity before even doing
any kind of uh steps we ensure that the
docker is fully up and running so it's
going to take some time to download the
packages and we will wait for that and
once the installation is done we will
continue further on that part
okay now once the installation is done
so you can run the command call service
docker status and when you do that
it will let you know that whether the
docker service is available there or not
so uh you can start the service
in case you don't get uh the proper
response and uh now you can see that
it's showing up that a process is
running so earlier it was not uh up and
running it was inactive but now it's
active and you can see here that dark
ride is the process which is running
over here as an process to initialize
the docker daemon so docker demon is up
and running now and we are good to go
here so now uh if we go and say like
docker
run
hello hyphen vault so we are doing a
validation to our docker instance that
whether our docker instance is working
fine as expected or not because uh if
there is any kind of problem with the
docker daemon and docker demon is not up
and running properly we would be able to
get an error message over there but
right now there is no error message
which represents that
yes you are
pretty much running the docker image and
it's giving you the proper response so
you will be able to see the uh
docker images when you run so you will
be able to see that the docker image is
pulled down to your system and
definitely you have executed that and it
got you the response now the next thing
which we need to do is that we need to
run a particular
ubuntu one so for example if i go for
docker
run
hyphen t
open to bash so what exactly we are
doing in this one is that we are pulling
down a ubuntu docker image and we are
running the bash executable on top of
that the whole purpose of doing that
activity is that so that if i want to do
some
process or i want to perform some
activity i should be able to connect to
that docker image so the moment i do
this first of all if this docker image
is available locally that's great it
will immediately create the container if
the docker image is not available
locally the very first thing which it
will perform over here is to pull down
the docker image the correct one and as
you can see here that it uh definitely
pulls down the darker image and once it
is done so it got a terminal for you now
you can see it shows that root at the id
uh root at the rate of one id is there
this id is nothing but it's a container
id which we are getting here so
definitely you are inside the docker
container and when you run the docker uh
when you run the exit command you will
see that you have come out of the docker
container over here and the moment you
run docker ps hyphen a command you can
actually see also that how many
container you deployed so far so you ran
hello world you ran the one to one both
of them are stopped there you can see
the exit zero in the status over here
because both of them are something which
you ran in the interactive mode so they
are done so if you want to keep your
container up and running you need to
have a container which runs in the dash
mode and always up and running but for
that you have to go ahead to the level
where we need to create a custom docker
image and do the setup accordingly so
let's see that how we can do that now
i'm going to create a particular folder
called nginx hyphen image
you can pretty much give any name
whatever name you feel you want to
perform you can do that now in this one
i'm going to put up a file called
dockerfile so let's see that what
content we need to put as such when we
talk about the docker file because
whatever content you put over here that
is what according which the docker image
will be prepared
now here
we have to talk about so first we have
to see a base image so we are saying
that okay 0.220.0 is what i want to use
then we are giving some labels now these
labels are used to give some information
like uh what is the version who is the
maintainer
what is the description uh you can do
the customizations to this one so these
labels are actually defined and utilized
so that i will be able to give an
information that okay so and so
developer is something which we can
contact so if there is any kind of
problem with the uh docker file or will
this build script we have to reach out
to that specific person so this is what
we typically do with the labels here now
um we also have to
set up a parameter like deviant
underscore fronted as in non-interactive
because whenever we talk about any build
process in docker file it it cannot be
there in the interactive session it
should be there in the non-interactive
and definitely a typical uh scenarios
like you can run app update command and
then we are installing the php and genex
super supervisor all these things we are
doing we are doing the installation uh
we are using the run attribute run a
particular step and in there whatever
the commands are executed these
statements will be executed when we will
be doing the build process and then we
are using some environment variables
okay so engine xp virtual host php
underscore conf engine extenders for
conf and supervisor and disco conf these
are the different environment variables
which we configuring over here now next
thing which we have is that uh
we have to transfer some files like
probably nginx and the virtual host file
we may have to transfer from our linux
server to the destination to the
docker container so for that we are
going to run some copy commands copy
statements so that we can do that stuff
and uh then definitely we are
transferring the supervisor
configuration file also to the server so
that we can have that configurations uh
setup over there and uh these are config
uh supervisor underscore conf and all
these different variables we have
already established where we are seeing
that what exactly configuration we are
looking forward over here and then we
are uh you know creating some folder
structure we had www html folder
structure we are creating so that we
will be able to push some content over
there and then we have the volume
configurations so whatever the volume
configurations are there we are putting
up so that uh you know we will be able
to have all the uh specific direct
directories mounted on the host machine
on the whole server so that we can even
talk about locally also and then the
star.search is something which we need
to run because that's uh that will go
into the command statement which needs
to be executed because when you want to
run your process when you want to run
your nginx process or your docker
container some process should be up and
running that's where
if any interactive process will run then
only the docker container will be hold
up so that's what you can
do or you can configure over there so
i'm going to copy this whole content now
this whole content represents the
complete docker file so uh we have
already gone through this content one by
one but uh if we combine all these
content together till the exposed part
that's where we come up into these one
so expose we are doing 80 and 443 over
here
right after this one we have to create
the host file virtual host file
supervisor d file and the start.search
file so let's go back to the server here
now
in this one you have to uh you can use
whatever editor you feel you want to use
you can do that
so this is what i will my
master file will look like you can see
i'm running some run commands uh these
are the environment variables i'm using
then further on these variables i'm
using just to define the paths okay so
you can see that this default file we
are copying from the host machine from
the server to the docker container and
then second file is super uh wiser d not
con file and then we have star dot sh
file so these are the different files
which we want to configure here so once
this file is prepared we have to type in
or we have to create a default file over
here in this current directory so in
this current directory we have to put up
a file called default now in this one we
will be having the default virtual host
configuration config so we need to put a
server attribute
saying that we have to look forward for
index.html or index.php and these kind
of files from the www.html directory
there so i'm just going to copy this
content
and uh put it up into this one
so this is how my final file look like
so i'll save it
and uh then we have a supervisord dot
com file so
so i'll just copy the content of this
one
i'll copy it and we have to create a
file called
supervisord.confile
now names we can double check because we
are referring these names into our
docker file so
we can double check that so once this is
done
save it
and we can check the docker file we can
grab
so you can see okay this one so super
wiser d so the name is correct that's
cool so we got default we got supervisor
d now we have to create the star dot sh
file because in this one we will be
configuring that how we want to start
our process of this nginx or this web
server so in this one again we have to
run the uh supervised process over here
and a configuration file so we are going
to put this one
and we'll go here and put this content
right so we got the supervised config
also available so that's also there and
the moment is done so you are going to
give the execute permission to this one
because
you can see that into our docker file
that we are having the attribute where
we want to run this into the dots
slash there so if you want to refer in
that mode you have to change the
permissions in case that uh change mode
you have to give the execute permission
to the start.sh here now once this is
done
so what you got is that you got a
particular components like you got uh
some couple of commands you have uh you
know uh got docker file super isd.com
default all these files are there now
the only thing which we need to do next
is that we need to build to the build
process
so uh if we look forward for the build
process what happens that docker build
is the command which we need to use and
uh nginx iphone image is the name which
you want to refer now you can totally
use this uh custom name whatever name
you feel that you want to use you can
always use that there's no restriction
on that part and once that is on so you
will be able to list down those images
that you got a new custom docker image
here so you can see that you got the
ubuntu as a base image which is built
down and the nginx iphone image is also
prepared over there
and once that is done so you are going
to create a web root folder and uh you
can run the docker run command to see
that if you really got connected with
that particular one so let's go back and
uh see that how we can create
the docker custom docker image here so
the moment i do this so it will pick up
the docker file over here and start
performing the activities uh the package
installations all those configurations
ones will be performed over here in a
non-interactive mode there is no
confirmation which will be asked from
the user because you cannot put that
confirmations so the command should be
in such a way that it should not take
any kind of confirmations at all from
the
end user so because tomorrow you may be
putting up these things in the jenkins
so that will not be a feasible thing for
you to put up the commands and put up
the
confirmations during the execution so so
it's trying to run do the package
installation for the php so fbm packages
are getting installed and
here we go so we caught the
successful message now you can see it
says successfully tag this one this
means that there is no issues at all
with the docker image and when you run
the docker
images or darker images ls you can run
these two couple of commands so when you
do that you got a 203 37 mb of the size
of this image that represents that this
docker image is fully ready to run to a
secured
so now what we are going to do is that
we are going to map a volume over here
with the wwe html directory during the
execution of this container because i
really want to deploy some pages and web
pages there if you have the web pages
now as part of the build process as part
of the docker file you can do a git
clone also of some repository but i
don't want to do that uh during the
preparation of docker image i just now
got an environment where the nginx is
set up properly and it's up and running
there now it should be upon me that how
i want to put up my content and all so
that's the reason why i'm putting up a
kind of a folder structure over here and
sharing it with the docker container so
that the moment i put that the html
files or the php files into that local
folder i should be able to get some web
page up and running there so that's what
i'm going to do over here in this one so
i'm going to create a folder structure
saying slash
web root here okay so there is a folder
structure which is created now in this
web root i will be putting up some files
and then same files will be redirected
inside the docker container with the
help of docker volume so let's go back
to the document now here
you have to run uh the uh once like i
said that uh you are going to connect on
that part okay so uh you can use this
port as an at also but here it is used
so whatever port you feel you want to
use you can do that and we are giving
the container name as test and iphone
container that also you can change and
generic hyphen image is the one which we
are using so if you use some different
uh particular image you can also use
that and uh you can see that the web
root is something which we are
connecting with the wwe html directory
so the moment you put some file in the
web root the same file will be reflected
into the
ww html directory there so i'm going to
run this command and once this is done
so you can see that for the testing
purpose we are putting up some content
in the html one so i'll come to that
point also and we'll validate as of now
we should be having our container up and
running over here in this one now i'm
going to copy that command
[Music]
one of my visions is to create a
positive change in the world through art
[Music]
i couldn't stop working on photography
every single day
so um
if you've been following my journey
you've seen me jump off buildings and
planes and boats and cliffs and whatnot
but according to me my biggest jump
happened two and a half years ago when i
made the leap from the life that i was
living then to the life that you see
today
my name is sharanya ayar and i am a
full-time travel content creator and
solo travel enthusiast
[Music]
i didn't just wake up one day and become
this person in fact i had a whole
different life before the life that you
see today
i met this kind of uh dream for i don't
know if it gets the idea that you can
just wake up one day and transform far
far away open conversation with them so
you know this told them that i wasn't
just uh
quit my job i know there are still
challenges but and your talent with an
actual plan
and trust me the world the moment you do
the call now you will be able to see the
same response so whatever the things you
put up in the index.html file the same
content is going to pop up when you run
the curl command now um you want to use
some php files
today i'm a professor i like to learn
new things i paint i do calligraphy i
play guitar but
two years before i couldn't even get out
of my bed without anyone's help
my name
is 30 years of age and i am an assistant
professor at vidalankar institute of
technology wadala i'm a learner at
upgrade and i'm taking up a course of
big data engineering postgraduate
certificate program
and now
if you feel that i've got a info.php
file so i can use in that name into the
url i have to modify the url is waiting
for you about over 15 countries in these
two years or the more you get into what
you're doing
you do learn the hacks
so
ambitious combine your passion and your
talent with an actual plan
and trust me the world is waiting for
you
[Music]
the world is waiting for you
but when you put up this one into the
browser into the web browser that will
be a meaningful information probably in
terms of some tables or something like
that right so um let me scroll to the
top here so you can see that it's
showing an error sorry it's showing in
the output and this output represents
that you got a particular php content
here so this is how we will be able to
have a container and uh you know this
container is up and running you can
modify to at any level you feel that you
want to prepare a darker image with the
code embedded also
you can have the git clone or you can
have this configuration into some git
repository have the source code also
there and then
prepare a complete bundle altogether so
this is what we have in this demo how we
can deploy a container and a container
up and running in case of the docker
here
hello this is matthew from simply learn
and today we're going to cover what is a
docker container why you would want to
consider using it in your devops
environment so let's have a look at what
we have in our current environment so
today when you actually have your
standard machine you have the
infrastructure you have the host
operating system and you have your
applications and then when you create a
virtual environment what you're actually
doing is you're actually creating
virtual machines but those virtual
machines actually are now sitting within
a hypervisor solution that sits still on
top of your host operating system and
infrastructure and with a docker engine
what we're able to do is we're able to
actually reduce significantly
the different elements that you would
normally have within a virtualized
environment so we're able to get rid of
the the bins and the so we're able to
get rid of the guest os and we're able
to eliminate the hypervisor environment
and this is really important as we
actually start working and creating
environmental
system because we want to be able to
make it so it's really easy and stable
[Music]
plus size becomes a new normal
[Music]
and i started feeling represented i feel
like there are real body types out there
who are making these videos but
microsoft
worked at india
[Music]
if you've been following my journey
you've seen me jump off buildings and
planes and boats and cliffs and whatnot
but according to me my biggest jump
happened two and a half years ago when i
made the leap from the light developers
working in jboss on his system and he's
coding away and he has to get that code
over to a test and now what will happen
is that tester will then typically in
your traditional environment then have
to install jboss on their machine and
get everything running and cool and
hopefully set up identically to the
developer chances are they probably
won't have it exactly the same but
they're trying to get as close as
possible and then at some point you want
to be able to test this within your
production environment so you send it
over to a system administrator who would
then also have to install j bars on for
30 years my dad drove a truck just like
this
and he used to tell me something
make sure you study hard
you don't have any times and this is
where
things get
[Music]
that could
[Music]
it reminds us that no matter where we
live what we speak or who we pray to do
is
[Music]
some cases handle just stories doing
really basic foundational challenges so
this is where docker comes in and docker
is the tool that allows you to be able
to share environments from one group to
another group without having to install
software locally on a device you install
all of the code into your docker
container and simply share the container
so in this presentation we're going to
go through a few things we're going to
cover what docker actually is and then
we're going to dig into the actual
architecture of docker and kind of go
through what docker container is and how
to create a docker container and then
we'll go out through the benefits of
using docker containers and then the
commands and finalize everything out
with a brief demo so what is docker so
docker is as you'd expect because all
the software that we cover in this
series is an open source solution and it
is a container solution that allows you
to be able to containerize all of the
necessary files and applications needed
to run the solution
so you can share it from different
people
and this allows you to have a consistent
environment from one group to the next
so let's kind of dig into that
architecture so you understand why
docker runs effectively every week so
the docker architecture itself is built
up
you have your different containers and
each one has a link to a docker registry
the docker client itself is a rest
service so as you'd expect a rest api
and that sends command line to the
docker daemon through a terminal window
or command line interface window
and we'll go through some of these demos
later on so you can actually see how you
can actually interact with darker the
docker demo then checks the request
against and the docket components and
then performs the service that you're
requesting now the docker image itself
all it really is a collection of
instructions used to create a container
and again this is consistent with all
the devops tools that we have the devops
tools that we're looking to use
throughout this series of videos are all
environments that can be scripted and
this is really important because it
allows you to be able to duplicate and
scale the environments that you want to
be able to build very quickly and
effectively the agile container itself
has all of the applications and the
dependencies of those applications
one package
[Music]
it's a little bit more than that
[Applause]
[Music]
on multiple different solutions so say
you have a team of developers and you
have 50 developers and they're working
on five different applications you can
actually have the applications
themselves the containers shared in the
docker registry so each of those teams
at any time check out and have the
latest container of that latest image of
the code that you're working on so let's
dig into what actually is in the
container so the important part of a
docking container is that it has
everything
[Music]
with great learning and run exactly the
right environment that the developer
intended what's interesting though is
the actual applications then will run in
isolation so they're not impacting other
applications that using dependencies on
other libraries or files outside of the
container because of the architecture it
really uses a lot less space and because
it's using less space it's a much more
lightweight architecture so the files in
the actual folder itself is much smaller
it's very secure highly portable and the
boot up time is incredibly fast so let's
actually get into how you would actually
create a docker container so the docker
container itself is actually built
through command line and it's built of a
file and docker image so the actual
docker file is a text file that contains
all the instructions that you would need
to be able to create that docker image
and then we'll actually then create all
of the project code with inside of that
image then the image becomes the item
that you would share through the docker
registry you would then use the command
line and we'll do this later on select
docker run and then the name of the
image to be able to easily and
effectively run that image locally and
again once you've created the docker
image you can store that in the docker
registry making it available to anybody
within your network so something to bear
in mind is that docker itself has its
own registry called docker hub and that
is a public registry so you can actually
go out and see other dock images that
have been created and access those
images as your own company you may want
to have your own private repository so
you want to be able to go ahead and
either do that locally through your own
repository or you can actually get a
licensed version of docker hub where you
can actually then share those files now
something that's also very interesting
to know is that you can have multiple
versions of a docker image so if you
have a different version control
different release versions and you want
to be able to test and write code for
those different release versions because
you may have different setups you can
certainly do that within your docker
registry environment okay so let's go
ahead and we're going to create a docker
image using some of our basic docker
commands and so they're essentially
really you know kind of just two
commands that you're gonna be looking
for one is the build command another one
is to actually put it into your registry
which is a push command so if you want
to get a image from a docker registry
then you want to use the pokemon and a
pull command simply
the container
have the image run exactly as it would
in production and then you can actually
use the run command to actually use the
docker image on your local machine so
just a you know a few uh interesting
tidbits about the docking container once
the container is created a new layer is
formed on top of the docker image layers
called the container layout each
container has a separate read write
container layer and any changes made in
that docking container is then reflected
upon the particular container layer and
if you want to delete the container
layer the container layer also gets
deleted as well so you know why would
using docker and containers be of
benefit to you well you know some of the
things that are useful is that
containers have no external dependencies
for the applications they run once you
actually have the container running
locally it has everything it needs to be
able to run the application so there's
no having to install additional pieces
it's basically very easy i went back to
share the containers and i don't know
in just one
is
[Music]
can you run multiple containers together
without the need to start each one
individually and you know what yes you
can with docker compose docking compose
allows you to run multiple containers in
a single service and again this is a
reflection on the lightweight nature of
containers within the docker environment
so we'll end our presentation by looking
at some of the basic commands that you'd
have within docker so we have here on
the left hand side we have a docker
container and then the command for each
item we're actually going to go ahead
and use some of these commands in the
demo that we're going to do after this
presentation you'll see that in a moment
but just you know some of the basic
commands we have are committing the
docket image into the container kill is
a you know standard kill command to you
know terminate one or more of the
running containers so they stop working
then restart those containers but
suddenly you can look at all the image
all of the commands here and try them
out for yourself so we're going to go
ahead and start a demo of how to use the
basic commands to run docker so to do
this we're going to open up terminal
window or command line depending whether
you're running linux pc or mac and we're
going to go ahead and the first thing we
want to do is see what our docker image
lists are so we can go sudo docker
images and this will give us well first
we'll enter in our password so let's go
enter that in and this one now gives a
list of our docker images and here are
the docker images that have already been
created in the system and we can
actually go ahead and actually see the
processes that are actually running so
i'm going to go ahead and open up this
window a little bit more but this will
show you actually
there's no
discussion on any issue i won't be
explaining anything
to the pros and cons
i won't be
telling you benefits or
and you
about
about a minute ago and it's called learn
and these are all running ubuntu and
this is the one that we had created just
a few seconds ago
let's open it up and
there we go
so let's change that to that new dock
container to a running state so scroll
down and we're going to type sudo
docker
run
dash
i t dash dash
name
my
[Music]
um
so this is going to be the new container
name it's going to be my docker so this
is how we name our docker environment
and we'll put in the image name which is
ubuntu
and dash bin dash bash
and it's now in our route and we'll exit
out of that
so now we're going to go ahead and start
the new my docker container so sudo
docker
start
my
and we'll get the container image which
will be my docker
my docker
return and that started that docker
image
and let's go ahead and check against the
other running docker images to make sure
it's running correctly so sudo docker
ps
and there we are underneath name on the
right hand side you have to see my
docker along with the other docker
images that we created that's been
running for 13 seconds
quite fast so we want to rename the
container let's use the command sudo
docker and rename we can take another
docker image this is grab this one and
we'll put it in rename
and we'll rename
and put in the old container name which
is image and then we'll put in the new
container name and let's call it
purple
so now the container image that had
proved something called image is now
called purple
so we do sudo docker
ps
to list all of our docker images
and we scroll up and there there we go
purple
how easy is that to rename an image
and we can go ahead and use this command
if we want to stop containers so we're
going to write sudo
docker
stop
and then we have to put in the container
name
and we'll put in my docker the container
that we originally created
and that image has now stopped
and let's go ahead and prove that we're
going to list out all the docker images
and what you see is that it's not listed
in the active images it's uh not on the
list on the far right hand side
but if we go ahead and we can list out
all of the docker images so you actually
see it's still
there as an image is just
not in an active stage it's what's known
as in an exit stage
so here we go
and there's my docker it's in an exit
state so that happened 27 seconds ago
so if we want to to remove a container
we can use the following command
so sudo docker
rm
or remove
my docker
and that will remove it from the exit
state
and we're going to go ahead and we're
going to double check that
and
yep
yep
it's not not listed there under exit
state anymore
it's gone
and there we go
there were that's where it used to be
all right let's go back
so if we want to exit a container in the
running state so we do sudo kale and
then the name of the container
i think one of them is called yellow
let's just check and see if that's going
to kill it
oops no i guess we don't have one called
yellow so let's find out name of
container that we actually have
so sudo
docker
kill
oh we're going to list out the ones that
are running oh okay there we go now
yellow isn't in that list so let's take
i know let's take simply learn and so we
can actually go ahead and let's write
sudo docker
kill
simply learn
and that will actually kill an active
docker container
boom there we go
and we list out all the active
containers you can actually see now that
they simply learn container is not
active anymore
and these are all the basic commands for
docker container
hey guys welcome back to simply learn
did you know before docker and
containers were introduced companies had
been deploying their software either on
a bare metal or in a virtual machine
but they had been facing a lot of
challenges in managing orchestration of
services instant deployment of services
on different platforms and maintaining
multi-host applications
all these issues were solved with the
help of docker and its containers
in this docker and container tutorial
session we will give you the conceptual
exposure to docker and its containers
we will focus on why is docker container
essential
what is docker container what exactly is
virtualization
then few significant differences between
vm and docker container
then some of the benefits of using a
docker container
architecture of docker
next how docker container works in the
docker ecosystem and finally a
step-by-step process in how to create
docker containers
let's begin with the first topic do you
know why docker containers are essential
in an organization
consider an example where a company
develops a code on oracle weblogic
software
in the company a developer installs
oracle weblogic software on his computer
system
once the application is developed he
shares it with the other team for
testing the code now the tester repeats
the weblogic installation process which
was done by the developer earlier on his
system
later the same application file is
shared with the production team
to host the application the system admin
must install oracle web logic on his
system
let me ask you an important question
here
have you noticed that the same weblogic
installation process was done thrice
but what could be the reason behind it
due to the difference in computer
environments web logic doesn't work on
the other systems so installation is
done separately on three different
computers
but this process of installing the same
software on different systems consume a
lot of time and effort
in order to avoid these problems docker
containers were introduced before we
start with the concept of docker
containers let me explain you what a
docker is
docker is an open source platform that
helps a user package and application and
its dependencies into a docker container
to develop and deploy software docker
provides suitable frameworks for
different applications
since every application has a framework
with an appropriate version this space
also can be utilized for a new software
application along with its required
framework
as a result docker makes more efficient
use of system resources
containerization includes all
dependencies frameworks libraries etc
required to run an application in an
efficient and bug free manner
with docker containers applications can
work efficiently in different computer
environments
after this let's talk about the benefits
the benefits of docker containers show
up in many places
containers are widely used because of
their services
since it's lightweight it can be easily
deployed and executed on other computer
environments regardless of their host
operating system or configurations
containers take up less disk space and
relatively faster in executing
applications
containers run applications in isolation
and also share the operating system
kernel with other containers
by default containers are entirely
secure
container policies ensure all
applications are highly secure including
the docker infrastructure containers are
highly portable and can run anywhere
across the docker ecosystem
multiple software can be encapsulated in
a single container and can be easily
deployed to different platforms
as soon as a container is created it can
be deployed into any other system where
docker is already installed
on that system the application will
perform exactly as it did in the
previous environment
containers take less boot up time
these containers save time in the
deployment process of an application
here comes the next important concept
virtualization
virtualization is the technology of
running a virtual instance of a computer
system or running a virtual version of a
computer resource like hardware
software storage devices and computer
network resources on the cloud
a virtual machine is an isolated
computing environment that allows
developers to use an operating system
via a pc or computer system
let's now talk about some of the
significant benefits of using docker
containers
the first benefit is the lack of
external dependency
containers have no external dependency
for applications to run
containers will just be used to host and
run the applications
as containers are lightweight they are
quickly shipped to other computers and
executed in different computer
environments regardless of their host
operating systems
containers are lightweight they share a
kernel across containers and therefore
use less memory space the next benefit
is the volume
volumes are also a convenient way to
share data within the docker ecosystem
volumes can be more safely shared among
other containers
and the last one is isolation
containers run application in isolation
and share the operating system kernel
with other containers
in containers the host operating system
provides isolation along with the
applications microservices can also be
more easily isolated
next comes the most important topic of
the session that is containerization
versus virtualization
containerization and virtualization are
two different ways to deploy
applications and microservices in a
computer environment in vms a hypervisor
is a firmware layer that enables
multiple operating system to run side by
side
a virtual machine has unstable
performance as multiple running vms run
simultaneously on the same machine
also the efficiency of hypervisors is
not as good as that of the host
operating system
due to the extra layer in vm and
application takes quite a long time to
start
as you can see there are two
architectures on the screen on the left
hand side is vm and on the right hand
side is the docker
on the left hand side as you see there
is one host operating system a
hypervisor and guest operating system
shared by all containers along with
their dependencies
in vm guest operating system occupies
more space and leads to unstable
performance
guest operating system makes virtual
machines less efficient than the
physical machines
guest operating system makes a vm slow
because they access the hardware
indirectly
on the other hand docker is efficient
unlike vms docker doesn't have a
hypervisor or guest operating system
docker consists of containers
these containers are efficient and are
easily portable across different
platforms
in vms the hypervisor has a scalability
issue
the hypervisor creates a security risk
as well
well did you know that according to
vitana the chances of experiencing a
data breach while using virtualization
are high
well
that could lead to a major problem for
companies who are still using virtual
machines
next let's have a closer look at the
docker containers
in case you are unsure what kind of
applications can be added to a container
then
look on the right hand side a container
can package apache tomcat and its
dependency that is java programming
language in a single file
later a user can ship the container to
another computer environment and run the
code without any issue
it's usually challenging to understand
the differences between container and vm
so let me explain to you the differences
in layman terms
as shown the virtual machine is compared
to a bangla and the container is
considered as an apartment
in a bungalow amenities like water lift
roof etc cannot be shared with the
neighbors likewise vm is less efficient
it doesn't share its resources with
other applications
on the other hand containers share their
amenities binaries and libraries with
the neighboring containers just like a
person who resides in an apartment
the bang law is owned by a single person
it cannot have tenants
likewise virtual machines cannot run
multiple applications
on the other side docker runs multiple
containers just like numerous tenants
reside in a single building
next let's look at the table in which we
have made a direct comparison between
virtual machines and containers
in docker containers data volumes can be
shared and reused among multiple
containers
either docker cli or docker api manages
the volumes
also the volume drivers give the
facility of storing volumes on remote
hosts or cloud providers
vm is a container based model it
utilizes user space along with the
kernel space of an operating system
so data volumes cannot be shared
containers have a better performance as
they are hosted in a single docker
engine
docker provides the most substantial
default isolation capabilities among the
other configuration tools making the
performance better
virtual machines run multiple vms at a
time which leads to unstable performance
docker is much more efficient than
hypervisors docker enables developers to
wrap ship quickly and run applications
as a lightweight and portable container
on the other hand virtual machines are
less efficient
docker containers can run multiple
containers on a system but virtual
machine can run only a limited number of
vms on a system
multiple software can be encapsulated in
a single container and can be easily
deployed to different platforms
containers are easily portable across
other platforms but virtual machines
have compatibility issues while porting
others across different platforms
moving on to the next one
let's have a look at the architecture of
docker
a docker or docker engine consists of
two major components
docker client and docker daemon
these two components are connected to
each other with the help of the rest api
now let's take a look at the
architecture
a docker client has no components but a
docker daemon consists of a docker host
docker daemon docker registry and docker
images
docker client is a service that uses
rest api to send commands to docker
demon through cli commands
rest api is a primary mode of
communication between docker client and
docker daemon
docker engine or docker is a client
server application that builds and
executes containers using docker
components
docker daemon checks the client's
request and communicates with the docker
components to perform a service
docker engine or docker is a client
server application that builds and
executes containers using docker
components
docker image is also one of the
essential components of docker
a docker image is a file of instructions
that are used to create containers
a docker image is built using a file
called dockerfile
a docker image is a template of
instructions that is used to create
containers
coming to containers
a docker container is a portable
executable package that includes
applications and their dependencies
docker containers are lightweight
because they do not require an extra
layer of a hypervisor and run directly
on the host operating system
there is a service in docker called
docker compose
a docker compose is used for running
multiple containers as a single service
in compose service each container runs
in isolation but can interact with each
other with no limitations
talking about docker registry it is a
service used for hosting and
distributing docker images among users
docker registry is a service to host and
distribute docker images among users
let's move on and understand how to
create a docker container
first ensure to set up your development
environment
then you can begin to develop
containerized applications
for that you need to create a docker
image a docker image can be created
using a dockerfile
a docker image is created using a build
command
you must build a docker image that
contains the code of what your
application needs to run in simple terms
a docker image contains all the
project's code
with docker image you can run the code
to develop docker containers
once the docker image is created ensure
to store it in the docker registry using
the docker push command
once a docker image is created you can
either store it in a docker hub or in a
repository
docker also has its default registry
called docker hub
there are multiple docker images
available in the registry and all can be
retrieved through the dockable command
as soon as a docker image is retrieved
from the docker registry you can build
new containers
moving on to the next one let's
understand how docker containers work
in docker a dockerfile is used to build
the image using the build command and
that image is stored in the registry
using the push command
when you run the pull command docker
image is retrieved from the registry
while a single container is built using
docker image through the run command
did you know that a new layer is formed
on top of the docker image layers called
the container layer when a container is
created
this new layer consists of the
application and its dependencies
in docker each container has a separate
reader write container layer
any modifications done in a docker
container are reflected upon the
container layer
suppose a container is deleted the
container layer also gets permanently
deleted
this was the simple functionality of
docker and containers welcome everyone
to this topic on docker files here in
this one we are going to see that how we
can make use of the docker files to
prepare a docker image and using which
we can create a docker container
so uh we are going to talk about what is
a docker what is a docker file what is
the syntax of docker file and how to
build a custom docker image with the
help of dockerfile and in the end we are
going to see a particular demo related
to the docker files over here
now let's talk about what is the docker
now docker is in configuration
management tool which we are pretty much
using to prepare the automation of the
deployment of the
software of the applications now in this
case we make use of the docker
containers using which we can host our
applications and within these docker
containers we are typically hosting both
the application source code and the
defenses all together so both the links
are getting packaged all together into a
single unit called docker containers and
getting hosted onto the server
these containers are very efficient in
work because they are not taking that
much utilization and resources and at
the same time they can be shared across
different environments also so the same
container can be easily deployed across
different different
environments as such
now it helps us to maintain the isolated
application it helps in having a high
productivity there and it also you know
helps us to see to resolve all the
problems which is related to the uh
dependencies for your software because
we are packaging up both the source code
and the dependencies all together in the
single unit in the single entity and
that's where you will be able to get a
particular final solution called as in
docker container over here so docker
container is in complete package using
which you can have like both the
applications and the dependencies bundle
up together into a single entity and
that's where we call it as a docker
container
now what exactly is an uh docker that uh
you know let's see a particular
difference between the virtual machine
and the docker here now if you see on
the left hand side we have the host
operating system
uh which is available there let's say i
have a laptop in this one we have a
windows 10
now we have a hypervisor on top of that
like how hypervisor is in software which
is used to manage the virtual machines
it's a software which is available there
which takes up all the requests from the
virtual machines process it and then
give the response back so hypervisor
acts like a medium between the virtual
machine and the host operating system
resources so
it's going to give that a particular
virtual environment to the virtual
machines and then we have a virtual
machines where in fact a guest operating
system is there then application
binaries then the application is hosted
so this guest operating system actually
takes up a lot of
utilization and these was the old
mechanism where we used to uh
follow this mechanism for hosting our
applications
so all the applications are pretty much
getting deployed in the same manner on
the form of the virtual machines here
right now
if you talk about the new method which
we are talking about right now is in
docker so here we have host operating
system but instead of hypervisor we have
now the docker engine which is available
there now this docker engine is
something which is making sure working
in the same way that how the hypervisor
is behaving but it's much lighter as
compared to the hypervisor
so docker is very lightweight as
compared to the hypervisor here
and here we don't have the concept of
the heavy duty guest operating system
over here so the guest operating systems
which we are using in case of docker
containers are very small in size
the size of guest operating systems is
is in gb's in case of virtual machine
but in case of docker containers it's
pretty much available in the mb size
which is there so the size of the guest
operating system in case of the virtual
machine is really small as compared to
the virtual machine
and that's a biggest benefit because
again it will
help the containers to have a low
utilization low consumptions and uh that
improves the overall performance of the
overall mechanisms and how exactly the
new method of application deployment
really helps us to go for an a
particular advanced mechanism so that it
brings on a very good and the efficient
uh way of doing the deployment of the
applications
now let's talk about what exactly is in
dockerfile here now uh dockerfile is a
concept which is being used as in build
script so it's being used so that we can
have a build a script there
so this will definitely helps uh to see
that how we can go for a build of a
docker image a custom docker image
now when we are using the dockerfile uh
concept so it really helps to prepare a
kind of docker image
so dock image is the end result when you
are going for the mechanism when you're
going for the docker5 buildup oh here so
dockerfile is a build script which is
available for preparing the custom
docker containers because not every
docker image is available on docker hub
so some containers you have to use some
images you have to use to work on that
part
now dockerfile is a very simple
straightforward text file which is
available there and it's basically used
to build up custom docker images so
dockerfile is basically used to prepare
a once so when you're running the docker
build so it's actually going to build up
a particular custom docker image and
that will be given to you
so docker uh image is the whole build
process which is being done
so it's a custom
process which is available and being
done over here in this case
so you got a docker file you run the
docker build command and that's how you
will be able to get a docker image so
whatever the steps you are having in the
docker file that will be processed one
by one and as a end result you will be
able to get a full flesh docker image
over here in this case
right now let's talk about the syntax of
the docker file so docker file is equal
to commands commands and the arguments
so whatever the things you want to put
up so in the docker file you can do that
and as a part of the execution so you
will be able to get a particular end
result
now it's a kind of a mechanism where we
feel that how the execution and the
modifications can be done
so uh the comments which we are trying
to do over here is that you know we can
put up the whatever the comments we want
to put in the case of docker files we
can do that comments is a standard
process in preparing any particular file
or any kind of code because it helps us
to understand that for what reason we
are preparing that particular line then
uh we have the uh particular run
statements the commands are there so you
can see that we are running a particular
command called eco so using the run
attribute we are basically going ahead
and running a particular command into
our system as part of our docker file
over here
now how to build up the docker images
using the dockerfile so um you know
dockerfile is uh just a template which
is available there where we are putting
up that what are the different steps we
want to follow and these steps when we
follow one by one step by step so that's
where we will be able to get a
particular final docker container over
here so docker image is getting
converted as a docker container and we
are getting a docker container as an end
result
now um docker file is being built up and
uh stored in the version control system
and uh this particular docker files when
we are processing so it prepares a
respective a specific
image layer over here and this image
layer is something which is uh
benefiting us that how the executions
can be done and how we can manage on
that part
so
that really helps us to see that how the
executions and the things can be managed
and that can help us to see that how the
management of the things can be
performed as such
so uh docker file is a very good concept
which is there using which you can
prepare any kind of custom docker image
and it can be very easily handled also
and it's in fully automated mechanism
you can use it inside the ci cd
pipelines for automating the docker
images
right now it's a docker image is a layer
by lay mechanism which is there in which
we have multiple layers each and every
layer we are doing some specific
entries some specific tasks or some you
know changes we are trying to deploy in
part of our these layers right so uh
you can use the uh particular docker
build command to perform the executions
and you will be able to get any
particular response an output will be
given back to you so docker file is
basically helping you to see that how
the executions can be done and you will
be able to get an end result over here
so the docker image is the final result
which we are getting when we are talking
about the docker file here
right so these are all read-only formats
which are available you cannot modify
these directly but yes with the help of
docker file you can do whatever the
changes you want to deploy on these
docker images
right so uh this is a small example
where we are using a base image as an 1
to 18.04 so we are using the from
attribute to specify that yes we are
going to use the ubuntu 18.04 here then
we are pulling our uh the file into the
uh directory we are transferring a
particular file inside the docker
container and then we are running our
make command and then cmd attribute is
there using which we can run the command
on the runtime on the docker container
so these are a very a basic example but
eventually when we are done with this
docker image we will be able to get a
four layer uh docker image over here
because there are four steps and then
hence it will be providing you a
particular four layers in your final
docker image over here so layer by layer
these changes will be done during the
build process and in fact using the
docker history command you can see that
layers these layers information also
right so layer one is ubuntu 18.04 layer
2 is pull
and the third layer is there where we
can run the
make command to you know run this file
which we have pulled on and then the
finally the last one is there where we
are running like using the cmd parent so
the difference between run and cmd is
that cmd will run only when you run a
docker container so run attribute will
be executed during the docker build part
so this is a pretty much is a way that
how we can go for the execution of a
docker file and how you know we can go
for the build up of a custom docker
image over here so these are the for
some couple of attributes which we are
using in the docker file here
right now let's talk about the entry
point over here now entry point allows
you to specify a command along with the
parameters right so uh let's say that
you want to run a particular command
over here in the docker container so
entry point is something which you can
use to refer to that so application is
the command which you're trying to run
and then you can give some arguments to
that and argument one is what you're
trying to run over here
so entry point is very important because
that eventually helps to see that how
the executions can be done and the
implementations will be done over here
in this case
right so you can see like you can run a
command called eco and then you can use
the parameters also it's not like only
the commands can be used but you can in
fact use the arguments also now add is
an attribute which is available in the
docker file which is primary used to see
to transfer the files from the host
machine inside the docker image
now let's see that you are trying to
prepare your own custom docker image
apart from the dependencies you need the
source code also right so the source
code needs to be transferred inside the
docker image and for that reason we can
use the add attribute so add attribute
requires a source and destination source
will always be the path on which uh on
the testing on the host machine the
files are present so we can give that
and destination is the folder which is
available inside the
particular docker container where we
want to store the files so you can use
the example over here just like this you
can use and you can give two entries one
is the source one is the destination and
once that is done so you will be able to
see your files being stored up in the
destination directory once the final
docker image is prepared
then we have enb attribute now enb is
something which is used to set up some
environment variables
which is required of course for the
docker image for the application which
is running inside the docker image now
environment variables are something
which you can hardcore during the docker
build one but using the when you are
running like when you're creating the
docker container at that time also you
can override the these environment
variables so environment variables are
very important because uh first during
the build process you can hard code some
values but if you really want to change
them during the runtime that also is
being supported by the environment
variables
so
most of the times we use it as an kind
of a keep value pair just like in linux
we use uh we used to set up a particular
environment variable so the key value
pair is being used in case of enb
attribute
maintainer is there where we can
describe that what is the details about
the author these are the fields which is
available in the top so where we can
give the the author name and the author
you know details like email id and all
so that we know that who is the person
who is maintaining this particular file
and we can reach out to them in case any
issues are there for the docker files am
right so that is what we have here in
this one so now we are going to see that
how we can go for a small demo and
docker file and we can go for the
implementation of this
particular docker file and prepare a
custom docker image so let's just wait
on that part
so let's see some demo here now in this
one we have got two examples one is the
python one is the notice one so first of
all what we need to do is that we need
to process the python one here so this
is the sample docker file which we have
got here for the python now all this one
requires a python file which is already
present on the server and we are going
to transfer we are going to copy this
content over here that this is the
specific docker file content which is
available to us and all we need to do is
that we need to put this content across
the server so that we will be able to
build our custom docker image so let's
go back to the server so here we have
already got the python file which is
present so we have to create a docker
file here which will have the steps
related to the docker image preparation
over here so we will be including some
steps over here that these are the
different steps we want to configure we
want to set up over here in this one so
python 3.6.4 is the version of the
python which we want to configure and
then we are going to transfer some files
into slash app we are also setting up
the working directory as slash app and
ultimately we are running a command
called pip install flask to do the
installation of flash package and then
we are starting the uh specific
applications on that part so i'm going
to save this file and uh once i save
this file so all we need to do is that
we need to create a custom docker image
right so right now there is no image
which is available over here and it's in
complete md instance so i'm going to run
a command called docker
build
hyphen t
python hyphen m dot so docker build is
the typical command but hyphen t is for
the tag that what kind of docker image
you want to build and then we are giving
a image name and then we are specifying
dot over there now once we are done with
that so it will pick up all the things
one by one the basic docker image is
being pulled down
then some sequence of steps is being
executed so it's a step-by-step process
which is happening over here in this
case and we are then transferring some
files in the slash app and then
ultimately we are going for the pip
install flask so it's installing those
packages and at the end the final docker
image will be prepared and will be given
back to us so we will be able to get
this uh docker images over here when we
run that command we will be able to find
out that we got our custom docker image
also available and as you can see that
the base darker image is also available
in this one but yes we have added up
like around 10 mb of work we have added
on top of this python
base docker image here so that's how we
are able to do the processing over here
in this case in this setup so that's
what we uh can do to prepare a custom
environment of python with the help of
the docker file here now let's see that
we will be proceeding on with the
node.js to see that if the node.js uh
kind of setup also can be done now for
node.js again of course we got uh the uh
specific docker file which is present so
we can process that but let's create a
new folder over there so i'm going to
create for a new node.js folder so that
we can create the work all together in
this one so i'm going to run a command
called npm minute which is the command
to initialize any empty project in case
of node now you can typically bring down
some real code also or you can say that
i want to process an empty a project so
you can give the configurations you can
give the custom names but i want to
process with these as default name
itself so ultimately it's going to
create an entries like uh you will be
able to see like all these uh values
which we are not providing these
standards value will be picked up for
the uh specific code and at the end you
will be able to get a package.json file
created over here in this one now you
can actually bring down the steps that
how you can perform or you can build up
a custom node.js based docker image now
these docker files is giving you the
capability that you can convert a
full-fledged application which is
deployable on the virtual machine you
can actually convert them in the format
of the docker containers over here in
this one so that's what we are going to
get over here with this uh particular
setup are these mechanisms
so let's go back to the document and see
that what exactly we can copy the docker
file
so we have got this docker file over
here so all we can do is that we can
copy this one so once we copy this uh
specific file here so all we can do is
that we can transfer uh these are files
into the onto the server we can convert
it into the docker file there so that we
will be able to set up the
configurations and we can perform the
setup around that so docker file is
again we want to create and we want to
set up on that here so let's go back to
the server
so here we want to create a docker file
and we want to
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
in which you can configure that how the
setup needs to be done and how the
configurations should be performed there
because that's a command that's a script
which is going to be executed within the
container so let's copy the content now
i'm going to copy this content over here
which is like a sample node.js code
which is available so i'm just copy this
one and transfer it to the server
so server.js file we have to create here
just like we did in case of the python
because this is the source we want to
transfer inside the
docker container
so this is what we have got now i'm
going to uh transfer like uh i want to
change this port value from 5000 to 8080
because that's what it's configured in
the dockerfile of course you can
configure 5000 also depending on your
requirement you can do that
configurations
now you have got uh these two files over
here in this one so all you need to do
is that you need to run like docker
build
hyphen t node.js hyphen app and dot so
it will automatically pick up like what
exactly it will uh you know go for the
node.js basic docker image over here so
that will be processed over here in this
one so step by step it will be able to
do the configurations
so first of all it will download the
basic docker image which is um quite uh
more incisive over here in this one once
it's downloaded onto your system then it
will proceed further with the build
activity on
processing the docker file performing
the execution so all that stuff will be
performed with this help of this docker
build process over here so it's going to
process it one by one in this one
and it's going to the next step where
it's transferring some of the files like
creating some working directory
transferring the files uh putting up
there and running the npm install
command
and then ultimately it will expose the
port and then it will have the
cmd attribute configured over there so
this is basically typically trying to
portrait it how a particular docker
image can be built up and of course once
the uh build a success you can validate
it with the help of docker images here
so this is the app docker image which
has been prepared of 911 mb and uh we
have got it like a final package where
the runtime is also there and the code
base is also available now you can
pretty much
experience it like with other actual
source course like you can generate the
download some pre configured node.js
websites or the source codes here and
you can try to run them onto the docker
container so that you can get the full
uh the complete idea about that how it
goes on but right now the uh these are
the basic docker image which you can
prepare and you can build up over here
in this one so that's how it really
works on for you today we're going to
dig into docker swarm so what we're
going to do in this session is we're
going to go through what a docker and
docker container is and why you'd want
to use it we'll then break out what are
the characteristics and structure of a
docker swarm environment and then
finally we'll go through and do a demo
using actual code in the command line
interface to actually run and build out
the main functions and commands that you
would use for a docker swarm environment
so with that said let's get started so
docker is a tool that we actually use to
help automate applications in our
environment so that we have a consistent
way that we're actually building and
testing and validating codes that's been
created think of it as a virtualization
but much more sophisticated and
efficient way of doing virtualization
the thing that you have that's a huge
advantage when you're working with
docker is that it's a very lightweight
software package it allows you to have
all of the tools needed for actually
running the code without having to have
the significant overhead that you would
normally have with virtualization so one
of the characteristics you have with
docker is that you can actually run
multiple docker environments in the same
host environment and for you to be able
to do this we had to figure out how this
would actually run and so to actually do
this we actually do what's called a
docker swarm and a docker swarm is an
environment where you can actually have
multiple docker images running on the
same host operating system so you can
have running in each of those docker
containers different solutions
so let's dig into what a docker swarm is
so a docker swarm is essentially a tool
that allows you to very easily create
and schedule multiple docker nodes so
really two or more docker nodes and you
can have quite a large number of docker
nodes in a single swarm uh each node
itself is actually a docker daemon and
that demon is able to interact with the
docker api and have all the benefits of
being a full docker environment one of
the other advantages you have is that
the each docker container within the
swarm can then be deployed and managed
but as a node in that entire clustered
environment so what we have here is a
breakdown of the five key elements
within a docker environment you have the
docker container you have the daemon the
docker images and the docker client and
docker registry so the docker game
itself is what does all the work
interacting with the actual host
operating system to be able to manage
the docker containers so if we look here
here we have set up an environment where
we have three docker containers being
run with docker and what we want to be
able to do is be able to interact with
the environment because what would
happen if we actually have something
changed in our environment so we have
the environment set up as a docker swarm
and one of our containers fails what
we're able to do is use the swarm to be
able to correct that failure so the
docker swarm manager is able to come in
and reschedule containers and as you
would imagine the actual swarm note has
full backups and full redundancy for any
kind of failures that would happen and
we would do all of this work through
command line interface so let's go
through some of the features that you
have within the actual docker swarm
itself so a key feature for docker swarm
is that it is fully decentralized which
means that it makes it very easy for
teams to be able to access and manage
the environment as you would expect as
well is that the communication that
happens between the manager and client
nodes within the swarm is highly secure
and of course this is really just a
fundamental that you should have for any
kind of solution but it is good to know
that docker swarm has that built in
there is also auto load balancing within
your environment you can actually script
that into how you write out and
structure your swarm environment and
that load balancing then also allows you
to then convert that swarm environment
into a highly scalable infrastructure
and then rollback task allows you to be
able to roll back environments to
previous safe environments so say
something that does get pushed out and
something breaks you're able to
immediately roll back into a safe
environment so each of the containers
are pushed out and and are controlled
using services and they actually happen
to be breast services which make it very
easy for you to be able to integrate
within your environment
and each of the different surfaces
contains a group of containers of the
same image now by having this structure
it allows you to be able to scale your
application appropriate to the demands
on your service so if you have a service
that needs to have a significantly
larger number of services for it to run
you can actually scale that
appropriately and they can be either geo
or demand based one of the requirements
for setting up a docker swarm is you
must have at least one node deployed so
the way that the architecture is set up
is that you have a manager node and a
client node and there must be one of
each for the entire environment to be
able to work effectively so you know
here we are just jumping ahead of sales
a little bit we have two types of nodes
in the docker swan we have the manager
node and we have the worker node which
is the client that does the actual
execution of the tasks the manager node
very similar to other systems that we've
talked about on simplylearn allows you
to actually control and manage the
actual tasks that are being executed by
the worker nodes and the working nodes
as you can imagine and then actually
execute the instructions that the
manager are sending out to it so here we
have a situation where we can illustrate
what would happen with a manager node
sending out commands to different worker
nodes the manager is fully aware of the
status of the entire swarm environment
at all times this is because of the
two-way secure communication that's
going from the manager to the worker
environment the workers as you'd expect
are accepting tasks that are being sent
from the manager so the manager sends
out a task saying that you need to be
running as a my sql environment then the
worker node will then convert to my
sequel environment and all of these
environments are scripted and controlled
by you as the manager the actual worker
nodes themselves actually have a client
agent and that client will then
communicate all different states of the
infrastructure back to the manager so
that any time the manager node is in
full control of the entire swarm the
manager is the controller of this
environment and so you always want to be
able to ensure that the manager has full
access to all the work that's happening
within the swarm and this allows you as
the manager to be able to control your
swarm and very quickly be able to react
to any changes without having to rely on
manual installations of software and
hardware and as we covered earlier on
there is a rest api that uses the
communication over http from the manager
to the worker node it's interesting to
note that it is a rest api because if
you wanted to you could actually
integrate that api into custom
applications and even then create
automated docker images to be created on
demand from third-party solutions that
you may want to create so one of the
things that's a really a big advantage
with having a swarm is that once you've
actually created the swarm any of the
services and that you create can be
accessed by any node of the same cluster
one of the things you do have to do
though is you have to specify what
container image that you're going to use
when you're creating a new service and
you can do that either through a
centralized docker hub environment or
through your own private docker hub
environment one of the things that's
interesting is that you can set up
commands and services to be either
global or replicated a global service
will allow you to run a service
consistently on every node within the
swarm whereas a replicated service will
only push out functionality and tasks to
specific worker nodes within a swarm so
you may be asking yourself hey isn't a
service and task the same thing no
they're kind of not in the docker world
and the difference is is a service is a
description of a task for the state
whereas the actual task is the work that
needs to get done and that's the
differentiator here so what you can do
as a docker user is you actually create
services and then you can then define
when you want them to start as tasks now
what's interesting is that when you do
assign a task to a node that same task
cannot be assigned to another node also
what's interesting is that you can
actually have multiple managers within a
docker swarm environment if you do
however go down this path you have to
elect one manager to be the primary
manager and the other managers to be
secondary managers in many ways those
secondary managers are really similar in
concept to worker nodes in which they
have the capability of a manager but
they are dependent on that single
primary manager to be able to provide
the right instructions and for services
and tasks to the entire swarm
environment so if we kind of recap some
of these we have a command line
interface which allows us to create and
connect via apis and that those apis
that we connect to in our small
environment allows us to do
orchestration via tasks and services the
task allocation allows us to allocate
work to tasks via their ip address which
allows them to execute them on the work
and then the worker nodes themselves
have to connect to the manager node to
be able to check for when to ask someone
so that they are keeping a consistent
communication back and forth across the
entire swarm and then the final stage is
to actually execute the tasks that have
been assigned from the manager note to
the work note so that you have a
successful execution of the solution
you're looking to build all right so
with that said let's go ahead and we're
going to do a demo
so we're going to go ahead and do a demo
and showing how you can run docker swarm
for this you'll need to have both a
virtual environment running your manager
and your working environment so here we
have our worker and uh here we have our
manager so we're just going to open up
terminal window and we're going to go
into the manager for terminal window
so the following command here is used to
initialize docker swan which is going to
type this in so sudo docker swarm in it
and we push the ip address for the
network we're connecting to
and we'll put in our password
and here we have now connected
and this is our manager node and what we
want to be able to highlight is the
specific token which identifies the
docker swarm environment and this is our
token right here so we're going to copy
that
because we'll need to use that for our
worker environment so here we are in the
work environment and we'll use the token
that we just copied and as a way to be
able to connect to the manager and
connect to the docker swarm environment
and so sudo
i'll paste in the docker swarm and we'll
join that
and now here we shows that we have
joined the swarm environment as a worker
and now
we're in the manager we can actually
show that we actually have
that worker in the environment so
there's docker node ls to list out all
of the
items in that environment
sorry we actually did them in the wrong
area so we're on the right sudo docker
node ls to list out
all the nodes in the swarm
and there you are you see we've actually
connected the
worker to the manager node and both
are active and the manager is the leader
and the worker virtualbox is in the
swarm
okay we're going to go ahead and create
a new service so docker swan create and
we're going to just change the name
to hello world for the new service and
we use the alpine image from docker.com
it takes just a moment for it to run
there we go
and there we go services converged
so what we have now is a new service
that has been created
let's go ahead and we'll list out the
services
and here we have our new hello world
service
and we go ahead and check the duck and
containers and we're going to do
docker ps and
here's our alpine it's running the
latest image
and that's the docker container id
and we can see that it was just updated
and so we're going to do is use the same
command in the worker node and make sure
everything is working over there
go over to our worker
paste that in
so what we see here is there is no image
or container created because it's not in
the working node it would be in the
manager node
so we can go ahead and create the new
service
and we're going to make the mode global
and that way the service is available
across all of the swamp
so we're just going to execute that work
takes a moment
and
there we are
done work has been completed and we have
the two different ids which shows that
two different services are running and
if we go back to the worker mode and we
run
sudo.ps again and there we are now we
see that we have the hello world
new virtual environment has been added
with the image of alpine and we also
have the new token id for that
if we want to kill a node from the swarm
we can use the following command which
is pseudo docker swan leave dash dash
force
and that will force the nodes to leave
the swarm
today we're going to cover
so in this session what we're going to
do is we're going to go through
[Music]
and at the end of this presentation
we'll take you through some basics
has come as an evolutionary
[Music]
in your own operations
heavy and complex and in contrast docker
is a much more lightweight and
flexible environment that you can
automate with scripts so we have to
remember that the container itself is
just software and it has dependencies
that run within that application that
are managed by docker so we have a look
at the way dockers broke now first of
all we have the docker image and we have
the docker image created by a docker
file and the dockerfile is a text-based
script and that text file within
dockerfile actually has all the commands
that allow you to run the appropriate
technologies within the document so the
docker image allows you to be able to
have a wide group of people and
consistently run the same environment
and if you want to be able to share that
docker image effectively you would do so
by uploading to docker hub and docker
hub can be available either publicly
yeah through the public docker hub
website or you can actually set up your
own private enterprise docker hub to
share your own images across your own
network and then from docker hub people
can then pull their own doc image and
build new containers that are consistent
on the original docker container that
you created so it's a great way of being
able to have your entire team scale up
easily and effectively so one of the
questions that will come up though is
what if you want to use two containers
in a single service and an example this
might be like a web server that is using
a database but the database may be in
one container and the web server may be
in another container which is very
typical for your own web and database
infrastructure so very similar um
scenario how would you do this with doc
app so by using just docker itself it's
actually very difficult to do this you
can do it but it's just very time
consuming and just not a very good use
of your productivity but with docker
compose you can actually do the whole
process quite quickly and easily and
hence the reason why we have docker
compose to allow you to have two or more
docker containers running in the same
environment being able to communicate as
if they were running in a production
environment so let's dig into what
docker compose is so let's consider a
scenario that you'd have today so
mintra is a
fashion website similar to amazon and
you'd go to intro with your web browser
and
on that website you would go through a
number of activities such as logging
into your account browsing a catalog
you'd have your checkout application
server and you go through the typical
process of building out an application
behind each of these services are
different products such as you know to
have an account database you'd have a
product database different checkout
processes and these would all be run
behind the scenes and each of these can
be considered a micro service so the
more microservices you build into your
environment the more complexity you're
adding and the more of value it would be
to have each of these services in their
own container but as a developer you
want to be able to jump from one
container to another container so your
login account can then be passed on to
your product catalog and then be able to
move through the whole process so the
environment that you would see today
would be small like what we're showing
right now where you'd have your server
and your database and you may have a
server running on apache tomcat or a sql
server you'd have different databases
and you'd want to be able to have each
of those in their own containerized
environment so the way that duck compose
runs is that it works as a single
service so you have the docker compose
running multiple containers but the
perception is of a single service run
the thing that's great though is that
each of those containers will run in
their in isolation and but they can
interact with each other so unlike a
normal docker environment where you have
multiple docker images running
completely in isolation of each other
these are images that will run in
isolation but can interact with each
other the docker compose files are very
easy to write they're all written with a
scripting language called yaml and yaml
is an xml based language it actually
stands for yet another markup language
but it's an xml based language and it's
very easy to use the great thing about
learning yaml is that a lot of open
source tools in the devops environment
use yaml as the scripting lane and then
finally in docker compose as a user you
can actually go and and trigger all your
services within the containers to start
with a single command as you can imagine
this dramatically reduces the amount of
work that you as a developer have to do
so let's take an example of if you're
running a container one with a ninjx
server and one with the redis database
uh you can create a yaml docker compose
file that actually has the instructions
on the containers needed to build out
both environments and then you can run
each of those environments separately
but have them connected as a single
service so the benefits of duck and
compose is that you have a single host
deployment environment you can run this
all on one piece of hardware you can
have a quick and easy configuration
using yaml scripts the productivity that
you get as a developer significantly
increases because you're not having to
have time wasted trying to configure
just traditional docker containers by
themselves you now have a way of being
able to interact with those containers
and then finally security is at the
center of all of these containers so
each of those containers are completely
isolated from each other and they are
controlled with the same level security
that you'd have with a traditional
docker image but there is a question
here around docket compose isn't it
similar in concept to docker swarm
because at a high level it kind of seems
like both do the same thing and the
answer is well actually no they're
different there are similarities but
there are also differences and
particularly for a developer these
differences will really start coming out
in scale as you start working on your
solutions so let's look at docker
compose so docker compose will allow you
to create multiple containers on a
single host and that's the important
part having a single host which is maybe
your development pc with docker swarm it
also allows you to create multiple
containers however you have to manage
those multiple containers on multiple
hosts which makes a lot of sense if you
are running an operations environment
but not so much if you're doing a
development environment and docker
compose is scripted with yaml which is
very easy for you to be able to control
your scripts docker swarm doesn't have a
scripting technology like yaml so it's a
little bit harder to work with so what
we have here is just some basic commands
that allow you to get up and started
working with docker compose now in our
next demo we're going to take you
through how to use all of those commands
so we're going to go ahead and do a demo
on how to use docker compose um the
first thing you want to do is check that
you have docker installed so what we're
going to do is we're going to open up
the command window and we're going to
type in docker you'll be able to see now
that we have docker installed uh if you
don't have dock installed go ahead and
install docker you can go to
google search to install docker and
they'll give you the instructions for
that we also have videos that we've
already done if once you have docker
installed then you want to do a google
search on docker compose or go to the
docker.com website and select for the
compose section and look for the install
docker compose instructions so we
already have another tab which has
the instructions already installed
you'll see on the left hand side there
are a number of docker tools you want to
expand the docker compose section select
install compose and then on the right
hand side you'll have different install
options for mac windows and linux if
you're installing on those platforms
make sure you copy the correct command
line so there's a couple of command
lines you want to
copy copy the first one over and we
paste that in and it's going to go ahead
and download all of the files for
compose it takes a while but uh we have
to get another file so while it's
downloading we'll go get the other
command line just go back and grab it
real quick it was a little faster but
we'll copy that over there was a second
command instruction and post that
command yep there's the command right
there and that will apply the
appropriate binary and once you've done
that you can actually go ahead and
validate that you have the correct
version of docker compose installed and
for that you want to write the command
docker dash compose space dash dash
version and that will then give you a
version build once you know that you
have a version built that means that you
have everything installed correctly on
your machine so you can see here that we
have a version number which means we
have everything installed you might see
a different version number depending on
how old the video is when you're
watching it but we're using real content
at the moment let's just go ahead and
clear the screen and now what we're
going to do is create a folder where
we're actually going to install the ammo
file that will have the instructions for
our docker component environment so
we're moving the cursor to the desktop
and on the desktop we're going to create
a new folder and
using the mkdirf command and we'll call
this one doc compose f for file and then
we'll move the cursor into that new
folder by using cd command and
now we are in the folder called docker
compose f and you can go look at your
desktop and you'll see it's there and
now you want to select um pound touch
docker dash compose dot yml and that'll
actually create
the new uh yaml file for you and you can
use the ls list command ls docker
compose.yaml and that allow you actually
now to step in and edit that file so
let's go ahead and uh hit return and
they'll allow us to go in and edit the
file so now i'm in the editor and i'm
going to write some instructions um so
i'm i'm going to put a couple of
mistakes in these instructions so we can
see how dr pose catches those mistakes
um so but most this is going to be
fairly correct so you can just type this
out so we're going to start with
surfaces colon then we'll do web colon
and then we'll create image colon and
we'll do nitrix and then we'll do a
database colon and we call the image
redis and so what you can see because we
have two reference images we're actually
calling two different images two
different containers that will be
created by docker hub so what we're
going to do is uh where we can actually
show you um how that's pulling in you
can go to docker hub and you can
actually see the references to the
images that we've just created so go to
dockerhub which is hull
hub.docker.com and you'll see that uh
nidjics redis those are the default
names for the images so you could do
other images like http for apache web
server if you wanted to there are a lot
of images in docker hub so suddenly have
a lot of fun building uh tools from that
environment so we're going to save those
files um in the docker image and we're
just going to do colon wq to exit this
screen save the text and let's go and
run our yaml file and you'll see the two
different error messages that will come
up so we can do cat docker dash compose
dot yml and here we have a display of
the text that we just wrote and now
let's go check the validity of the file
that we just corrected so we'll do
docker dash compose config and we should
get an error message and there we are
error message and the reason why we have
an error message is because the spacing
is not correct in the yaml file itself
so let's go to the actual yaml file we
created let's go through and we're going
to use just the file finder and you
actually open up the yaml file in your
text editor your favorite text editor
and here we have um the code that
created it and that's use the correct
spacing so that everything is spaced out
appropriately in the image and so this
is the spacing that you'd expect to see
a space a line between surfaces and the
first image and the first image is a tab
in and then it referenced what the image
is and let's go ahead and clear the
screen and we'll see whether or not
we've got that all correct it click um
this clear screen and we're going to
check that everything is running
correctly and we're seeing we're still
getting an error message and the reason
why we're getting another error is that
there's still a config error in this the
actual yaml file so one of things you
have to do when you're creating a yaml
file for docker compose is you actually
have to have the appropriate version
number in there so what we have to do is
we have to go and find which is the
appropriate version and there are three
major versions one two and three
depending on the age of docker that you
have installed on your computer uh so if
you have the very latest version of
docker 18 and newer you would put 3.7 as
the version number and what we're going
to do is we're going to just check on
the version that we have installed and
so just clear the screen and then we'll
just do docker version and what we have
is our version of docker's
17.12 now this is the version of docker
not docker compose uh it's your main
docker environment and so if we go back
to our web browser we'll actually see
that version 17 should align with
version number 3.5 yep there we are
version 3.5 so what we want to do is go
back into our yaml file and the very
first line that we want to put in above
the services is the version number and
that version number we're going to put
in is 3.5 so we type in version version
and we put colon and then version number
is in brightening quotes and you save
that and now what we can actually do is
we can actually go ahead and use the
single line instruction to run both of
these uh
two images that we've created because
everything is configured correctly or
just one note you'll see that the
version number is actually at the bottom
of the list and that's just the way that
docker compose works it pulls out the
services and the images that you'd
create and then put the image the
version number at the bottom of the list
so in the presentation we talked about
how you can use one line to trigger two
or more images and so to do that we're
going to do sudo docker dash compose up
dash d and it's going to create the two
environments we have the web environment
and the database environment and let's
use sudo docker ps to actually list out
that all the processes that are running
right now and there we are we actually
see all of the images that are running
we have the names the commands the
images and everything's up and running
and if we want to close both of those
images we can actually use a single line
of command as well and that command will
be sudo docker dash compose down and
that closes both of the images and we
can see that all the databases and the
web services images have been closed and
pseudo docker ps will actually list that
there is nothing running and that's how
to use docker compose welcome everyone
to this topic on docker networking here
so in this one we are going to talk
about that what exactly is in docker uh
why the docker networking is important
uh what is the docker networking all
about features of docker networking
container network modes uh network
drivers and then we will be having a
demo on creating a bridge connector a
bridge network and we will see that how
we can run our custom docker container
on that custom docker network so let's
go ahead with this activity what is the
docker all about so docker is an os
level virtualization software platform
which helps the user to develop deploy
and manage and run applications inside a
docker container now the best part about
this is that not only you store the
source code you also put up the
dependencies inside it so if i have a
job-based application so apart from the
java code base i will also be putting up
the dependencies like jdk and also
inside the docker container so it's a
complete package which you're going to
prepare and inside this package you will
be having all the dependencies and
whatever the binaries you require you
will be having it inside a docker
container now if you see the diagram
over here you have an infrastructure on
top of which you have the host operating
system then on top of the host operating
system you have the docker engine now
docker engine is the main component here
which takes up all the requests which
make sure that all the containers are up
and running and it actually gives an
interface or kind of a runtime to the
docker containers so that they can run
their specific applications so this is a
basic component basic architecture of
the docker now docker container is a
very lightweight software package okay
usually inside these docker containers
you will be having all the dependencies
all the software packages everything is
included in this side these docker
containers so it's a complete package if
i'm looking forward for a jenkins
application container in there
everything will be there right from the
base operating system to the jdk and
then on top of that the jenkins
application running there so the moment
i go there and run the docker container
of jenkins i will be able to have a
full-fledged jenkins application
available which i can access through the
url and through a specific port 8080 so
docker container is a kind of a package
where both the dependencies and the
source code and the liabilities are
available why exactly the docker
networking is important
let's talk about some scenario over here
so my application is something which
totally works perfectly fine into my
system and there is no issues on there i
ran it perfectly fine and i got it as
far as i'm able to interact everything
i'm able to do but the same application
does not works on the other person's
system now what could be the issue
because it's working on one machine and
it's not working on another machine now
the application does not work on another
system because there is a difference in
the computer systems maybe one system is
having a different machine and another
system is having a different machine and
you may be having some of the
differences maybe in the uh term of
hardware maybe in the terms of software
so the differences are possible in two
different machines so how we can get a
solution that we don't get this kind of
problems and once the container is
prepared it should be able to run it
across different systems so docker
networking is the ideal solution for
this uh problem over here with docker
networking the application works totally
fine and
it's something which can work on any
system you don't have any dependency
that it will run only on a specific
machine or a particular system so what
exactly is in docker networking all
about so docker networking enables a
user to link a docker container to as
many as networks you know he or she
requires so you can actually connect a
docker container to a specific network
the docker networks are used to provide
complete isolation to the docker
containers so you can have it like okay
i want to run some couple of containers
in a different network and another
containers i want to run it into a
different networks so you can do that
isolations and the whole purpose of
doing that isolation is so that we will
be able to have a proper networking and
proper executions and all that stuff so
docker networking is a very important
concept when we talk about or when we
come up with the interaction of having
the docker containers isolated so it
resolves most of the problems okay so um
you can have like uh multiple containers
in running in same network you can have
different particular networks also there
so a specific network
have its own uh attributes and then you
can use those attributes to connect to
that containers and to access that
containers but the whole idea is that
the containers are something which is uh
specifically running in a set of
servers or in a set of uh platform so
whenever i'm trying to look forward to
that particular container
it has to be there into a network if you
don't run it into your custom network
then whatever the default network
present it will be hosted in that
network there so how does the docker
networking actually works so you got a
decker file so using the dockerfile you
got up a custom docker image and from
this docker image you have to actually
go there and uh you know put up like the
docker container so
you can also store this docker image to
the docker hub so that the same docker
image can be shared across different
users and they can also pull down their
docker image and they can have the
container running in their systems so
for the collaborating the docker image
you require the docker hub and the
container is the ultimate thing or
object which we need to create out of
the docker image when we go with the uh
particular process when the whole
process goes on over there so what
happens that uh the instead of the
docker hub you can use your own private
repositories also that's something which
totally relies on to you that how
exactly those things works on so a
docker file creates a docker image using
the build command
a docker image contains all the project
source code all the dependencies uh
using this docker image you can actually
run the source code in order to get a
docker container the moment you
initialize or running stance of docker
image you will be able to get a docker
container you can actually use the
docker hub for collaborating or for
sharing the docker image so you can
store the docker image on docker hub and
then different people can actually go
ahead and download or pull this docker
image onto their system and they can
also run their specific containers so
what are the different advantages we get
with the docker networking very first
one is the rapid deployment portability
better efficiency a faster configuration
scalability and the security over here
so these are some of the advantages
which we get when we talk about the
docker networking here now let's talk
about the container network model here
so what is the network model we are
looking forward from the containers
perspective now this is a kind of
architecture here now in this one let's
see that how it actually works on now
you have a docker engine which is a main
component which takes up all the things
and all the important components are
actually integrated with each other now
the network sandbox is the one in which
you will be having your container
running up and running now every network
is having its own attributes the uh
particular different gateway ips the ip
addresses the range of ipads the cidr
blocks also everything it can be
different to for two different networks
so the whole point is that you will be
defining okay if you don't define that i
want to run this uh particular container
into a specific network then definitely
that's going to run into default network
which is which gets created the moment
you do the installation of dockers but
anyhow any network is required for
running a docker container so there are
different network drivers which is
available there so if you feel that you
want to create a network so you have to
choose a particular networking or the
connectivity over there and uh it really
helps us to understand that how the
configurations and how the different
modifications and those changes can be
really done here so a lot of changes are
actually going on and uh you know
performing there and this really helps
us to understand that how the things are
being done as such over there so network
is something which is very important
from the containers perspective so the
network sandbox is in kind of a isolated
sandbox that holds the all the network
configurations of the containers so you
will be requiring
at least one docker container network if
you want to run a container inside in
that particular sandbox so sandbox is
created when a user requests to generate
an end point on the network so that's
where the sandbox gets created uh it can
have severals and points in a network as
it represents a containers network
configurations like ip address mac
address dns name so every container will
be having its own unique ips right so
that can be a particular endpoint to
connect to that container and it can
have it like different uh endpoints and
different different networks so that's
always the possibilities which is
available there now the endpoints
establishes the connectivity for the
container services with other services
also so the moment you work on the uh
particulars uh endpoints so that can be
used for having okay there is a service
running in a container so how you can do
that so if you in order to connect that
you require these endpoints so that you
can establish the connectivity with the
container services whatever running
inside these docker containers
right now the network is something which
provides the specific underlining
network attributes like the networking
support to the docker containers because
these uh network sandbox uh boxes will
definitely have a requirement of the
network so how you're going to get that
that you will be only able to get when
you go okay i will be looking forward
for the connectivity and i can go for
the communications and i can give the
hardware because although it's a os
level virtualization but still you
require some interaction with the
hardware from the networking perspective
and then docker engine is a the base
engine which is installed on the host
machine and it's actually the main
component which make sure that the
docker containers and the corresponding
docker services are always up and
running and the uh using the network
drivers you can actually create multiple
networks onto your system and you can
have those uh configurations
now the network architecture is
something which helps us to provide the
connectivity among the endpoints that
probably belongs to the same network and
it's something which is a kind of
isolated network so different different
networks can be isolated uh networks and
we can have the end points to them so
there are different ways in which we can
establish the connectivity and this is a
complete network architecture which is
there so you have a network drivers you
have the networks you have the network
sandboxes in which internally the docker
containers are running and then these
network sandboxes are having their
respective endpoints there to access
them to establish the connectivity now
let's talk about the network drivers now
there are five type of network drivers
which is available first one is the
bridge
host none overlay and mac vlan so these
are the different uh particular network
drivers which is available over here
first one is a bridge it's a private
default network created on the host if
you go there if you go to the
installation of a docker this is the
default driver which gets installed onto
the system onto the host the containers
linked to this network will have an
internal ip address through which we
they can actually communicate with each
other on the same machine also you can
establish the connectivity you can
connect to the containers using that
private ip address but outside the
server you will not be able to have the
communication but internally you can
connect to the containers and containers
can also interact with each other they
can also communicate with each other
with this one
uh the docker daemon creates the uh
docker zero so if you run the ipconfig
config or if config on the system you
will be able to see a docker zero kind
of ethernet bridge network which is
created using which you can see that
okay this is the network which is
created by default it's a default
installation or default configuration
which automatically happens the moment
you set up a docker instance so you
don't have to go into the configurations
or in the setup of there it will be
already available on that particular
installation board there and the next
one is the host one so it's a public
network so when we go with the public
network it's actually uses the host iprs
and uh tcp port in order to uh interact
with the service running inside the
docker container so if you are looking
forward that i want to reach out or i
want to connect to the container but i
want to use an
ip address which can be accessible from
outside world probably some other server
should be able to resolve that in that
situation the host network driver comes
into the picture so it uh effectively
disables the network isolation between
the docker host and the docker
containers which means that using this
driver a user can actually run multiple
containers you know it's it's not
possible for the user to run multiple
containers on the same host because of
the fact that you are using the host ip
address now when we were talking about
the bridge connection at that moment of
time we were getting the private ip
addresses which was totally isolated and
totally unique so there were actually if
you create a using the bridge connection
multiple containers so you will see that
if there are five three containers
everyone will be having a different
private ip address but the moment you go
for the host one so in that situation
the ipad is not going to change so you
get some restrictions okay because the
combination is of ipads and port so iprs
and 8080 can happen only once it cannot
happen multiple times so that's the
limitation that you cannot run multiple
containers on the same host due to this
restriction and the next one is the none
so in this network driver the docker
containers will neither have any access
to the external network or it will not
be able to communicate with the other
containers also total isolation and
total private containers are being done
when we use this driver so if you these
options are usually used when you want
to
disable so this is not doing nothing but
disabling the total networking of
functionality for a specific container
that's what it's happening over here
next one is the overlay so this one is
utilized for creating an internal
private network to the docker nodes in
the docker swamp cluster so overlay does
not comes up in case of a standalone
docker installation the moment you go
with the particular docker swamp cluster
at that moment of time the overlay type
of network is created so docker uh swam
is an orchestration tool so
that requires a overlay kind of uh
driver which can uh you know help them
to achieve the networking in case of
cluster because in case of docker spam
you have a master node manager node
worker nodes different different
machines are there so in that situation
overlay is the
main component or is the main type of
driver which is used and then we have
the mac vlan so it simplifies the
communication processes between the
containers
this network assigns a mac address to
the docker containers with this mac
address the docker you know servers will
route the network traffic to a router so
it's it's not on the basis of ip address
it's actually on the basis of mac
address so on the specific mac address
the network this docker server will
redirect the network to a specific
router
right it's usable when a user wants to
directly connect the containers to the
physical network rather than the docker
host so that's where this communication
works on so it's a direct connectivity
between the host network and uh the
docker container so there is no
virtualization which is happening over
here so uh it's something which is you
know giving a direct access to the
networks but it's definitely on the
basis of mac address which on which the
communication is happening now let's
talk about the networking implementation
and we'll see that how we can go for a
particular bridge network implementation
there so let's go back to the virtual
machine so i am connected to a
particular system here so i can check
that if the docker is available to me
and i can just run the docker version so
it says that okay the client and the
server component both is available there
now we are going to see that what are
the different uh containers which is uh
what are the different docker containers
network which is available there so i'm
going to run a command called docker
network ls now the moment you do it over
here you will see that none host and
bridge these are the different
containers uh network which is available
there and uh you can see their network
ids the names the drivers but drivers is
also very important because that's what
we are going to use here so it's a very
good one here so the default one you can
see that the bridge is available and uh
it's a default one whenever you create
any container by default whether you
give the container attribute or not it's
something which gets created into the uh
terms or in the
basis of the container only in the
default network only so how we can get
that we can always get that part by
you know having the understanding that
what network we are using so i'm going
to run a couple of containers a small
container and we can see that how
exactly uh the containers can be
executed and can be done over there
right so let's see so i'm going to run a
command
docker
run hyphen d id
iphone iphone name
alpine one
alpine
image is what i am going to use
and usage
so it uh pulls down the alpine image
that's what it happened and the same
thing i'm going to run but this time i'm
going to run uh alpine 2 because uh i
want to create two containers
right so with this one what will happen
that i will be having
like two containers available here so i
can say like darker ps so i can see that
two containers that are running one is
the alpine and one is alpine two right
so now what happens that we will see
that how the connectivity happens and uh
what are the network details so what i'm
going to do is that first of all i'm
going to do an inspect over there onto
the
bridge connectivity so that i can get
the detailed information so
this is the name of
the particular ones of the network so
this is the network which is available
and this is the default one so if i
scroll up you can see that this is the
name of the bridge connectivity and uh
even if you run the docker network list
so uh you will be able to see that the
id also so id also if you compare so uh
e65 that's the one which is available
now this one is something which is using
a driver called bridge and here you can
see the subnet information now if you
scroll down you can see that two
containers are available here so i did
not provide any kind of network details
but uh definitely what happens that the
two containers which i deployed are
basically running inside this network
okay and you can see that uh the bridge
name docker zero is the internet or
network which gets created uh which
during the installation of docker gets
configured now
you can see that uh this is the ip
address this is the ip address here this
is the mac address and this is also a
mac address here so uh the ip address
you can see this is a
3.0.3 in the last and this is dot 2 over
here so you can see that the increase
the sequence is there so alpine 1 was
having an ip dot
172.17.5.2 and please come in
[Music]
if you want to access them if you want
to connect on them you will be able to
have the connectivity accordingly so
even if you go inside these houses
you can actually second that so the
story started way back in 2018 when i
was out of job for two years
and then this uh simply learned come
over where i have so this is the way
that so thanks to simply lunch
today i'm in a very good place in my
career and hopefully this will help
other aspiring professionals to see that
growth cannot be lost down how the
configurations can be done
now so uh what we are going to do over
here is that we will try to see that how
exactly uh we can
go ahead and we can connect on there and
we can also see that if we are able to
communicate with each other because
probably uh if i run like ping command
over here
and i'll put the containers like two
and i'm able to reach out there is no
problem in reaching out to these ips
because these are the private ip
addresses and i will be able to reach
out to them without any problem and
without any concerns so from the current
uh connectivity perspective there is no
problem as such and i have a connection
uh available over here but let's see uh
we'll go uh back to the containers we'll
see that how exactly we can talk about
we can reach out to the one container
with each other so i want to connect
alpine one with then pine two so how we
can do that
so i'm going to use like docker
fine one
okay now i got a terminal so what i can
do is that i can go for the ipa in this
show so with this one what will happen
that i will be able to know the ipad is
so dot to is the one which is available
over here okay so this is the ip address
now i can simply do the small pink
command so i can say like ping
google.com so that will show me that if
i have an internet connectivity so that
is great so i got a connectivity with
the internet uh over there so i will be
able to reach out any websites or any
kind of that order now i have another ip
so dot three is remember we were using
three front ip so i can actually do a
ping also here so ping hyphen c five
5 request will put and 3 will do here
now we are trying to reach out to the
alpine 2 over there so although we are
connecting to the alpine one but we have
the connectivity with alpine 2 also so
from alpine 1 you can connect to the
alpine two containers
so that shows that since both of them
are running in the same container so
they are having the automatic
uh connectivity and you can easily reach
out to them and without any issues you
can do that and similarly the same thing
you can do it uh in case of uh
alpine two also so you get it connected
to the alpine two and uh you can uh just
follow the same thing so you can connect
it uh with the if you go to the alpine
two you can connect to the alpine one
also so if you come out the containers i
will be always up and running and you
will be able to have the mechanisms
there so the whole idea about these
things is that it will be basically
helping you to understand that how the
executions can be done and how we can
perform the activities as such over here
so this is the way that how we deal with
the networking and how the containers
gets created into a network and then
they can interact with each other
welcome to this session on docker versus
virtual machine
did you know the famous global
researcher gartner predicts by 2023 more
than 50 percent of the companies will be
adopting docker containers
however a serverless container like
docker will have a rise in the revenue
from a small base of
465.8 million in the year 2020 to
944 million in the year 2024. in this
video we will be doing a side-by-side
comparison of the docker containers and
the virtual machines but before that
let's have a look at the objectives of
this lesson in this session you will
have a good understanding of what a
virtual machine is and what a docker is
followed by that we will have a major
difference between docker and the
virtual machines
also we will discuss some of the key
differences between docker and virtual
machines and finally a use case on what
made bbc to use docker
so the first one
what exactly is a virtual machine it is
an isolated computing environment that
enables a person to use an operating
system via a physical machine virtual
machines provide the functionality of a
physical computer as you can see on my
screen there is a virtual machine and
this is how a typical virtual machine
looks like now let's look at what a
docker is
docker is an operating system level
virtualization software platform that
enables software developers and it
administrators to create deploy and run
applications in a docker container with
all their dependencies
and a docker container is a lightweight
software package that includes all the
dependencies like frameworks libraries
and many more which are essentially
required to execute an application
this is the architecture of docker tool
now let's move on to our next main topic
for the discussion that is
docker versus virtual machine
when it comes to comparing the two we
could say the docker containers have
much more potential than virtual
machines
as you can see on the left and right
hand side
both the images look similar now let's
define the layers of virtual machine
from the bottom up let's begin with the
infrastructure
infrastructure could be a computer
system a laptop or a virtual private
server such as an amazon ec2 instance or
as your virtual machine or gcp virtual
machine instance
on the top of the infrastructure runs
the operating system an operating system
is a software that manages hardware and
software resources for the computer
programs
on your laptop this will be likely
windows mac os or linux flavored
operating system such as ubuntu next
comes the hypervisor a hypervisor is a
firmware that builds and runs virtual
machines there are two types of
hypervisors
type 1 hypervisors are hyperkit for mac
os hyper-v for windows and kvm for linux
operating systems and type 2 hypervisors
are virtualbox and vmware then we have
the guest operating systems consider an
example where you want to run two apps
on your server in total isolation
this process would require two guest
operating systems which will be
controlled by a hypervisor
virtual machines come with many
dependencies where each guest operating
system will at least occupy 512 mb of
your ram
this is worse because each guest
operating system needs its own cpu and
memory resources eventually this will be
expensive
then on top of that each guest operating
system requires its own dependencies
such as binaries and libraries since
every application has different
dependencies it requires its own set of
libraries
finally it's the application this layer
consists of the source code for the
application you have built
this was all about the virtual machine
on a server here's what the same setup
looks like when you're using docker
containers
here you'll notice that there are a lot
fewer layers docker doesn't require a
bunch of massive gust operating systems
let me break it down from the bottom up
again
infrastructure and host operating
systems are the same as we discussed for
the virtual machine coming into the
third layer instead of a hypervisor
docker uses docker engine
docker engine or docker is a client
server application that builds and
executes containers using docker
components
next we have our dependencies
just like on the virtual machines here
dependencies are built into a template
called docker images as you can see on
the screen each application is still
isolated and occupies less space
now let's have a look at the significant
differences between docker and virtual
machine
let's start with the operating system
first
docker is a container based model where
containers are software packages used
for executing an application on any
operating system
on the other side virtual machine is a
container based model it utilizes user
space along with the kernel space of the
operating system a kernel space is where
the core of the operating system runs
and provides its services to the user a
user cannot modify the space and user
space is the portion of the system
memory in which the user's processes run
docker containers share operating system
kernels with other applications and
result in a higher server efficiency
hence docker provides the most
substantial default isolation
capabilities among the other
configuration tools on the other hand
virtual machines do not share the
operating system also it does not
provide isolation in the host kernel
in docker multiple workloads can run on
a single operating system but in virtual
machine each workload needs a complete
operating system or a hypervisor
the next significant difference between
the two is the performance in the case
of docker they use the same operating
system without any additional software
like hypervisor
in case of virtual machines performance
issues are a major problem it can be due
to the several reasons like cpu
constraints memory allocation network
latency and many more
running multiple virtual machines lead
to an unstable performance
docker containers can start up quickly
and result in less boot up time whereas
virtual machines do not start quickly
and lead to a poor performance now let's
talk about the next difference which is
portability with docker containers a
developer can build an application and
store it into a darker image later he or
she can run it across any host
environment
but when it comes to virtual machines it
has portability issues virtual machines
do not have a central hub like docker
dust and it requires more memory space
to store data
docker containers are smaller than
virtual machines due to which the
process of transferring files on the
host file system is easier on the other
hand dependency on the host operating
system and hardware makes virtual
machines less portable while
transferring files virtual machines
should have a copy of the operating
system and its dependencies due to which
image size is increased and becomes a
tedious process to share data
the boot of time between the both is
very different the application and
docker containers start without any
delay since the operating system is
already up and running on the other hand
virtual machines take much longer time
than it takes for a container to run
applications
these containers were basically designed
to save time in the deployment process
of an application whereas in virtual
machines to deploy a single application
virtual machine needs to start an entire
operating system which would result in a
full board process
so those were the major differences
between docker and a virtual machine now
let's discuss the minor differences
between them
docker is not always in a running state
it stops when the stop command is
executed whereas the virtual machines
are always running in the background
which will result in huge ram
consumption talking about snapshots
docker has a lot of snapshots a snapshot
is an image that you can upload on a
private repository to access it on
another host but virtual machines do not
consist of any snapshots in docker
images can be version controlled just
like git they have local registry called
docker hub where users store and
distribute container images on the other
hand virtual machine does not have a
central hub they are not version
controlled
docker can run multiple containers on a
system
users can connect multiple containers
using user-defined networks and shared
volumes multiple containers can be
accessed on the same machine and share
the operating system kernel with other
containers each container is isolated in
user space also docker containers occupy
less space than virtual machines and
start instantly
virtual machine can run only a limited
number of virtual machines on a system
since each virtual machine requires a
certain amount of cpu ram memory and
other resources your physical systems
will have less space
multiple containers can be started at a
time on the docker engine the isolation
environment allows a user to run and
deploy several containers simultaneously
on a given host
virtual machines can run only a limited
number of virtual machines on a system
since each virtual machine requires
certain amount of cpu ram memory and
other resources your physical systems
will have less space now that i have
told you the differences between docker
containers and virtual machines let me
show you a real-life case study of how
pcc uses docker
bcc news is a british news channel over
500 developers working across the globe
pcc news delivers broadcast in almost 30
different languages and with over 80 000
daily news in english alone the news
channel ran more than 26 000 jobs with
more than 10 continuous integrations
with sequential scheduling the company
had issues with identifying a way to
unify the coding process and monitor the
continuous integration consistently also
the existing jobs took up to more time
that is up to 60 minutes to schedule and
perform its task
docker allowed bcc news to eliminate job
wait times and run jobs in parallel it
also gave the users the ability to work
in a more flexible ci environment where
entire core processes were unified and
stored in a single place however docker
succeeded in spreading up the whole
continuous integration process welcome
everyone on this topic of the docker
commands over here in this topic we are
going to talk about what exactly is the
various docker commands which we can use
to interact with the docker docker
images docker containers and some core
components of docker is what we are
going to talk about in this
particular topic here now let's begin
with what exactly is in docker because
we are trying to explore that one of the
different docker commands we can
eventually run to interact with the
docker because uh you have the command
line interface which is available there
using which you can run some couple of
docker commands and internally you know
you will be able to have some particular
processing which is done at the docker
end now docker is in configuration
management tool it's being used as a
configuration management tool just like
the other configuration management tools
uh in the industry in the market now
it's pretty much used by the developers
to make sure that they
wrap or they package an application with
all its dependency
now normally in a virtual machine what
we do is that we host or we install the
dependencies separately and then on top
of that we host our web applications or
whatever the application we have we host
it on that particular framework or
platform
but here in this scenario we are talking
about like how we can wrap an
application all together with its
dependencies all the dependencies are
getting wrapped are getting uh packaged
up into a single entity
and you know that's what we call it as a
docker container so docker is in
configuration management tool and the
containerization tool which is there
which helps us to wrap or package both
the dependencies and the source code
within a single unit called docker
container and this is the docker
container which the developers use to do
the deployment across multiple
environments
so um as part of the process um when you
are working on the
hosting of your application onto your
docker so ultimately you are looking
forward for an entity called docker
container so if you see if you go
through the diagram over here so in this
one
this is in kind of a basic way uh
architecture that how the docker is
being architect and is getting uh
deployed
so initially you have an infrastructure
like a physical infrastructure is there
you have the uh particular cores memory
infrastructure all those things are
available there now on top of this
infrastructure you are hosting up a host
operating system
this host operating system is
responsible for taking up all the
requests and interacting uh providing a
particular interface between the uh
particular docker and the infrastructure
the core hardware so it acts like a
medium over here
so after the host on operating system on
top of that you are going to install the
docker engine docker software it just
like you got a virtual machine on linux
and on top of that you are installing
the docker software
once the docker engine is installed then
docker engine will take care of
management of the docker containers you
don't really have to uh do a lot of work
docker engine is going to take all the
internal work uh the communication
between the operating system and the
infrastructure so that needs to be done
by the docker engine so docker engine
make sure that the different container
gets uh up and running and you can see
that in this scenario in this diagram we
have container one container two and
container three and all these containers
are actually having its own applications
and the dependencies binded up together
so that's the reason why we are saying
that with the docker we are getting a
complete package end-to-end package is
being given to us in which we have both
the uh particular source code and the
binaries and the executables embedded
inside that so it's a complete package
which is getting created in the form of
docker container and the developer is
responsible for preparing this docker
container so that these containers can
be deployed on the docker host and you
can get your application up and running
so this is what we have docker into our
particular and the architecture of the
docker here now let's see that what are
the different commands we have for the
docker here now the very first one is
that what are the different images
related to commands which is available
there the very first one is the
command which we typically use to
prepare a custom docker image now i can
uh easily go to the docker hub and i can
pull down a docker image which is
available there but let's assume that
you are working on application source
code so you want to prepare a docker
container for that now that docker
container you will not be able to have
it on the docker hub you have to prepare
on your own
right so in order to prepare your own
docker image all you have to do is that
you have to run docker build command now
in this case we
have to prepare a docker file which will
act like a docker a kind of a docker
build script just like in case of maven
we have found xml file and in case of
and we have built.xml file so here we
have the dockerfile which is available
there and this dockerfile make sure that
whatever the steps are mentioned in this
dockerfile in the build script it's
going to perform a series of steps and
the build will be done so docker build
is the command hyphen t is the tag that
what exactly name uh you know whatever
the image you are building so what
exactly tag name you're trying to
provide over here so here we are using a
tag name called my image and then after
the column we are providing that what
version we want to go here 1.0 2.0 5.0
so whatever the version you feel that
you want to uh you know refer you can do
that
now this is the exact way that how in
the actual world the docker images are
getting built up by the respective
vendors let's say that jenkins is born
and jenkins wants to prepare a docker
image so they will be preparing the
docker file in the same manner and
prepare these docker images and publish
it to the docker hub so all the docker
images are built up the custom docker
images are built up with the help of
docker files so docker build is the
command which will process the docker
file and give you a particular docker
image in the end
now how to list down all the docker
images so docker list
ls is something which is there so this
will eventually help you to list down
all the docker images which is listed on
or which is available into your system
so that will be listed out over there
for you
if you feel that you want to remove a
particular image in that case you can go
for docker image rm command and whatever
the image you want to remove you can
give the respective image name and the
tag name there so docker image rm
command is there using which you can
actually see that how the image can be
deleted from the host over here in this
one right so whatever the ways whatever
the you know mechanism is there so we
are making sure that how the image can
be built up and how we can go for the uh
built up and a particular image can be
deployed over here in this case so in
order to delete it in docker image so
you can go for docker image rm command
to remove a docker image completely from
the docker host
so these are some couple of commands
which is available there using which you
can actually interact or manage the
docker image because in order to prepare
in order to run a docker container we
require a source and that source we are
going to get it from the docker image so
now we are going to see that how we can
execute these commands so first of all
what we need to do is that we need to
see that how docker build works for that
we require a docker file so i am going
to have a simple docker file over here
in which we are going to have a basic uh
docker image selected as an ubuntu after
that we are going to go for the one
attribute where we are going to do the
installation of a specific package like
let's say git and accordingly you can
whatever software you want to prepare
you want to set up you can do that and
put up the commands over here in this
docker file so i'm going to save this
file and after that what i need to do is
that i need to run like darker images to
find out that how many images are there
there is no images present so i'm going
to build a docker image over here with
the name of
simplylan or whatever the uh name you
want to give you can
give it over here in this case it's not
any kind of restricted word so you can
give the actual docker image name also
that what for what purpose you are
preparing this image and with that what
will happen that it will take up the uh
values whatever attributes you have put
up into the docker file so that will be
processed and that will be picked up and
once that uh docker file has been
processed has been uh you know prepared
you will be able to see that yes a final
product or a final docker image is
finalized and prepared over here in this
one so we just have to wait for the
whole process to complete and once my
docker image is prepared i will be able
to have a particular setup done or
achieved over here so that's what we
require over here in this one to be
performed
now once the installation is done so you
will be able to see like the final
docker image is being prepared over here
so it says successfully built which
means that the docker image is prepared
now if you run like docker images you
will be able to find out that this image
is available over here in this one now
you are seeing like two images because
one is like the basic image which is
being pulled down because we are using a
docker file to do that to process that
one there
now in case you want to remove it so all
you need to do is that you need to run
like docker
image
rm and simply learn
so if you do that what will happen that
your docker image which is related to
simply learn will be wiped off from your
system and in case you want to do like
removal of the uber to also so that also
you can do over here with the help of
docker imager
rm
ubuntu and that will be removed from
your system so your docker images will
be removed from your system using the uh
particular command called docker
um image and then rm command to remove
the docker image from your system from
your host here so that's how you deal
with the different docker images uh
commands over here in this one now let's
go back to the document now the next
section over here is the docker
container commands over here so all the
commands related to docker containers is
what we are going to talk about over
here now the very first one is the uh
particular container so
in order to create a container so you
can run the command called docker create
and the image because for a container
you require a docker image that's a
pre-request so once the docker image is
prepared you can just simply run docker
create command and that will help you to
create a container onto your system now
if you want to run a particular um you
want to create a container and you want
to run it also at the same time so in
that situation you can go for a docker
run command the main difference between
the docker create and docker run command
is that the docker run command is going
to uh run a container and uh it's going
to give you a response from the command
but
the docker create command is going to
create only the container so once the
container is up and running so that's
only being done by the docker create
command but the docker run command is
going to actually do the
uh preparation of the container also and
at the same time you are being given as
in particular response also like you
know what a command you want to run so
that response also you will be able to
get here and if you feel that you want
to rename an existing container so for
that you can go for the docker rename
command so existing container you can
rename it with the new container and
that's how the particular rename of an
existing container will be done with on
to the docker host here so docker rename
is the command using which you can
rename an existing container and you can
get a new container over here in this
case
so these are some of the options some of
the ways that how you can interact with
the containers how you can manage them
onto your docker host over here so you
can run it you can create it and you can
rename the containers also so now what
we're going to do is that we're going to
see that how we can work on this
particular container commands here so
first of all i'm going to quickly pull
down uh jenkins image so that i can
create a container out of that so it's
in kind of a 600 round mv docker image
which is available there now you can
also have a custom docker image prepared
using the dockerfile or you can have a
ready-made docker image pull down from
the docker hub also so this is going to
pull the latest version of the jenkins
from the docker hub so that we will be
able to proceed further on that and we
will be able to continue with the
hosting so we will be converting or
running this uh specific docker images
in the form of docker containers so that
we will be able to have uh instance of
docker container over here running in
this one so that's what we are trying to
do here
so we just wait for this a pull activity
to complete because it's an heavy darker
image so it may take some time to
download and once it's download you will
be able to see that docker
images is showing a specific docker
image of jenkins here now you're going
to create a container out of that so
you're going to run a command called
docker create and jenkins over here
so that will help us to do uh the
creation of a docker container and once
that is done so you will be able to see
like using docker ps command that if any
container is up and running and if you
go for docker psyphony you will be able
to see that yes a particular docker
container is in
created mode now this is not in running
mode because you see that when i ran the
docker ps command it was not showing it
in the running mode because i just
created a docker container here and the
created status also shows that yes the
docker container is created but it did
not run over here
so if
you want to run it so definitely you can
say like docker start
and
[Music]
you can give the container name and that
will help me to
start my container over here but of
course you if you feel that you want to
directly create a container and you know
you don't want to create the container
only you want to start it also so in
that case you can go for the docker run
command so docker run command is
something which can be used instead of
doing the execution so you can say like
docker
run
jenkins
and what it will do it will definitely
help you to get the
container created onto of the jenkins
over here in this case it's not like
only creating a container but in fact
it's actually starting the container
also so you can see that it started over
here into your screen itself that whole
jenkins gets initialized over here in
this one so this is the way that how you
can initialize or you can create a
container now i can just do a control c
over here because it says that and
jenkins is up and running so you can
start using this one according to your
requirement over here right so i'm just
doing ctrl c so that it can be stopped
over there
right now
so this is the way that how uh typically
we can create the containers now we got
like two containers over here and one is
up and running and one is something
which i just closed just now over here
now if you feel that you want to rename
a container let's say like this is a
container which is available but it's
not having a meaningful name now i want
to convert into a meaningful name like
dev underscore jenkins so that you can
easily do with the help of docker rename
command because that will rename the
docker container name so that you will
be able to connect on to that and you
can go for the processing so that's what
we can get over here in this one so this
is how you can do the
various management of the resources over
here so let's go back to the main
content
now if you feel that you want to remove
all these top containers because what
happens that sometimes we simply stop
the container but we do not remove it
from the
docker hose because
we are not
going for the cleanup now clean cleanup
is very required because these
containers are actually taking up the
disk space also so we need to make sure
that we should be using we should be
having like minimum amount of disk space
utilization so for that what we need
really need to do is that we need to run
docker container prune command so this
will basically help you to prune or do
the cleanup uh purge of all the
containers which is running on the host
machine here
and that will definitely help us to
remove all the containers which is in
stop status so that will be simply
removed over here in this one so
this really completely removes all these
top containers onto the docker host over
here in this scenario
now second one is that it creates a new
image from a container's file changes
now the
way what happens that normally what we
follow is that we use the docker build
command to do the build process right so
docker build command is being used in
that particular way now if you really
want to go for a preparation of a new
you know image so all you need to do is
that you need to create a new image from
a container file
so you can run the command called docker
container commit command and you know
whatever container is there so that will
be saved or preserved as a docker image
because sometimes we also do some ad hoc
changes or modifications on the fly
inside the docker container by going
inside the docker container and doing
the steps so we really need to preserve
those steps and that is the reason why
we are converting a docker container in
the form of a docker image here so
that's what we are trying to perform
here so docker container is something
which is uh being uh done over here in
such a way that whatever the steps
whatever the changes we are trying to do
so that needs to be performed over here
in this case so docker container uh
commit command is being used so that we
can get a particular you know final
image as part of the container so the
container will be converted in the form
of a docker image over here
and the last one is that how we can
remove an existing container so we can
go for the docker rm command which is
available there using which you will be
able to go ahead and you can get a
particular container removed from your
existing system so docker rm command is
pretty much there using which we can see
that how we can remove an existing
container from your system as such
what exactly now we are going to see
that how we can perform the various
commands on the containers here
the very first command which we want to
do here is that uh you know in order to
see that how we can actually remove all
these top containers but for this one
what we really need to do is that we
need to first of all run some couple of
containers so i'm going to quickly run a
container called docker
run hyphen d httpd
so i'm going to run a particular web
server over here and
it should be able to give me a proper
container up and running so i can just
double check or value that it as with
the help of the
docker ps command
so docker ps command should give me the
proper confirmation that whether the
container is in up and running over here
or not so you can see that it's up
entering from last 11 seconds here now
we got a command where you know for
example we have got some stopped
containers but again you have to
manually remove them one by one now if
you don't want to do that stuff if you
feel that whatever the stock containers
which is available that should be
automatically removed from your system
then we have one command called docker
container prong now for this what we
really need to do is that we need to
actually stop this container because
again it will be only picked up like
whatever the containers which is
available in these top setters only
those will be picked up
so i have copied the uh container name
here in this case and i need to stop it
so that i will be able to
remove it with the prone command over
here in this one and then i can run like
docker
container
print command which will basically
remove all the containers which is in
these top stitches and once that is done
you will be able to see like that is
something which is completely gone from
your system so this is a way that how it
can not only take care of these top
containers but it's actually being done
so that you can remove the multiple
containers with a single command itself
over here so this is not something which
will be executed one by one on a
different container but yes good grammar
and spelling are important
but if you want to write essays that
inspire
it is free completely cross platform
that is
has
it's called getanime.com the other
software needs internet access
so go ahead and install the software on
your operating system for this instance
i am using a windows computer so i will
software just like download install nes
windows software though make sure you
run the right version that is if you're
having a 64-bit computer then run the
x64 version
also sometimes window might detect it as
a mac but it is just a case of false
show hidden icons you will
because
you will be
so if your router supports maximum 51
mbps which most of that
then you will get around 21 divided by
eight that is around two to three mbps
transfers
but why are we dividing it by right so
these are the commands
in the management
so once the container is restart so
whatever the application running inside
the container so that will also
help
um
operations
start is also there which can help you
to see that how the containers is are
really available so this is the way that
how you can manage like you know even
the restarts and all because this really
helps you to even do the restart or
bounces to the application which is
present inside this container so that
also you will be able to see with this
particular component here
so that let's go back to the main
content and then um you know killing a
running container so if you really want
to kill a container so for that we can
go for the docker kill because rocket
stop is also going to stop the container
but if you want to forcefully kill it so
in that case you can go for the docker
kill command to do that particular
kill on the containers and then if you
really want to go inside the container
and you want to attach your terminal so
for that you can go for the docker
attach command and with this what will
happen that you can go inside the
container you can do whatever the
changes you want to perform you can do
that and you can again come back outside
that also so normally typically we use
it so that we can see some errors of uh
in the logs which is coming up in the
containers and if any kind of issues are
coming up for the applications we should
be able to know that part
now the last one is the uh particular
weight docker weight is there so that
will block a container and uh it will go
in the wait status so docker weight and
the container id or the container name
you can give so with that the particular
container will go into the block status
let's see somewhat more uh commands over
here so we can run like docker container
ls again to find out like what container
is available so you can see that this
particular container is available over
here in this one now if you see like if
i want to get uh attached to this
container if i want to attach my input
and output stream with this container so
you can run like docker
attach and the container id so your
terminal will be stuck over here because
it's taking up whatever the progress
which is going to be done in the
container that will be in you know a
kind of attached to your terminal over
here and you will be getting the output
but the moment you come out of this like
you say control c
so you will see that you know it's
basically sending the request to the
container that is getting stopped so you
will be able to see like the docker
container list it's not going to show
you because the container is in stop
status so again you have to do the
restart of the container to make sure
that the container is up and running
right so the attach one will help you to
go uh and attach your standard input and
output with your container with a
running container but when the moment
you comes out you will be able to uh
disconnect or shut down the container
and again i had to restart that
container over here in this one then
again of course we have like docker
weight
then container is there so this will
basically put the
container into a block status because
all the requests and all will be not
sent to the container and it will be
blocked and uh
if you really want to like
consume or if you want to make use of
the container you will not be able to do
that so docker weight command will us
kind of a block the container and you
know if you again uh try to come out of
that so
again the request to the container will
be uh
resumed and they will be able to use on
that part so docker read command is
being used to block the container and
then we have docker attached to attach
to the container the standard input and
output and lastly is the docker kill
which is going to kill the container
and you will be able to uh see that the
container is in simply killed status so
it's uh you know it's not like a stopped
over here if it's gracefully stopped
then the exit code definitely will be
zero but in this case since it's being
killed the particular status is 137 over
here in this one so that's a non-zero
status code so that's how where you will
be able to manage the containers on
different aspects let's go back to the
main container so these were some of the
commands which was there from the docker
containers perspective let's talk about
some of the commands from the share
command perspective so how we can share
the docker images
so we have a typical pull push mechanism
which is there using which we can
actually interact with the docker hub or
a docker registry so uh if you really
want to pull a docker image so in that
case you can go for the docker pull
command
if you want to push an image to the
registry so you can use for the docker
push command if you want to execute a
command inside a particular running
container or you want to uh execute a
command or a script or something like
that so you can go for the docker as a
command and with that the execution will
be done and you will be able to get a
response so that will make sure that yes
whatever the execution you are trying to
do so that will be done over here in
this mechanism now let's see that how we
can do a pull and push activity to a
docker image so first of all the pull
command is pretty simple all you need to
do is that you need to say that okay i
want to pull a docker image
uh if let's say that our docker image is
already present then it's just going to
say that it's already up to date it's
already available there but if uh in
some cases you feel that the docker
image is not available and you want to
pull it so all you can do is that you
can give that a docker image name and
that you can give the tag also but in
this case we are using the tag as in
latest
so that's the reason why even if you
provide or you don't provide it doesn't
really matter so i'm going to give like
a docker pull a mysql over here and the
moment i hit on this one what will
happen that it says this a particular
docker image is not available into my
system it's going to download it and
once it's going to be downloaded you
will be able to see that into your local
system so docker images is something
which is going to help you with the
commands and it will give you the
particular ways that how the docker
image is available so i can run like
docker images over here to see that what
are the different docker images which is
available in this manner
now if you really want to move any of
the docker image then of course you have
to do a docker login
and uh you will be doing the
uh you know the connectivity to the
docker hub and then establish the
connectivity and all so what you need to
do is that you can run the docker login
command we will also see this command in
the next particular slide but right now
we are just doing it because we want to
showcase that how the push really works
so you can actually give your
username that uh what username you are
holding up
so the password does not shows any
activity but yes still it will let you
know that whether the login is
successful or not so in this case it
says login is successful so all you need
to do is let's say like i got this
custom image and i want to push it to
the docker hub so
you need to rename or you need to do a
tag over here because the same if you
run
docker push
custom
image
colon version one so if you do that it
will not be pushed into these uh
particular docker hub so it's going to
throw e error over here that the access
is denied so all you need to do is that
you need to do a tag here
so you have to rename it in such a way
that you should be able to uh use uh add
your username over there because docker
hub will identify that if it's there
with your username then only it will be
pushed otherwise it will be simply
rejected over there so that's what you
need to do you need to rename your
docker image uh the same docker image
which you have you have to append your
username of the docker hub and once that
is done so all you need to do is that
you need to just run like docker
then push is there
then this image name and then version
one
so the moment you do this what will
happen that it will start transferring
those docker image to the docker hub you
see this specifies that yes this is
going to the docker hub docker.io where
my username is there and this is the
custom image which is available there so
if i refresh my page on the docker hub i
will be able to see like this public
repo which is available there but again
this one just requires a credentials and
the login which we did in just a last
command where we ran the docker login
command to do the login to the portal
and after that only we are able to do
the setup and the modifications over
here so that's how you do the login and
you are able to connect on that now
these are some of the pull and push
operations but let's say that if you got
a container which is up and running like
this is uh
right now we are not getting any
container which is available over here
so you can say like docker run
hyphen d hd pd like i'm just running a
dummy container over here so that i will
be able to
show you this command now if you for
some reason want to go inside the
container and want to see some
processing and want to see some content
so you can run the command called docker
asic
iphone id and there you can give the
container id this is nothing but the
full format of the container id which is
given to you so you can use this one
also or you can use the shortened also
shortened value also you can use and
then the last we can say like bash the
moment you do this you will be going you
will be going inside the container you
see that this is the hostname which is
being shown as the container id you can
do a like psiphon ef command and it will
throw an error that the ps command is
not available because you are running
this command into the docker into the
docker container so using these kind of
commands which is not available in
container will help you to identify that
yes you are not on the host machine you
are in fact into the docker container so
that's the reason why you can do it
because for you the parts and all
everything is same the terminal is also
same so you may not be able to
differentiate in that part so that's the
reason why it's preferred that we use
that uh commands which is going to fail
but that's okay it will give you that
okay this command is failing because i
am into the docker container right now
so that's what we are performing over
here
right and you can come out of that but
still the docker container is going to
be still up and running over here in
this case so the container is not going
to
be down over here in this one so that's
how we manage the container we can go
inside and we can check some
informations and get some files there
so these are some of the commands where
we can interact now in order to log into
the docker hub because before doing the
docker push you have to log in you have
to get a credentials and the
connectivity with docker hub so you can
run the docker login command where you
can see that how the execution can be
done now using the docker login command
you can interact with the particular
docker hub you can set up the
credentials once the credentials is
being set up so what you can do is that
you can go ahead and say that okay
the uh configurations is done and uh we
can go ahead and we can perform the
execution so docker login is the command
where you can give the credentials
docker info is the command using which
you can get the uh information about the
docker tool so whatever the docker info
is available there so those things you
can actually get it over here in the
case of the docker info so docker info
is going to give you complete
information that what exactly you have
the information available over here on
this one
and then we have the docker history so
using the docker history you can see
history of the docker image that what
exactly uh the mechanisms or what are
the different image ids are available
there so this is basically giving you
the complete history on how the
docker image is prepared all the
commands is available there and that
will help you to eventually go and
understand that how the images can be
going on and you can manage on that part
so these are some of the couple of
options which is available there where
we can see that how the executions can
be done and we can go ahead on that
particular part so docker history is the
command again which will help you to see
that how you can go for the particular
mechanism and you can listen on on the
things over there so docker login was
already done previously when we try to
push the image but again if you try to
run docker login you will be able to do
that now docker info is something which
will give some additional information
about the docker and uh all the
informations about the docker will be
given back to you over here in this one
so the complete clarity
uh then let's say that you got a docker
image called uh
httpd now you want to check the history
of this image that how this image is
prepared what are the different layers
which is available how many layers are
there how much size is being modified in
each and every layer so you can see that
we got a layer where we have a
particular changes of 7.838 mb but
pretty much the uh company from the
complete size of this httpd the major
portion is actually of the uh this one
the basic operating system which is
being implemented and then of course
there are some packages which got
deployed due to which this uh 60 mb and
7 mp size is coming up there so this
actually gives you the complete layer
wise mechanism that what are the
informations which is available that how
the modifications actually got modified
and got
changed over here in this one so this is
the additional uh help which you can get
from the docker to
manage the containers here
so these are the ways where you can
interact with the docker hub if you
really want to create a volumes for the
container so you can go for the docker
volume create command so docker volume
create command is there using which you
can create the docker volumes and uh you
can pretty much do that uh setup so
docker volume create is the command
which is available there for that
particular part it will create a volume
for you now let's see that how we can
actually work with the volume so you can
run the command called docker volume ls
to find out at what are the different
volumes which is available there now if
you really want to create a volume over
here in this one so you can say like
darker volume create and you can go for
the uh volume name here
now the moment you do that what will
happen that a volume will be created and
you can validate it with the help of
docker volume ls command that whether
the volume is being created or not over
here so this is the way that how you can
manage the volumes onto the docker host
now let's talk about some of the docker
swamp commands here now docker swamp
commands is there to set up a particular
mechanism where you can see that how you
can perform a setup you can actually go
ahead and see that how the setup and
modifications can be done
so docker swam is there where we can see
that how the execution needs to be done
so
you can go for the command called docker
spam init command this will actually go
for an initialization of our docker
swamp cluster and once the docker spam
cluster is initialized then you can
pretty much go there and perform
whatever the executions you want to
perform you can do that and you can
execute as such over there so docker
swap in it is a command using which you
can actually see that how the execution
needs to be done
and how we can perform the uh you know
mechanism and the changes over here so
docker sam in
uh hyphen f1 advice uh adr address is
there which helps you to see that how
the executions can be done
now joins you have the docker swamp join
command which is available there now if
you go for docker spam join command so
uh you can have a particular host so
docker's swam join command is there
which you can run on the node machine
and in that case what will happen that
node will be a part of the docker spam
cluster
and then if you want to leave uh from
the swamp cluster then you can go for
docker swam leave command and it will be
simply removed from the docker swamp
cluster there some of the couple of
commands which using which we can
initialize or we can
remove from the docker spam cluster here
so docker
spam is already being initialized or
it's been created when the moment you do
the installation of docker so docker
swam in it is the command using which
you can interlast uh analyze the docker
container now once you analyze over here
so initial after the initialization you
got a command you which you want to add
it like you want to run it onto the
docker spam uh cluster
it will act like a worker node so that
you will be able to deploy the
containers on top of that
also if you want to join it as a manager
so you can also get the join token again
so it will give you the proper command
now if you run like docker
node ls so you will be able to see like
what are the different nodes which is
available there and for any reason if
you're not comfortable with that and you
want to reinitialize your docker spam
cluster so all you can do is that you
can say like docker
swamp
leave iphone f and you will be left out
of the docker spam and now if you want
to run like knock docker node ls you
will not be able to get that output
because it's saying that there is no uh
particular swap manager which is
available so you can run docker spam in
it or you can run the join command to
connect to that specific node but we
have already left it and nothing is
available over here so that's a way that
how you can manage like what are the
different docker spam commands we can
typically run to manage the docker spam
cluster now let's talk about the docker
compose commands now docker compose
commands is actually there using which
we can create multiple containers it's
not only one container which can we can
create we can create go for multiple
creations of the containers with the
help of docker compose file so docker
compose hyphen version is the u command
which we can give you the version of
docker compose which is being used so
here we use a particular vml format file
which will help us to create the
multiple containers we define the
services that what are the different
containers we want to create here
and then with the help of docker hyphen
compose dot ml file we can create or we
can have that particular docker compose
file setup over here in this case so
docker hyphen compose dot vml file is
used to do the setup and the
modification so that you will be able to
have the modifications done and you will
be able to find out a particular
multiple containers gets created all
together so docker compose is there is
the way that how you can do the setup
how you are going to run the docker
compose file so in that case you're
going to run the docker hyphen compose
up command which will help you to set up
like how the compose can be done and
once you are done with the docker hyphen
compose up command so using this the
compose will be done and the containers
will be up and running so these are the
commands using which we can manage
multiple containers using the docker
compose one so let's try to run some
commands related to docker compose so
docker hyphen compose iphone version
will let you know that what exactly
version of docker compose is installed
into your system
so you can run typical apt command to do
the installation so docker hyphen
composes the package name which you can
install so that the executables and the
package can be installed into your
system onto the server
now
all we need to do is that we need to
create a docker compose file so what we
need to do is that we need to create a
docker hyphen compose dot yml file is
the default name of the vml file which
we want to create here that's a standard
name so once you create this all you
need to do is like you need to put some
values attributes the very first one is
the version value that what version of
uh this uh particular attribute you want
to create here let's say that i want to
create a version too so i will configure
here that yes the version 2 is what i
require i want to set up over here in
this one
now again if i want to configure that
what are the different services we want
to run because services is the main
thing which we will be running on this
machine on the server here so that's
what we require so then we need to put
for a particular service called web so
web service we want to search and we
want to run and then again we need to
take care about the spacing because
that's a very important part
and we need to provide the values of the
image
and
all these configurations here so that
you should be able to set up like how
the uh images and how the docker images
can be built up over here so web is the
service which you want to deploy and
then of course the image is the
attribute which is there for the web
that yes engine is the one which we are
trying to build up now you can give the
ports configuration also so you can say
like ports
and inside that you can say like what
port mapping you want to perform so you
can say like
um 8080 so sorry 80 is what you can dash
for the nginx because it runs on 80 port
but now i have to run like 80 port i
want to attach that port over here in
this one so i can specify that 80 port
should be available in this one so i'm
going to save this one here and i'm
going to run a command called docker
iphone compose up now this will run the
containers in the interactive mode but
if you feel that i want to run in the
detach mode so you can say like hyphen d
also which will of course run these ones
into the detach mode and it will be
executed so it will process your docker
compose file and since you have used a
standard name called hyphen docker
hyphen compose dot primal so it will
automatically pick that docker
details and start creating the container
hi guys in today's video i am going to
show you how to install ubuntu on
kubernetes kubernetes is an open source
platform used for deployment and
management of containers so let's get
started now the first step is to install
the necessary dependencies using two of
the commands first is sudo apt get
update which gets all the updates
and then you have to enter a password
so this will take a few seconds
that's done the next step is to install
app transport https this is basically
used to make repositories via https so
let's go ahead with that sudo
okay that's done going ahead the next
thing we have to do is to install the
docker dependency using the command sudo
apt install docker dot io
you have to choose y
and this will take a few minutes
okay that's done so after installing the
docker we have to start and enable the
docker using the command sudo system ctl
start docker and sudo system ctl enable
dock
so now the docker is enabled so now we
are done with the first step of
installation the next step is we have to
install the necessary components for
kubernetes before that we have to
install the curl command because current
command is used to send data using a url
syntax let's install the curl command
using the command sudo apt-get install
curve
so you have to select y
and this will take few minutes
[Music]
so moving on the next step we have to do
is download and add key for kubernetes
installation from a url so let's go
ahead with that sudo curl
so this is where we get the key and then
we have to add it using sudo apt key add
and it's done so the next step is we
have to add a repository in a certain
location so before doing that we have to
change the permission of that file so we
do that using c or sudo chmod command
okay so the permission is changed now
let's go ahead and save this file in
that location first we have to enter
this command into the file
this is a url
save as
so we have to save it in this location
let's rename this to
kubernetes
okay
now moving forward now we have to check
for any updates
in the next command we are going to
install the kubernetes components that
is cubelet qad vector and kubernetes
this one
okay that's done
so
moving forward the next step is to
deploy paths using the following command
[Music]
now the pods have been deployed to our
network to see all the parts you have to
use the command sudo cubic till get pods
there you can see the paws that have
been deployed hello and welcome to
simplyland today we're going to be
giving you a kubernetes tutorial will
provide the overview of how and why you
should be using kubernetes but before we
get started don't forget to hit the
subscribe button and the like button if
you want to get notified about
additional content from simply learn and
as always if you have any comments about
the material that you're about to see
and you have any questions please post
them in the comments below we do read
them and we do reply to them so with
that said let's jump in so we're going
to go through a bunch of things today
around kubernetes we're going to cover
what kubernetes is and why you should be
using it along with the features of
kubernetes we're also going to take a
little bit of a look at kubernetes
versus docker swarm as the two
technologies do tend to get referred to
quite frequently and then we'll do a
deep dive into the actual kubernetes
architecture itself and how kubernetes
runs and operates within your network
and then finally we're going to look at
some kubernetes use cases of how you can
actually apply best learnings that other
companies have used with kubernetes
we'll finish everything off with a demo
where we actually step through and use
some of the actual codes that you can
actually use to run uh from your
terminal window to actually activate
kubernetes itself so with that said
let's jump in so why kubernetes well
kubernetes is really being built from
allowing you to be able to have a more
reliable infrastructure the tool itself
is designed to manage the containers you
have within your network it's very
modular in architecture which allows it
to be very easy to be able to maintain
and to be able to scale
one of the reasons why kubernetes was
created was to be able to scale up the
deployment of software into tens of
thousands of networks and servers within
a data center and then finally when you
start working with kubernetes really
what you're doing is laying the
foundation for building cloud native
applications and
[Music]
solutions that you're really building
out an infrastructure that's designed
for cloud-centric solution delivery so
let's dig into why what kubernetes is so
the history of kubernetes is that it was
originally developed by google google
actually used the precursor to
kubernetes to manage and maintain the
data structured and data infrastructure
that they had within their network they
really liked it and one of the big
benefits that kubernete that google
provided is that they uh converted their
code into an open source program that
they released as kubernetes in 2014 and
made an open source this means that any
company can use kubernetes there's no
charge for it all you have to do is know
how to use the command lines to actually
get up and running the benefit of
kubernetes being open source is that
most cloud providers now support
kubernetes so whether you're using
microsoft azure you're using google
cloud or aws you'll find that you can
actually use it
really helped eliminate manual processes
so it allowed for deploying and scanning
and we have a number of features that we
want to kind of step through again the
first thing that kubernetes is a strong
benefit of is that it eliminates those
manual processes and allows you to
automate them the benefit you have from
this is that you can then scale up your
automation across your entire network so
whether you are
that something you simply didn't have
before kubernetes is also well managed
of working with kubernetes is that not
only is it a cloud-centric solution but
it was really built from a core need of
a secure solution so security is at the
heart and center of all the work you're
doing which really helps benefit any
teams scaling out containers your
kubernetes environment will be
constantly monitored and so that when
you have nodes that have your containers
the health of those nodes is being
constantly communicated back to
the kubernetes environment so that the
entire environment is always being
managed and checked so if you have any
um additional hosting and launching that
needs to be done kubernetes will help
you automate those manual processes uh
if something does go wrong you can
actually set up your kubernetes
environment to do an automatic roll back
again this is just allowing you to have
that confidence that when you're
deploying a solution that everything is
going to work within that environment
and then finally kubernetes will allow
you to mount and add the storage needed
to run your apps so whether you have
storage such as a local ssd storage
device physically on the hardware or if
you're connecting to storage via the
cloud kubernetes will allow you to
access the storage you need how you're
accessing it so let's look a little bit
into the differences between kubernetes
and docker swarm so if we just step back
a little bit uh kubernetes and docker
often get connected with each other
largely because kubernetes manages
containers and docker is really famous
for creating the most popular uh
container management solution which is
called docker um if you're a developer
you're probably already using docker
today so one of the things that
kubernetes is really really good at is
that it manages containers at scale just
massive volume of containers docker
swarm is docker's alternative to
kubernetes is a tool that allows you to
also manage large number large numbers
of containers um there are differences
between the two of them and right now
without doubt the most popular open
source solution out there is kubernetes
from google it just has a massive
community behind it and the community uh
really have embraced um kubernetes um
yes the original product was by
developed by google but google has been
great steward and they've allowed the
community to drive the future evolution
of the product uh docker swarm is
actually managed and developed by docker
there is a smaller community but it is
also a very passionate community and the
reason being is that both products are
actually pretty good and you just really
kind of have to choose which one you
want to go with without doubt there is
more customization and extensions built
for kubernetes simply because the
community is just so much bigger than
the docker swarm community but with that
said docker swarm is really easy to set
up so if you are used to working within
the docker environment you will be able
to set up docker swarm very very quickly
whereas kubernetes does require some
heavy lifting to get up and running now
with that said if you are using
microsoft azure or google cloud very
often those environments will actually
set up kubernetes for you so you don't
have to do it and you can actually then
focus on writing the instructions to
maintain your kubernetes environment
kubernetes um has extremely high fault
tolerance again
it's because kubernetes is has been road
tested the foundation for kubernetes is
based on managing sites such as gmail
google.com youtube i mean just
incredibly robust environment compared
to docker swarm which has lower fault
tolerance and and this really kind of
leads into
the final areas where kubernetes does
guarantee um strong clusters and
management just a really reliable
environment docker swarm however is able
to
take containers and deploy them into
large casters very very quickly
and be interesting to watch how
kubernetes matures
so let's dig into the kubernetes
architecture
and we should have a link in the
comments that you can select that will
take you to that video
hardware within a specific unit and so a
node is really a physical machine uh in
a data center or a virtual machine and
when you're setting up an environment on
a cloud environment such as microsoft
azure or google cloud or aws kubernetes
will be managing the containers within
that node so it's important to know that
kubernetes itself doesn't work with the
individual nodes but actually works with
the cluster as a whole and and why
that's important is that it's a tool to
manage your entire environment it's not
going to come down and manage the
individual node itself it's going to
match the entire environment the actual
control of data within a cluster and
it's very flexible within kubernetes you
can have local storage such as an ssd
card or a traditional local storage or
you can actually connect to the cloud
and use cloud-based storage and the
benefit that cloud-based storage offers
you is that you are increasingly moving
your solution into more of a
hardware free environment cloud-based
architecture where you're not reliant on
a physical piece of hardware within your
data center and why that's important is
that it gives you the opportunity to
scale up your solutions much more
effectively so if you need to increase
the hard drive space you can do that
very easily from the cloud whereas local
hardware is a little bit harder to
manage great news kubernetes gives you
both options to be able to
choose from and so the the next layer
down is the actual management of the
application and that's within a
container and as mentioned earlier
docker is the most popular container
solution out there and again if you're a
developer you're probably already using
docker as it was a natural maturity from
using a virtual machine but kubernetes
itself will actually manage the
containers that you have within your
nodes and so you have a collection of
containers working together and then you
pull those together into what's called a
pod and what's great is kubernetes will
actually manage the health of that part
so if a container or a pod fails
kubernetes will automatically deploy out
a replica so your entire environment can
stay running and being efficient and so
the pods themselves will actually be
managed by kubernetes and you really
want to
let kubernetes um do this because it's
allowing you to step away from the
manual management of parts your
environment is just going to be
healthier relying on kubernetes to do
the actual management of all the pods
you have out there so you are able to
allow access to from services outside of
your kubernetes and this is done through
a process called ingress and
going back earlier we talked about how
security is a key part of all the work
that goes into kubernetes and this is a
great example of where you can use an
external service but still have that
layer of security that is vital for your
solution because to be able to provide
the ingress connection kubernetes
requires an ssl connection which um
automatically allows for a secure data
transfer absolutely fantastic so here we
have an overview of the actual
architecture on the right hand side we
have our nodes and the pods within our
nodes and within those pods are the
containers on the left hand side we have
the master architecture and the master
architecture is the actual brains behind
the work that you're doing it's actually
managing the schedules the controllers
for all of the nodes and then at the
bottom left-hand side we have commands
which are written on a local workstation
and those commands are pushed up to the
master so let's kind of dig a little bit
further into the architecture of the
master um so the master itself is
comprised of a number of key components
again this is the tool that's going to
manage your
entire kubernetes infrastructure the key
components that you have are the
etcd control manager scheduler api
server and the key four components are
etcd
or the cluster store the controller
manager the scheduler and the api server
the cluster store is the tool where all
the details of the work that you're
doing is stored and it's going to manage
the rules going to manage all the
instructions and this is where you're
going to post that information the
controller is actually going to then
perform the tasks that are stored in the
cluster store and as you'd expect the
schedule is the tool that actually
controls when instructions and tasks are
pushed out to
all the pods and nodes within your
network and then finally you have an api
server which allows you to be able to
control all the operations the actual
operations themselves are all
instructions written um as rest
instructions and which allows you to
take advantage of the security that has
been built into rest and so you end up
with a worker slave architecture and
slaves are all the different nodes and
pods within your network and so a part
itself will have multiple one or more
multiple containers and then each
container and then each pod will have a
docker container a kubelet and a
kubernetes proxy and the these are tools
to allow you to communicate back up to
the master layer so the docker is the
actual container itself and this is
going to actually run your application
and
the instructions here are to pull down
the correct container from the docker
images that you have within your library
the cubelet is going to manage your
containers and your container
instructions that will be deployed to
the cubelet are going to be written in
either yaml or json format yaml is just
great if you haven't had a chance to
start working with yaml i certainly
encourage you to do so it's very easy to
pick up if you know any xml you'll pick
up yaml very quickly and finally the
kubernetes proxy is the tool that
interacts with the master environment
within the kubernetes network and allows
all the instructions from that are
pushed to the kubelet and to docker to
be able to perform effectively so let's
have a look at some of the companies
using kubernetes there are a lot and if
you're doing any work today in the cloud
and or even if you're just starting off
and doing some simple work in the cloud
there's a really good chance that you
are using kubernetes but some of the
companies that you would are probably
not surprised at using kubernetes are
spotify sap ebay
and of course uh some of the the big
companies out there google with their
entire network of solutions and
microsoft with office and their tools so
let's take a a step into a uber now
let's have a look at a kubernetes use
case and in this example we're gonna
look at the new york times and how they
use kubernetes to solve a problem that
their iit department was struggling with
so when new york times started working
after their data centers their their
actual deployments were small and the
applications were managed across vms but
the problem is is that as new york times
became more of a digital company they
started building more digital solutions
and at some point they realized that
what they needed to do was to embrace
the cloud and move all their solutions
to the cloud however their first step of
using the cloud and this is i think
typical for a lot of companies is they
treated the cloud hosted provider in the
same way as they would with a data
center and they at some point they
realized they had to take a change and
this is where the development team came
in and they said look how about we stop
thinking of our solutions as a data
center even though they're being run in
amazon and start thinking them as cloud
first solutions and so what they
proposed and what they ended up doing
was using google cloud platform with
kubernetes as a service and to
provide greater efficiency and so by
using kubernetes they had the following
advantages they're able to deliver
solutions at a much faster speed and in
the world of digital content speed is
everything they were able to reduce the
time for deployment from minutes to
seconds and by doing this they were able
to increase the amount of time that
uptime for the actual infrastructure
updates began to be deployed
independently and when required so you
didn't have to schedule an event when
you did the deployment it just happened
and there was more unified approach to
deployment from the engineering staff
which just made the whole solution more
portable so the fundamental end line for
the new york times is that by leveraging
kubernetes they were able to
automatically manage their deployments
and scheduling of solutions instead of
having to do solutions through a more
traditional ticket-based system it just
really speed up the efficiency of the
new york times website so let's finally
kind of look into some of the important
terminologies before we take our time to
do a demo so we have six terms that
we're going to look through um and uh
we'll let you uh read through this but
we have a cluster which is a set of
machines physical vertical in which
applications are managed and run we have
a node that are the working machines
that run containerized applications and
other workloads there is the pod which
is within a node and is a group of
containers that are deployed together on
the same host we have replication
controllers and a replication controller
is used to define a pod life cycle
rather than to create the pods directly
we have a selector which is an
expression matched label to filter
specific resources uh labels are key
value pairs that are attached to objects
such as parts and the key value pair or
the label can be filtered organize and
perform operations on resources
replication sets define how many
replicas of each pod will be running and
manage when you want to either replace a
pod when it dies annotation is a label
with much larger data capacity a name is
a resource as it is identified volume is
the directory which data is accessible
to a container namespaces provide
additional qualification to resources
name and then finally service is an
abstraction of a top-tier pods which
provide a single iep address and dns
name by which the pods can be accessed
so at this time what we want to do is
take you through kubernetes demo
actually runs through some of these
basic controls so i'm going to take you
through a video of how to actually
install kubernetes um and to use some of
the basic instructions so kubernetes is
the most widely used platform for
container management the first step is
to actually install the necessary
dependencies so let's see if there's any
updates first so the first so to check
if there's any updates we use the
command sudo app dash get update i'm
going to enter in our password and this
looks like it's going to take a few
minutes because we've got a few updates
that need to be running all right we're
done all right next we're going to write
sudo apt-get install dash y apt dash
transport https and this will install
all the dependencies we need to actually
start installing the solutions needed
for kubernetes all right that was quick
now we're going to put in the docker
dependency and the way we do that is
write the command sudo apt install
docker dot io i'll go typo correct that
quickly and put in y so for yes and we
continue and it's going to take a while
because we're going to download and
install docker off the internet and it's
quite a large installation now would be
a good time to go get a cup of coffee
because it'll take us about a minute to
get this all done once we actually have
docker installed we'll let you go ahead
and we'll start docker and enable docker
using our sudo commands
all right so that's all done so let's
start to enable docker we're using so
we're going to use sudo system ctl start
docker and sudo system ctl enable docker
this will be quite quick
so the next step is to install all the
components for kubernetes and we're
going to
install the curl command and then
kubulat cube c and then cube adm and
we're going to install all the necessary
tools we'll do the curl command cubelet
cubic c2 and cube adm and so let's go
ahead and put in the sudo apt-get
install curl we're going to get a prompt
we can say yes for that
and then after this we'll go ahead and
install kubernetes so the first what
we're going to do is we're going to
actually put in the kubernetes key so
that's going to be sudo curl dash s and
then we have
long url which is https
packages.cloudgoogle.com apt doc apt
key dot gpg
sudo
apt-key there we go and click my typo
there
okay now we have to go ahead and change
permissions of like folder so we do that
with sudo chmod 777 slash etc
apt
sources.list.d all right we're good okay
now you want to go ahead and open up
your text editor and we're going to make
um an actual edit
and we're going to create a simple file
and so what we're going to type in is
the the following command db http
apt
dot kubernetes dot io slash kubernetes
xenial
main and we're going to save this file
in the etc folder and then look for and
then a apt which is going to be down a
little bit and there we have it and
we're going to save it in the
apt-get updates and we're going to name
this file as
kubernetes dot list and we'll save that
and then we can close out the notepad
and go back to the terminal window and
let's look and see if there are any
updates again so we're gonna go ahead
and run apt-get update and it's gonna
run any updates from what we've created
and we want to check what's in the
folder and so we do
cat slash accept
etc
apt sources.this dot d slash kubernetes
dot list and there we are it shows what
we have in that text file and so we're
going to go ahead and we're going to uh
install uh cubelet cubic cubic 2
again but first we're going to have to
initialize
and so we're going to go ahead and use
sudo swap
dash hyphen a and now we're going to
initialize the master node and we're
going to do that with sudo cube
adm in it and this will take a few
minutes for it to initialize
all right so that's all done all right
so we're going to deploy the pod to a
network and we have two commands that
we're going to use we use sudo cube
cube ctl apply and then we have a long
pathway to type out which is dash f
https raw githubs
content.com courios final master
documentation cube dash final dot yml
what we we have to do is we have to
actually go ahead and deploy the nodes
first so we're going to do that by
creating
mkdi
p and then we have um dollar sign home
dash dot cube we'll create that new
directory and sudo cp dash i and then
the path will be
etc
slash kubernetes admin dot conf and then
dollar sign home slash dot cube dot
slash config
and then final one will be
sudo
chown dollar
[Music]
all right now we're going to go ahead
and deploy and uh let's see uh oh yeah i
think i have a typo in my command here
yep oh yeah i did have a typo and so um
i've got that incorrect now so
documentation is actually spelled with a
t not an s and then we're going to go
ahead and we're going to put in the next
line which is pseudo cubic uh cube ctl
apply uh
dash f and then we're just going to
change a little bit of the
actual link here and that runs great and
now we want to be able to see all of the
parts that we have in our network and so
we're going to do that by
writing the command sudo qbec c tcl uh
get pods dash all dash dash name spaces
and it should list all of our pods we
only have one
there we are there's all of our content
now we're going to so there's only one
node so let's see what we have here so
we can use the command sudo you know
cubic tl get nodes there we are just one
node so our final step is to actually go
ahead and deploy a service and so what
we're going to go ahead is deploy the
nginx service and we're going to do that
with the command sudo cubex ctl run dash
dash image equals nginx and we're going
to put this into port 80 so it's going
to be nginx
app dash dash port equals 80
environment emd equals uh ubun cone open
quotes so domain equals cluster close
quotes
and we're going to write one more
command which is sudo cube ctl expose
deployment nginx dash app dash dash port
equals 80
name equals nginx
http and once we've done this we'll be
able to then run the command to actually
see our services and there'll be quite a
few of them
and our final command is sudo docker ps
dash a
and we have quite a lot of lists quite a
lot of services listed so there you are
that's the instructions on how to get
docker up and running and uh with some
basic commands um it it's worth going
through a few times to
get right
but once you actually have um the
kubernetes environment up and running
and managing your docker environment in
containers it's extremely powerful
welcome to kubernetes architecture from
simply land we're going to take a deep
dive into the kubernetes architecture if
you're new to kubernetes we already have
an introduction that goes and provides
an overview of kubernetes and we have
the link below so you can go straight to
that if you want to have a refresher
otherwise hang around and join us in
this presentation and if you want to see
more of these videos hit the subscribe
button and if you want to get notified
hit the notification bell and every time
we post up a new video you'll get the
notification right onto your phone or on
your desktop that the new video has been
uploaded and as always if you have any
questions please post them in the
comments below we do read the questions
and we try to respond to all of them as
quickly as we can with that said let's
jump into kubernetes architecture so
we're going to break out the
presentation into the following areas
we're going to cover what kubernetes is
and why you want to be using it we're
going to introduce the actual
architecture and provide an overview of
how it contains the containers and the
other components that you'd have within
the architecture we'll also compare
kubernetes with docker swarm and one of
the things that you hear with kubernetes
almost in the same breath as darker and
we have to be careful not to confuse
docker from a container point of view
and docker swarm which is a container
management tool and kubernetes is also a
container management tool so compare the
two of those and then we'll look at the
hardware and software components and
then finally do a deep dive into the
architecture of kubernetes and provide a
case study of where kubernetes has been
used successfully in the past so let's
jump into this so what actually is
kubernetes so kubernetes is a tool that
was designed to actually help manage and
contain large groups of containers it
was developed originally uh by google
out of the google borg solution and then
open source by google the actual
environment allows you to manage large
groups of containers so if you're a
developer in devops and you're working
with docker then you're used to the
concept of a container and you'll also
know that containers and cloud
technologies tend to be almost breathed
in the same breath so the work that
you're doing with kubernetes is to be
able to manage large groups of
containers inside of the cloud the thing
that's great about working with
kubernetes is that it is incredibly
flexible and allows you to have
incredibly complex applications run
efficient efficiently so let's step into
why you'd want to use kubernetes so a
couple of key points kubernetes itself
is an open source solution originally
developed by google but it is available
on most cloud platforms today so aws
google cloud microsoft azure all of them
support kubernetes and what you'll find
is as you're setting up your
infrastructure particularly if you're
using containers you'll see that the
support for kubernetes is floated up
very very efficiently and effectively by
all three vendors it's extremely um
useful for being able to manage large
modular environments and that's really
kind of the s i think one of the big
benefits of kubernetes is its modularity
is that it really breaks down uh
containers into their smaller parts and
once you do that it becomes much more
efficient for you as an administrator to
be able to manage that entire entire
environment the reproductibility of
kubernetes is extremely high you can
build up infrastructures very quickly
and have them being able to manage and
have containers coming on and off and
killed and created to be able to help
low balance your entire environment and
so again you know we keep talking about
containers but that's really what
kubernetes is all about it's being able
to manage your applications that are
managed through containers and being
able to do that in a virtualized
infrastructure and the thing that's also
really good with kubernetes is it's
really easy to deploy solutions you just
have to use a simple curl call and you
can actually push out your kubernetes
infrastructure so let's have an overview
of the kubernetes architecture so
kubernetes is really broken up into
three key areas you have your
workstation where you develop your
commands and you push out those commands
to your master and the master is
comprised of
four key areas um which essentially
control all of your nodes and and the
node contains multiple pods and each pod
has your docker container built into it
so consider that you could have a really
almost an infinite number of pods sorry
infinite number of nodes are being
managed
by the master environment so you have
your cluster which is a collection of
servers
and you have the master which is really
components that control and schedule uh
the activities of your network and then
you have the node which actually hosts
the actual docker virtual machine itself
um and be able to actually control and
communicate back to the master the
health of that pod and we'll get into
more detail in the architecture later in
the presentation so
you know you keep hearing me talk about
containers but they really are the
center of the work that you're doing
with
kubernetes and can the concept around
kubernetes and containers
um
so the solution to this is the container
so uh you can think of containers as
that natural evolution from you know uh
15 20 years ago you would have written
your code and posted it to a data center
and more recently you probably post your
code to a virtual machine and then move
the virtual machine and now you actually
just work directly into a container and
everything is self-contained and can be
pushed out to your
environment and the thing that's great
about containers they're they're
isolated environments very easy for
developers to work in them but it's also
really easy for
operations teams to be able to move a
container into production so let's kind
of step and back and look at a competing
product to kubernetes which is docker
swarm now one of the things that we have
to remember is that docker um containers
which are extremely popular um built by
the company docker and made open source
and docker actually has other products
one of those other products is docker
swarm and docker swarm is a tool that
allows you to be able to manage multiple
containers so if we look at some of the
uh the benefits of using docker swarm
versus kubernetes and one of the things
that you'll find is that both tools have
strengths and weaknesses but it's really
good that they're both out there because
it helps keep it really kind of
justifies the importance of having these
kind of tools so kubernetes was designed
originally from the ground up to be auto
scaling whereas docker swarm isn't the
load balancing is automatic on docker
swan whereas with kubernetes you have to
manually configure load balancing across
your nodes the installation for docker
swarm is really fast and easy i mean you
can be up and running within minutes a
kubernetes takes a little bit more time
is a little bit more complicated
eventually you'll get there um i mean
it's not like it's going to take you
days and weeks but it's it is a tool
that's when you compare the two docker
swarms much easier to get up and running
now what's interesting is that
kubernetes is incredibly scalable and
it's you know that's its real strength
is its ability to have strong clusters
whereas with docker swarm its cluster
stream isn't um as strong when compared
to kubernetes now you compare it to
anything else on the market it's really
good um so this is kind of a splitting
hairs kind of comparison but kubernetes
really does have the advantage here if
you're looking at the two compared to
each other for scalability i mean
kubernetes was designed for by google to
scale up and support uh google cloud
network infrastructure they uh both
allow you to be able to share um storage
volumes with docker you can actually do
it with any container uh with um that is
managed by the docker swamp whereas with
kubernetes it manages the storage with
the pods and a product can have multiple
containers within it but you can't take
it down to the level of the container
interestingly uh kubernetes does have a
graphical user interface um for being
able to control and manage uh the
environment the reality however is that
you're likely to be using terminal to
actually make the controls and commands
to control your
either docker swarm or kubernetes
environment um it's great that it has a
gui and to get you started but once
you're up and running you're going to be
using terminal window for those fast
quick administrative controls that you
need to make so let's look at the
hardware components for
kubernetes so and what's interesting is
that kubernetes is extremely light of
all the systems that we're looking at is
extremely lightweight um it's um allows
you to have if you compare it to like a
virtual machine which is very heavy you
know
kubernetes is extremely lightweight and
hardly uses any resources at all
interesting enough though is that if you
are looking at the usage of cpu it's
better to actually take it for
the cluster as a whole rather than
individual nodes because the nodes will
actually combine together to give you
that whole compute power again this is
why kubernetes works really well in the
cloud where you can do that kind of
activity rather than if you're running
in your own data center um so you can
have persistent volumes such as a local
ssd
or you can actually attach to a cloud
data storage again kubernetes is really
designed for the cloud i would encourage
you to use cloud storage wherever
possible rather than relying on physical
storage uh the reason being is that if
you connect to cloud storage and you
need to flex your your storage the cloud
will do that for you i mean that's just
an inherent part of why you'd have cloud
storage whereas if you're connecting to
physical storage you're always
restricted to the limitations of the
physical hardware so let's kind of pivot
and look at the software components as
compared to the hardware components so
the main part of the
components is the actual container and
all of the software running in the
container runs on linux so if you um
have docker installed as a developer on
your machine it's actually running
inside of linux and that's what makes it
so lightweight and really one of the
things that you'll find is that most
data centers and cloud providers now are
running predominantly on blending
inside of the um the container itself is
then managed inside of a pot and the pod
is really just a group of containers
bundled together and
the kubernetes scheduler and proxy
server then actually manage what um how
the pods are actually pushed out uh into
your kubernetes environment the uh the
bots themselves can actually then share
resources both networking and storage so
the pods aren't um pushed out manually
they're actually managed through a layer
of abstraction and part of their
deployment and and this is the strength
of kubernetes you use um to find your
infrastructure and then kubernetes will
then manage it for you and there isn't
that problem of
manual management of pods if you have to
manage the deployment of them and you
that's simply taken away and it's
completely automated and the the final
area of software services is on ingress
and this is really the secure way of
being able to have communication from
outside of the cluster and passing of
information into that cluster and again
this is done securely through ssl layers
and allows you to ensure that security
is at the center of the work that you
have within your kubernetes environment
so let's dive now into the actual
architecture before we start looking at
a use case of how kubernetes is being
employed so kubernetes again is um we
looked at this uh diagram at the
beginning of the presentation and there
are really three key areas there's the
workstation where you develop your
commands and then you have your master
environment which uh controls the uh
scheduling the communication um and the
actual um commands that you have created
and pushes those out and manages the
health of your entire node network and
each node has various pods so we they
break this down so the master node is
the most vital component and with the
master uh you have four key controls you
have etc
controller manager scheduler and api
server the cluster store etc this
actually measures the details and values
that you've developed on your local
workstation um and then we'll work with
the out the control schedule and api
server to communicate that out those
instructions of how your infrastructure
should look like to your entire network
uh the control manager is really an api
server and again um this is all about
security so we use restful apis which
can be packaged in ssl to communicate
back and forth um across your
pods and the master and indeed the
services within each of them as well uh
so um at every single layer of
abstraction uh the communication is
secure uh the schedule as the name would
imply really schedules uh when tasks get
sent out to the actual nodes themselves
the nodes themselves are are done nodes
they just have uh the applications um
running on them the master in the scheme
is really doing all of the work uh to
make sure that your entire network is
running um efficiently and then you have
the api server which has your rest
commands and the communication and back
and forth across your networks that is
secure and efficient so your node
environment is where all the work that
you do with your containers gets pushed
out too so
a work is really a it's a combination of
containers and each container will then
logically run together on that node so
you'd have a collection of containers uh
on a node that all make logical sense to
have together uh within each node um you
have docker and this is your isolated
environment for running your container
uh you have your kubelet which is a
service for conveying information back
and forth um to the service about the
actual health of the kubernetes node
itself and then finally you have the
proxy server and the proxy server is
able to manage the nodes the volumes the
the creation of new containers um and
actually helps pass the communicate the
health of the container back up to the
master to see whether or not the
containers should be either killed stop
started or
updated so finally let's look and see
where kubernetes is being used by other
companies so you know kubernetes is
being used by a lot of companies and
they're really using it to help manage
complex existing systems so that they
can have uh greater performance and with
the end goal of being able to delight
the customer increase value to the
customer and enhance increased value and
revenue into the organization so an
example of this is a company called
blackrock where they actually went
through the process of implementing
kubernetes uh so they
so blackrock had a challenge where they
needed to be able to have much more
dynamic access to their resources uh
they were running complex installations
on people's desktops and it was just
really really difficult to be able to
manage their entire infrastructure so
they actually went and pivoted to using
kubernetes and this allowed them to be
able to be much more scalable and
expansive in the in the management of
their infrastructure and as you can
imagine uh kubernetes was then hooked
into their entire existing system and
has really become a key part of the
success that blackrock is now
experiencing of a very stable
infrastructure um and the bottom line is
that blackrock is now able to have
confidence in their infrastructure and
be able to give that confidence
as back to their customers through the
implementation and more rapid deployment
of additional features and services and
i welcome you to this short tutorial and
demo on kubernetes kubernetes specific
to aws cloud platform so what's a part
of this tutorial and demo what's in
store for you at offset i would like to
cover the basics of orchestration tools
as most of you would know kubernetes is
one of the most popular orchestration
tools in recent times specifically for
applications which are cloud native and
deployed on some or the other types of
containers but what are these
organization tools why would one need to
use orchestration tools what are the
facilities or features provided by these
orchestration tools that's the first
thing that i'm going to cover after that
i will pick two orchestration tools
specific to container management docker
swarm versus kubernetes i am going to
compare them with regard to the features
that they provide the use cases that
they cover what facilities that they
provide and when to use what after that
i will get into a little bit details of
the kuvernez architecture what exactly
is required for setting up a kubernetes
cluster what runs in a control plane or
a master node what runs as a part of the
worker node after that i will end the
tutorial by running you through a demo
by setting up a three node kubernetes
cluster on aws platform i will use
something called as cops which is one of
the admin tools for setting up
production grade kubernetes cluster so i
will use this to set up a three node
cluster on aws all right now that we set
the context right let me get started so
what are orchestration tools
the application development and the
lifecycle management from the time the
application is developed connecting the
source code to your continuous
integration to testing them all along
your development process and eventually
moving it down to production managing
your production servers the dependencies
that your software has
the requirement that it has in terms of
the hardware the features of fault
tolerance self-healing capabilities auto
scaling all this has complicated over
the last few years as a part of devops
one thing that everyone is interested in
is managing all this application
dependency or lifecycle management using
some or the other kind of a tool so
that's where these orchestration tools
have become very very popular so what
kind of features that they provide is
you'll have to just let them know what
are the kinds of tool sets that is
required what are the fault tolerance
mechanisms that it has to be adopted to
what kind of a self-healing capabilities
that application will have to need and
if at all there is any auto scaling
features that is required if at all you
can bake in all these specific
parameters into your tool your
organization tool becomes a one-stop
shop for all your deployment and
configuration management needs that's
where this orchestration tools have
become a very very popular and relevant
specifically these days when people are
more and more interested in adopting
devops practices all right so having
said that about orchestration tools
let's concentrate on two of these
orchestration tools specifically for
container management docker swamp and
kubernetes many of the applications that
are written for these kind of containers
are called or kind of fall into a
category of cloud native where the
application need not know much about the
underlying infrastructure or the
platform where these applications are
running so these two along with apache
missions there are many other container
management systems but i'm going to pick
docker swarm and kubernetes for
comparing the features that is provided
by these two frameworks for the sake of
comparison i picked up docker swarm and
kubuntes just because of the reason that
both of them operate in the space of
container management they do something
very very similar to containers that's
the similarity that exists between these
two orchestration tools however there's
a big difference that exists when it
comes to the types of containers that
both of them cater to and also the
capacity of workloads they can be used
for docker swarm is a cluster management
solution that is provided by docker
container docker is one of the very very
popular containers of recent times and
in case you have your applications that
is totally powered by only docker
containers if you have a need where you
want to run a cluster of servers which
are running only docker containers
docker swarm should be your choice for
your orchestration tool kubernetes on
the other hand can cater to any other
types of containers other than docker
and including docker as well so in case
you have your applications which have
got docker in them which have got rkt in
them which they have got alex in them or
any other type of container kubernetes
should be your choice of orchestration
too a docker swarm can manage up to 40
50 or 60 max
nodes so in case your application is
totally written in docker containers and
the load or the expected cluster size is
about 50-60 nodes docker swarm should be
your choice of orchestration tool on the
other hand kubernetes is something that
was open sourced by google and the kind
of the scale of operations that
communities can cater to is google scale
so if in case your applications are more
than a thousand nodes that is where
kubernetes comes into play that's the
big difference that exists between
docker swarm and communities putting
those differences aside let me compare
docker swarm and kubernetes based upon
other features which are similar in
nature the first and important feature
that kubernetes provides is something
called as auto scaling if at all the
load on your cluster is too high an
application is experiencing more load so
kubernetes can add new nodes to your
cluster of course you'll have to
configure kubernetes in order to have
those capabilities where it can spin up
new vms or new nodes if at all you do
that configuration correctly kubernetes
has got the capacity or it has got the
feature where it can bring up a new node
and add it to the cluster on the fly
based upon the load that exists at that
moment on similar lines if at all the
load is not too high it can identify a
few of those nodes which have got less
number of replicas or less number of
application containers running on it it
can move them to some other node and
also scale down by deleting few nodes
from your cluster so that is the
powerfulness of auto scaling which is
provided by kubernetes and this
unfortunately does not exist in docker
swarm the other feature of load
balancing specifically application node
balancing so docker swarm gives you an
application level auto load balancing
however kubernetes gives you the
flexibility of manually configuring any
other type of load balancer of your
choice for application load balancing
installation as i mentioned earlier
docker swarm is a loose cluster of
containers which are running on nodes it
is very easy to spin up a new node and
then connect them to a swarm and this
can be done in a very very loosely
coupled way where you can create swarms
of your choice notes are allowed to
connect to swarms and quit or leave the
swamps on the fly so in and all the
installation is pretty easy and fast
kubernetes on the other hand the
configuration of kubernetes the way to
spin up a big cluster specifying the
size of the node how many masternodes
how many config planes that you want how
many nodes that you want it's a pretty
tough thing to bring up a kubernetes
scalability kubernetes strength is very
very strong they are very tightly
coupled and even they have the
capability where on the cluster size
things or the nodes can be increased on
the fly based upon the requirement on a
darker swarm the cluster strength is
weak as compared to cobra days worker
notes can be added to a swarm worker
notes can be asked to leave us form or
can be taken out of a swarm based upon
the requirement so this is kind of a
loosely coupled architecture for docker
swarm while coverage is the cluster is
very tightly coupled since docker swarm
runs only docker containers containers
find it very easy to share data and lot
of other things with each other because
they all have the same signature they
are all from the same family so it's
very easy for them to share not just
volumes but lot of other things however
for kubernetes since it manages
containers of different types if your
application has to share some data
across different containers there's a
little bit of a complexity in how you
would want your containers to share data
also uh when it comes to kubernetes
kubernetes groups containers in
something called as pods while a pod can
have either one container that's the
preferred choice or multiple containers
and the idea of pod is like each part
can run in any other node it's not
guaranteed that you would want to have
two or three parts to be running on the
same node that makes data sharing a
little bit of a different thing compared
to docker's form
gui so there's not a good enough ui tool
in docker's form at least the ce edition
of it which will allow you to get to
know what is running on your containers
what is the size of the containers what
is the volume of the containers and all
that stuff there are some free and open
source tools like proteiner which gives
you a good visibility into your running
docker containers however there's
nothing at a swarm level that is
provided by docker kubernetes gives you
an out of the box dashboard which is
easy to configure and set up you can
also club it with some metrics services
and you can also get information about
the size of the cluster that is running
what is the load on the nodes and stuff
like that all this across your cluster
in a very beautiful dashboard
perspective so that way um this is
little bit of a good ui for kubernetes
while for docker's form there isn't
anything that is provided out of the box
let me spend some time in explaining a
little bit about the kubernetes
architecture what comprises of the
kubernetes cluster what resides in a
master or a control plane and what
resides in a worker node this is a very
high level depiction of a kubernetes
cluster so this is the master node which
has got something called as a cluster
store a controller a scheduler component
and an epa server and these are the
bunch of nodes that are connected or
administered by the master node the
master node can be 1 3 5 typically an
odd number this is as per the typical
cluster management thing where you would
need the master nodes to be in odd
numbers so that whenever there's any
contention in terms of what needs to be
deployed where or where to give the job
to whom and stuff like that all the
masters would cast their vote and they
would decide on the outcome so that's
the master node and there are a bunch of
nodes which can be connected and
administered by the master node cubicctl
or the command from using which anybody
can assign some workloads to the cluster
can also be run either on the same node
or on a separate node so cubectl is the
command line tool that we will be
installing and using in order to fire up
our commands to our cluster so if at all
i have to put up a job on our cluster if
i have to give out any specific commands
to my cluster all this is done using
cuba ctl there's a bunch of rest apis
which is used by cuba ctl and cubectl
will talk to the api server and fire up
the commands specific to my cluster what
runs in the master node master node
without saying it's the most important
component of any of the cluster if at
all you're running a cluster with only
one master node if your master node goes
down there's no other way that you know
you can or any user can talk to the
different nodes in the cluster so master
node is the most vital component
responsible for the complete kubernetes
cluster there's always one node that
should be running as a master node
that's the bare minimum requirement for
your cluster so what are the other
components in the master node the most
important one is called etcd so this is
nothing but a data store a value of key
value pair which is stored which
contains all information about your
cluster so all the configuration details
which
node is up which worker node is down all
this information is stored in the
cluster store so all the managers would
access this cluster store before they go
ahead and decide any other work item or
anything else that has to be done
specific to your cluster what's in the
controller as the name says controller
is something it's like a daemon server
that is running in a continuous loop all
the time it is responsible for
controlling the set of replicas the kind
of
workloads that is running based upon the
configuration that the user has set in
so if at all if you are aware of
something called as replication
controllers endpoint controllers
namespace controllers all these
controllers are managed by the
controller component if any user asked
for some three replicas of a particular
pod or a service to be running and if at
all any of the nodes goes down or the
part goes down for whatsoever reason the
controller is the one who wakes up and
assigns this particular job or the part
to some other available node by looking
up for the details using in the cluster
store that's the importance of the
control manager or the controller the
scheduler the scheduler assigns the
tasks based upon whoever is asked for
any job to be scheduled based upon a
time frame or based upon some criteria
it also tracks the working load as to
what what exactly is the load who is
running what and in the cluster and
places the workload on whoever is the
available resource at that time all
right epa server this is one other
important component in in our kubernetes
cluster where how would the end user
deploy or give out any sort of a
workload onto your cluster all the
requests come to the api server so this
is an entry point for all your um
requests that come into your cluster
anybody wants to deploy something
anybody want to scale up a controller
anybody who wants to bring down a few
services anybody wants to put in a
service all this will have to come in as
a part of a rest um api endpoint and api
server is the enter point in case you
don't want uh you know somebody to
access your cluster in case you want
only specific people or a specific users
to be running some specific workloads
you can set all those role-based access
control for this apa server so this is
the entry point for anyone who wants to
submit any job to your cluster so that's
a quick overview about the master node
what what are the important components
of a master node now let's go over to
what runs in a worker or a slave node as
i mentioned earlier slave nodes are
something where the job that is
submitted to your cluster is eventually
run as a board as a service as a
container so in kubernetes world there
is something called as a pod a pod is
nothing but a combination of a container
it is a wrapper around your running
containers so slave nodes or the worker
nodes typically run these parts so that
is where the whole workload typically
gets run but there are a bunch of other
components in the in the node which also
manages what runs in the pod who has to
have access to the pod what is the state
of the pod is it in a running state is
it going down for some reason and all
the stuff so let's quickly go over those
components that is there in the slave
node the most important component in my
opinion that should be on the on the
node should be the container runtime as
i mentioned earlier kubernetes can run
any different types of containers not
just docker so in case you want to have
a node which wants to have docker
running on it rkt running or lkc running
on it or any other container environment
that is running on it you have to ensure
that the specific container runtime
environment is available on that
specific node so that whenever a job is
submitted description of what needs to
be run as a part of the pod what should
be the image with it should be powered
and what kind of a container to spin up
so that's what you know when the job is
finally assigned to this particular node
it would definitely need a container
runtime to be up and running so that
exists only if at all the container
runtime is installed and running on your
kubernetes worker node okay now that we
know what our kubernetes node can run
how would somebody assign a job to our
node that is using something called as a
cubelet as the name says cubelet or
cubelet is a small subset which talks to
the cube api server so any node which
has to run any kind of a pod all these
instructions are passed around by the
qbps server to the cubelet and cubelet
is capable of processing whatever job
that is assigned to it and ensuring that
so many parts and so many services are
spun up based upon the requirement the
last component that exists in the worker
node is the cube proxy or kubernetes
proxy this plays a very very important
role acting as a load balancer and a
network proxy so what typically happens
is whenever the pods are running in
nodes the parts can be typically running
in any node there is no um
affinity towards any node on which these
parts are running because pods or
containers are something called as
ephemeral they can run anywhere so how
would somebody reach out to these
applications that is running in some pod
which is running in one container now
and running in probably another
container another node altogether
tomorrow so that is where your
kubernetes proxy contains a picture and
this component will ensure that any
container that is spun up or any pod
that is spun up it keeps track of all
these parts and kind of connects the end
points or acts like a dns server so that
it knows when somebody is trying to
reach out to this particular service
which is the part on which the service
is typically running so that plays a
very very important role by acting as a
load balancer and a network proxy now
that at a very high level we know what
are all the components that make up of
our kubuntu's cluster let's go ahead and
create a small cluster and spin up this
cluster on aws platform finally we get
to the demo section of my tutorial now
that you guys are aware as to what is
kubernetes what is the use of kubernetes
you also know at a very very high level
what are the components of a cluster
what is a master node or a control plane
what are the components of a master node
and what should be existing in a worker
node you're probably thinking that it's
maybe pretty hard to kind of set this up
so let me demystify that by running you
with a quick demo of how to set up a
simple pre-node kubernetes cluster using
a tool called cops and i will be doing
this whole setup on my aws cloud okay so
what is cops cops is nothing but a
simple tool this is an admin tool that
allows you to bring up production grade
kubernetes environments as i said
setting up a kubernetes cluster on a
bare metal is little challenging so that
is why i would use something called as a
cops and i will use this on my cluster
which i'll spin up on my aws instance so
i have an aws account and what i'll do
first is i will first spin up an ec2
server i will power this with one of the
linux amis and i will install cops on it
now this will be my starting point from
where i'm going to trigger running up a
big cluster in our case i'll try to keep
it little small i don't want too many
nodes in my cluster i'm going to have
one master node and two worker nodes
this whole operation would be done
programmatically by installing this cops
admin tool so as you may know aws is
little hard for me to programmatically
run other components or rather bring up
servers it's not pretty simple so what i
would do is i will create an iam rule
which will attach to my ec2 server so
that my ec2 server gets powered with all
the required role so that it can go
ahead and spin up cluster based upon my
configuration that i'm going to specify
all right so once i have my cluster set
up i will also install cuba ctl which
you would probably know by now is
nothing but a command line utility using
which i can kind of connect to my
cluster give it some jobs put some parts
and stuff like that so i will use cube
ctl i will also have a pair of ssh keys
so that from this machine i would be
able to successfully get onto the master
node and submit jobs on my behalf so let
me begin by first logging into my aws
account all the steps that i will be
following to bring up my aws cluster
kubernetes cluster will be documented
and i'll be sharing you this document in
a github repository so that in case
anybody wants to try you'll be more than
happy to find all the required
instructions in one place okay now the
first thing that i would need is to
launch an aws ec2 instance now this is
an instance where i'm going to install
cops and i will use it as a base server
from where i'm going to find some
commands which will bring up my
kubernetes cluster so let me login to my
aws account and
let me stick to one particular region
and let me bring up some one ec2
instance all right so let me launch my
instance let me choose um
doesn't matter in the ways but in case
you want to try it on your free tire i
would recommend choose free tire only
and choose an ami of your choice let me
choose
this instance i will make it t2 micro
that is good for me configuration
instance details all right i don't want
to change anything here that looks good
maybe i will change this 30 gig that's
good for me let me add a tag to my
instance i will name this as my cops
server all right i would need a bunch of
posts to be opened up so what i'll do is
i'll create a new security group
called open to
the word i would not recommend that you
do this since i don't want to it will
take a long time for me to specifically
to pick and choose
the ports that has to be open for
running my cluster i don't want to do
that i will open up all the http and
https ports so that it's quicker so i
will say all tcp i would say from
anywhere just to be on the safer side
also open http and https and i will make
this anywhere and anywhere this is good
for me i will say review and launch all
right so i chose a t2 micro instance
just for the sake of easiness i've
opened up all the ports and um the
instant details are you've seen what is
that i've chosen all right now important
part is like i would need a keyboard i
need to create a new keypad i will call
this as simply learn keys i will
download this
keypair and then i will launch the
instance it will take some time for my
ec2 instance to come up in the meanwhile
what i'll do is i will convert i have
this pen file which is the pair of keys
ssh keys with which i need to log into
my ec2 instance so i'll need to convert
this because i'm trying to connect from
my windows box i would need to convert
this into a ppk file so i have puttygen
i'm going to load my set of keys here
and convert that key into a ppk key all
right open all right i would say save
save private key yes i would say simply
learn or simply learn private private
key and save this here and that that's
all so this is my public key which is
the pem file and this is my apk or my
private key now using the private key i
will log into my ec2 instance okay now
my ec2 instance is up and running it is
running in this ohio region and this is
the ip address of my public ipads of my
machine so let me connect to it so i use
a moba x term which is nothing but an
ssh emulator you can use putty or any of
these sessions which allow you to do an
ssh this is my ip address of my machine
and since i've spun up an amazon ami the
user this is the default user i would
need to specify the private keys for my
session and this is the private key for
my session say okay i am in my
amazon ec2 instance so let me look at
what are the other things that i need to
do all right so as i said i just brought
up my ec2 instance but i would need my
ec2 instance to
run few things on my behalf so that it
can spin up easy to other ec2 instances
it can also talk to an s3 bucket where
i'm going to store the instant state of
my kubernetes cluster also some sort of
an auto scaling group because i want to
spin up more and more instances i also
want to have a private hosted zone using
my route 53 so i would need my ec2
instance to have all these sort of
permissions for my server so what i
would do is i will go and create a
permission a rule in the ec2 rather in
the aws im role and i will attach this
im role to my ec2 instance all right so
let me go to my iam which is nothing but
the identity and access management i
will create a rule called as possibly
cop's role i will create a role this
role will be used by my ec2 so i'm going
to click on ec2 and say next permissions
they would need a lot of permissions uh
specific permissions to be very honest
and the permissions are all listed out
here s3 ec2 and all this stuff just to
keep it pretty simple what i would do is
i'll create a role with the
administrative access all right so i
don't want any tags i'm going to review
i'll create a role name i will say cubs
role for ec2 all right so i'm going to
create a rule which has got
administrative access rules i'm going to
create a role so this would ensure that
my ec2 instance from which i'm going to
run my cluster would have all the
prerequisite permissions so that it can
go and spin up instances talk to s3
buckets and all that stuff all right now
let us have our running instance get
powered by this role so i will connect
this role to my running instance all
right so this is my
ec2 instant that is running
action attach attach attach attach
replace im rolls so there is no rule as
of now i would want my cops roll for
easy this row that i created so i want
this new roll to be assigned to my ec2
all right great now my ec2 instance
which is my cop server has got all the
required permissions so that he can
create a cluster on my behalf great now
before this let me do a sudo m update
iphone y so that any of the because this
is a newly provisioned vm i just want to
ensure that all my library system
libraries are all updated so that when i
do install cop and cube ctl and all
those things none of them will fail
because of some dependency or package
issues so i'm just running a sudo update
iphone y so that all the libraries are
updated okay looks like it is done so
let me go ahead and install cops cubs is
a pretty simple installation it is
available in a particular location i
have to just copy this and ensure that i
do a curl and i install this particular
stuff all right so it is fetching uh the
cops tool it's installing for me once it
is copied down let me change the mode so
that i can execute it and then also let
me move it to my user local bin so that
it is available for me in my path okay
that's pretty much the corpse
installation let me also do one other
thing let me install something called as
cuba ctl so this is what would be you
know a tool using which i'm going to be
firing my uh commands to my kubernetes
cluster once it comes up right this is a
pretty smaller executable so
ctl all right so i have cubicctl as well
as cops installed on my ec2 server now
okay now what i'll do next is i'm going
to create an s3 bucket in aws so that
the equipment is a cluster state is
persisted in this bucket so let me
create a simple bucket with this name s3
bucket with this name so let me go to s3
and let me create a simple bucket with
this name i will just say create a
bucket okay so the simply
learn.kubernetes is the bucket that i
created so this bucket will store all
information about my cluster let me now
uh go and create a dns entry or a dns
zone or aws route 53 hosted zone for my
cluster so this is required so that you
know i can give a cluster name for my
kubernetes cluster that i'm coming up so
i will create a private hosted zone and
possibility possibly i will call this as
simply learn dot in so this will be my
name of my private hosted zone in case
you already have any other public hosted
zones in your name you can always put a
route 53 hosted zone specific for your
domain name since i don't have anyone
i'm just going to create a simple
private hosted zone so let me head down
to route
53 click on any of these and you'll get
these hosted zones out here so i'm going
to create a hosted zone here i'm going
to create a hosted zone click on create
hosted zone um this would be simply
learn lot in i want to create a public
no i don't want public i want a private
hostess zone and i'm going to associate
my vpc id for this hosted zone since i'm
going to try out all my exercises in the
ohio region i will associate the vpc of
the wire region for this all right so
this is the one that is specific to the
ohio region so i will say this one i'll
say create a hosted sum great now let me
come back to my ec2 box my ec2 is all
powered with whatever it needs in order
to go ahead with the installation of my
cluster only few things that i need to
take care of is that you know now that i
put a name for my cluster i also have an
s3 bucket that i've configured for my
cluster i will have to ensure that i
need to put in these two configurations
as a part of my cluster building
activity so i will open my bash rc file
and i'm going to export these two
variables if at all you remember well
these two variables are nothing but the
cluster name which is nothing but the
public uh sorry the private hosted zone
that i created and the s3 bucket where
i'm going to create or rather i'm going
to store my cluster state so let me copy
these two and open up my
bash rc file all right so i will just
add these two and copy these add export
them out as my ah variable i'm going to
save this here now let me ensure that
this gets picked up all right i've got
these two that have configured and i
also ensure that these environment
variables are set now let me create a
pair of ssh keys this is to ensure that
i can log into the box that i'm going to
be provisioning as a part of my cluster
ssh hyphen keygen i don't want to give
any parameters let it go to the home
directory with the default name and
without any passphrase all right so i
created a bunch of my keypair now i'm
all set to go ahead and run my cops now
cops will ensure that this will take
some time for the cluster to come up but
this is exactly how i would define my
corpse command how do i have copied here
so corpse create cluster the state of
the
cluster will be stored in this
particular variable which is what i have
exported out the number of node count is
two node count is the worker node count
if at all i don't specify configuration
for specifying the master or the control
pane as well if i don't specify that the
default one is one so i'm going to
create
one primary or the master node and two
uh worker nodes uh size of my master
node size of the worker nodes uh what
are the zones where i want this to be
created and where do i store the cluster
information and uh okay i've already
added this master account this is
actually not required but this is the
command that i'm going to fire off so
that i bring up my cluster all right
that went off uh very fast but um this
actually did not create a cluster it is
just the definition of a cluster and
that's why this came out very fast
now that everything looks good with
whatever configuration that i specified
now let me go ahead and create the
cluster by saying corpse update cluster
hyphen f1 yes now this will take some
time a good five to ten minutes for it
to because this will actually start
provisioning the servers and as i
mentioned earlier based upon my
configuration i'm going to come up with
one master server and uh two nodes or
the worker nodes all right so this is
the command for me to validate the
cluster and i'm going to try it out
first i'm pretty sure that it will fail
because all my servers are not up yet it
is taking some time the validation
everything failed but let me try to look
at my ec2 instances and
see how many servers do i have running
as of now if you see i had only one
server that i had started which was my
cop server and automatically the other
three instances one is called node start
simply not in this these two are the
nodes and this is the master node so
these three got automatically
provisioned by the cops command that i
ran all right so this may take a while
for it to get validated a good 5 to 10
minutes so what i'll do is i'll pause
the video now and i'll come back once
the server the cluster is up and running
it's been a good uh eight to nine
minutes since i started my cluster so
let me validate now okay seems good so
there's a master node uh minimum one max
one some nodes which are nothing but the
slave nodes or the worker nodes there
are two of them due to micro uh subnet
so my clusters seem to be up and running
and my cluster name is simplylearn.n so
what i would want to do is now let me
just log into the master and see if i
can run some parts so let me get back to
my install installation steps here the
validation cluster is done so let me log
into my since my cluster name is simply
none dot and this is the way to log into
my box so let me get into my box so if
you see here this is the host name of
the machine that i'm currently in if you
see this this is nothing but our this
cop server this is now from here i'm
trying to get into the master box all
right so if you see the ip address has
changed i was in a different box i'm in
a different box now if i see host name
you'll find a different host name so
this is 153 which is nothing but the
master node yep it's 153 this is the
particular host so i'm getting into this
machine now so i started the cluster
from my cop server here it ran and
brought up three nodes so i'm actually
getting into my master node and see if i
can run some parts on it all right so
let me try kubectl uh get cluster info
try cube ctl get nodes all right so
there are three nodes here master node
and um one master node and two worker
nodes so let me see if i have some pods
here cubicle get pods so there's no pod
as of now so what i'll try to do is let
me just spin up a very very simple part
just to check if my connections is
everything is correct or not correct i
have a simple uh node.js application
that i've built uh and i've got a
container for that this is already
pushed to the docker i've registered is
called simply learn docker hub and the
image name that i have here is called my
node app and i will use this image to
power one of my parts that i will run so
this is the way in which i'm going to
launch my pod let me show you these
commands cube ctl run the name for my
deployment that i'm going to run hyphen
iphone image and this is the image that
is going to be powering my container so
this is simply learn docker hub forward
slash my node app hyphen f1 replicas
equal to i want two replicas to be
running and the port that i want to
expose this particular part is on eight
zero eight zero so let me run this as
soon as this is run it creates something
called as a deployment all right now let
me just say um i'm not really interested
in the deployment i'm interested in
checking if at all the parts are up and
running so i will say cube ctl get both
all right so that was pretty fast so i
have two parts that are running here
these are two replicas because i asked
for two replicas these parts are running
so i can run cube ctl describe pod
pickup all right i can pick up any of
the pod name and see what is the pod
what is the information does it contain
from what is the image that is pulling
what is the image image name id this is
actually running my pod which is
actually spinning up a container great
so far so good so in kubernetes the pods
can are ephemeral so they can be there
at any time cannot be read in time if i
need to expose my pod outside i will
have to create a service for my part so
what i'll do is i'll create a very very
simple uh service by exposing this
particular deployment
before that let me check cube cdl get
deployment so there's a deployment that
is created the deployment name is simply
run app so i will expose my deployment
simply learn app as uh yeah i'll just
expose this let me see all right i am
not specifying what type and all i don't
want to get into the complications of
what are the different types of exposing
the service and all that stuff so if i
don't specify anything ah it gives me
something closer cluster id so this is
where my pod is actually exposed so let
me just check if at all this part is up
and running i'll just try a simple curl
command curl http colon this is my
cluster ip and the port is 8080 if at
all i hit this it's actually hitting my
application and giving me whatever i put
a simple uh sys dot out kind of a thing
where i'm just printing um the container
id of whatever pod is serving uh being
sold out of so i'm actually hitting my
container and i'm getting this output
from the content so everything looks
good my content is up and running uh so
let me just go and clean it up i'll say
equip ctl uh delete deployment simply
learn app this should get rid of all the
parts that i created cube ctl get pod
all right these ports are intermediating
things let me just check cube ctl get
services there's one service i don't
want this service let me delete that
cube ctl delete service i want this all
right that sounds good so let me come
back to my host my cop server from where
i'm running so i managed to successfully
verify this part see if everything is up
and running so what i'll do is i'll just
go ahead and complete this demo by going
and
getting rid of my cluster so corpse
delete cluster hyphen f1 yes all right
so this will ensure that it will clean
up my complete cluster that i created so
i had three or four running instances if
you see that all the three are shutting
down because you know the cop server
which had cops installed on it has now
got a mandate to go ahead and shut down
and clean up the whole instances and all
those things that are created as a part
of my deployment kubernetes versus
darker but before we jump into that i
want you to hit the subscribe button so
you get notified about new content as it
gets made available and if you hit the
notification button that notification
will then pop up on your desktop as a
video is published from simplyland in
addition if you have any questions on
the topic please post them in the
comments below we read them and we do
reply to them as often as we can so with
that said let's jump into kubernetes
versus docker so let's go through a
couple of scenarios let's do one for
kubernetes and then one for docker and
we can actually go through and
understand what the problem specific
companies have actually had and how
they're able to use the two different
tools to solve them so our first one is
with bose and bose
had a
large catalog of products that kept
growing and their infrastructure had to
change so the way that they looked at
that was actually establishing two
primary goals to be able to allow their
product groups to be able to easier more
easily catch up to the scale of their
business so after going through um a
number of solutions they ended up coming
up with a solution of having kubernetes
running their iot platform as a service
inside of amazon's aws cloud service and
what you'll see with both these products
is they're very cloud friendly but here
we have um bose and kubernetes working
together with aws to be able to scale up
and meet the demands of their product
catalog and so the result is that we're
able to increase the number of
non-production deployments significantly
by taking the number of services from
being large bulky surfaces down to small
micro services being able to handle as
many as 1250
plus deployments every year an
incredible amount of time and value has
been opened through the use of
kubernetes now let's have a look at daca
and see what a similar problem that
people would have so uh the problem is
with paypal and paypal and processes
something in the region of over 200
payments per second across all of their
products and paypal doesn't just have
paypal they have braintree and venmo